foreign
welcome to this video tutorial on data
science with our 2022 full course by
simply loan R is one of the best
programming languages to learn data
science this video covers all the
crucial data science Concepts and
algorithms that will help you master
data science using r before we look at
the topics we'll be covering in this
video Let's understand the importance of
using R4 data science
data science is a field of study that
has its usage in all domains to extract
meaningful insights from large volumes
of data in order to make business
decisions
R is a powerful programming language
that has excellent statistical and
visualization capabilities
R is an open source language so you can
contribute to R make new libraries for
different functionalities edit the code
and add modifications to it it supports
amazing packages such as deployer tidier
tidy verse and H2O that make your life
easier as a data scientist
statistical models can be written with
only a few lines of code using R you can
also make interactive web applications
in R using the signee package
visualizing and presenting data in an
elegant manner is very important in
today's business CV world
R is a Powerhouse when it comes to
creating interesting graphs and visuals
our packages like ggplot plotly and
ggvis allow you to create detailed and
attractive visualizations
it also has a growing community of data
scientists and statisticians another
reason why R is so popular for data
science and analytics is because some of
the top companies across the world use R
to analyze manipulate and visualize data
as well as create predictive models
Facebook Microsoft Google JPMorgan IBM
and Uber are some of the top companies
using RFA data science now that you have
learned about the importance of using R
for data science let's look at the
agenda for today's session
so we will start by getting an
introduction to data science after that
we'll understand how to import data in r
next we will learn about data
manipulation using D player and tidier
packages
after that we learn to visualize data
using ggplot and plotly
moving further we learn about the
various algorithms used by data
scientists such as linear regression
logistic regression decision tree as
well as random Forest algorithminar
we will also learn about support Vector
machine and
hierarchical clustering algorithms
after which we'll look at time series
analysis
we will end our 2022 full course video
by understanding who is a data science
engineer and look at the data science
engineer resume so let's get started
are you one of the many who dreams of
becoming a data scientist keep watching
this video if you're passionate about
data science because we will tell you
how does it really work under the hood
Emma is a data scientist let's see how a
day in a life goes while she's working
on data science project well it is very
important to understand the business
problem first in our meeting with the
clients Emma asks relevant questions
understands and defines objectives for
the problem that needs to be tackled she
is a curious Soul who asks a lot of eyes
one of the many traits of a good data
scientist now she gears up for data
acquisition to gather and scrape data
from multiple sources like web servers
logs databases apis and online
repositories oh it seems like finding
the right data takes both time and
effort after the data is gathered comes
data preparation this step involves data
cleaning and data transformation data
cleaning is the most time consuming
process as it involves handling many
complex scenarios here Emma deals with
inconsistent data types misspelled
attributes missing values duplicate
values and whatnot then in data
transformation she modifies the data
based on defined mapping rules in a
project
ETL tools like talent and Informatica
are used to perform complex
Transformations that helps the team to
understand the data structure better
than understanding what you actually can
do with your data is very crucial for
that Mr does exploratory data analysis
with the help of Eda she defines and
refines the selection of feature
variables that will be used in the model
development but what if Emma skips this
step she might end up choosing the wrong
way tables which will produce an
inaccurate model thus exploratory data
analysis becomes the most important step
now she proceeds to the core activity of
a data science project which is data
modeling she repetitively applies the
type Force machine learning techniques
like k n decision tree knife base to the
data to identify the model that best
fits the business requirement she trains
the models on the training data set and
tests them to select the best performing
model Emma prefers python for modeling
the data however it can also be done
using R and SAS well the trickiest part
is not yet over visualization and
communication Emma meets the clients
again to communicate the business
findings in a simple and effective
manner to convince the stakeholders she
uses tools like Tableau power bi and
click view that can help her in creating
powerful reports and dashboards and then
finally she deploys and maintains the
model she tests the selected model in a
pre-production environment before
deploying it in the production
environment which is the best practice
right after successfully deploying it
she uses reports and dashboards to get
real-time analytics further she also
monitors and maintains the Project's
performance well that's how Emma
completes the data science project we
have seen the daily routine of a data
scientist is a whole lot of fun has a
lot of interesting aspects and comes
with its own share of challenges now
let's see how data science is changing
the world data science techniques along
with genomic data provides a deeper
understanding of genetic issues in
reaction to particular drugs and
logistic companies like DHL FedEx have
discovered the best routes to ship the
best suited time to deliver the best
mode of transport to choose thus leading
to cost efficiency with data science it
is possible to not only predict employee
attrition but to also understand the key
variables that influence employee
turnover also the airline companies can
now easily predict flight delay and
notify the passengers beforehand to
enhance their travel experience well if
you're wondering there are various roles
offered to a data scientist like data
analyst machine learning engineer deep
learning engineer data engineer and of
course data scientist the median based
salaries of a data scientist can range
from 95 000 to 165 000 so that was about
the data science are you ready to be a
data scientist if yes then start today
the world of data needs you that's all
from my side today thank you for
watching comment below the next topic
that you want to learn and subscribe to
Simply learn to get the latest updates
on more such interesting videos science
with r sponsored by simply learn that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead my name is Richard kirschner and
I'm with the simply learned team what's
in it for you we're going to go through
an introduction to our yr cran
comprehensive R archive Network and
cover installing R then we'll get into
simple linear regression using our line
of best fit using error summation
correlation analysis in R and then we'll
get into classification using R use case
predict the class of a flower let's
start with an introduction to R first
it's an open source R is completely free
and open source with active community
members extensible it offers various
statistical and graphical techniques
compatible R is compatible across all
platforms Linux Windows and Mac Library
R has an extensive library of packages
for machine Learning Easy integration it
can be easily integrated with popular
softwares like Tableau SQL Server Etc
this only touches a little bit on these
different aspects of R the fact that
it's a free it's very extensive it
probably has one of the most extensive
set of data analysis packages currently
out it has a compatibility is
continually growing so it's integrated
with everything from cluster Computing
to python integration which is now
coming out and its extensive libraries
allows you to import the different
libraries to use for whatever your needs
are makes it a very diverse and easy to
use coding source for analyzing data R
is more than just a programming language
as I just touched upon it it has a
worldwide repository system
comprehensive R archive Network and it
can be accessed at https colon slash
slash cran dot
rproject.org it provides up-to-date
versions of code and documentation for R
cran hosts around 10 000 packages of r
that is a huge repository focused on
just data analytics let's install R to
get started you can easily download the
executable file for R and install it
from cran website if you go to under the
downloads in this case since I'm on a
Windows machine we'll walk through it
from the r 3.5 version for Windows so
here we are at https colon slash slash
cran dot R Dash project dot org and you
can see down here we have the different
options for the downloads if we go under
Windows which is I'm on a Windows
machine if you're in a Mac machine you
do the Mac or Linux there's install R
for the first time just click on that
and open and run it the installation is
pretty simple follow the default options
to finish the installation after the
installation is complete you'll see the
r icon on your desktop alternatively
there are mirror sites and so we can go
into our studio this to take a quick
look at that if you're on the r Studio
website that's
www.rstudio.com you can go down under
products and rstudio download you'll see
a number of options here the first one
is the rstudio desktop open source
license that's the same thing you just
downloaded so if you download that
that's what you're getting there's also
an open source server setup which is
also free you can download from here and
then our studio offers a number of paid
packages which includes all kinds of
different supports for a company and
individual level setup whether you go
through the cran site or the rstudio
site the installation is pretty simple
just a quick note if you're a Debian
distribution including Ubuntu you can
install R using as regular package
management tools and when you're using a
Linux system that is preferred because
then it registers it properly on the
setup system let's go ahead and open up
our R studio and take a look here we are
and I've opened this up in the r studio
version which automatically opens up
some extra windows which is nice let's
go and take a look at that we have our
console on the left this is your main
workspace so if I go in here and I do
click the mouse and I do a four plus
four hook them up and say the answer is
a and you have some environmental
information and over on the right you
have plots usually when you're working
in here let's do a script we'll go up
here into the plus sign in the upper
left hand corner and just add some
script in here in this case it showed up
on the top but you can move these
windows around and let's say I do y
equals three plus four x equals y plus
two and then I'm going to do just X and
let's do a plot we'll throw a plot in
there c c is a notation that these are
going to be Cartesian points so we got
one comma two comma three that'd be like
your X and then y three comma four comma
five for just a standard call scatter
plot we don't have to memorize this
we'll go into some of this later on and
then I can take all of this if I go
under code since I'm working in the code
console and I go down to run region and
just run all it takes this code and just
runs it through my console and you can
see down here it it's executed y equals
three plus four x equals X plus two and
if you add three plus four plus two you
get nine that's what the X does and then
I did a plot I threw the plot in there
I'm plotting one two three three four
five and if you use just a straight plot
it's a scatter plot and you can see that
this appears on the bottom right where
you have your plots coming in so it's a
very quick way to show data that's one
of the wonderful things about R is it's
very easy and quick to go through and do
different functions on the data and
analyze it so it's a very popular
package before you start programming an
R you should install packages and its
dependencies packages provide
pre-assembled collections of functions
and objects each package is hosted on
the cran repository not all packages are
loaded by default but they can be
installed on demand remember earlier
we're talking about all the different
packages available you don't want to
install everything from R it would just
be a huge waste of space you want to
just install those packages you need so
to install packages in our studio you go
under Tools and install packages when
you click on the install packages you'll
get a dialog box you'll see whereas the
repository current because there's other
repositories and you can even download
and install your own packages you can
build and then you'll pick out the
packages you want and separate multiple
with spaces or commas so you can install
numerous packages at the same time in
this case we've installing the forecast
forecast package and you can see down
here I just type in forecast all the
install all the dependencies uses other
packages to build on it has those then
just click on install and it's done
before we cover the basic linear
regression model let's just take a quick
look at some of the different parts of
our or parts of programming you'll need
or scripting uh first you need to know
there are various data structures in R
we have vectors we have matrixes we have
arrays data frames and lists vectors is
the most basic data structure remember
vectors are a location and a direction
it's how they're generally defined
although a vectors you're talking about
scripting can contain numerous different
values you could have vectors with four
five six seven eight different values in
it for example a picture on the computer
might have the location of the pixel and
the number for the Red Q or the green
Hue and the blue hue so now you have
something with five different numbers in
it consisting of that Vector matrixes
allow you to move stuff around so you
might have a two by three Matrix that
you switch to a three by two we looked
at an X Y plot earlier it might be that
you have everything is you have 10
different numbers and each one has two
values x y and you need to switch that
Matrix so then you have two rays of five
numbers arrays are just at a collection
and you can have arrays of arrays of
arrays data frames have labels on them
which makes them easier to use so
usually we use a lot of data frames when
we're working with data because they're
just easy you can have a column and you
of rows and columns when you see the
term data frames and then lists are
usually homogeneous groups so in R
you're usually looking at similar data
that's connected in the list so the
first thing we do with before we even
importing the data you should have the
data ready so we need to look at the
data and see what's going on you can
import data from various sources
including Excel minitab CSV table text
files uh CSV is usually a text file
comma separated variables tab separated
variables there's all kinds of different
options here and importing the table is
very simple we have table read table
file equals data table header equals
true and let's just take a closer look
at what we're talking about here scratch
the closer look I didn't realize it was
just for example so importing a table
file is pretty simple you read.table
file equals data.table so whatever the
name of the file is comma header equals
true so if there's a header to it in
this quick flash they have name age
gender we'll actually do this in r with
another data set in just a minute but
you can see it's very easy to read a lot
of people use are even in other
programming languages so I can quickly
look at the data before they even start
analyzing it csev file same thing
read.csv file equals data CSV header
equals true separation equals space so
in this case even though CSV stands for
comma separated variable this one is
separated by spaces and they have the
header name age gender so it's the same
file saved as a c SV file and there's
also Excel
Excel has its own issues as far as
making sure you know what the tables are
and the headers are but you can see that
each one of these is easy to import so
and just like it's easy to import the
data you can also export tables in R so
you can see here right dot table my file
see my file.text comma separated and the
scoop T just means it's tab separated so
if you're using tab files on there
example like Excel so you can write a
DOT XLS to my file in this case they did
a text separation equals scoop T so it's
a tab separated for Excel file CSV same
thing very easy to write a CSV file to
your computer once you've changed the
data or altered it depending on what
you're doing with it and once we have
our data imported and we can save it
afterwards and Export it graphing
visualization in R is very powerful and
it's quick love doing this before even
exploring the data sometimes you just
want to graph it to see what it is there
so you have an idea looking for so
graphics and R cover a huge amount of
different things R includes powerful
package of Graphics that help in data
visualization these Graphics can be
viewed on screen saved in various
formats including PDF PNG JPEG wmf and
PS can be customized according to very
graphic needs you can copy and paste in
word or PowerPoint files R supports
various types of Graphics including bar
chart pie chart histogram kernel density
plots line chart box plot heat map word
cloud there's even some more obscure
ones but these are the main ones that
most people use I know I use a lot of
heat Maps but word clouds are a lot of
fun if you're doing websites and did and
word analysis then histogram is very
popular all of these are very widely
used let's look at the box plots also
known as whisker diagrams box plots
display the distribution of data based
on minimum first quartile medium third
quartile and maximum so right off the
bat we can use a box plot to explore our
data with very little work to create a
box plot we simply give a box plot and
the data very straightforward so we
might have passenger numbers in the
thousands I guess this is exploring data
dealing with airplanes and you can see
here they just have a simple plot if you
break it down you have your if we go
back one you'll notice we have like a
minimum a maximum our medium first
quartile and third quartile let's just
break that apart you can see the line on
the bottom is your minimum your line on
the top is the maximum gamer medium and
your first quartile right there first
quartile and third quartile and the way
a lot of times you read this is things
that are above the Box are outliers and
things below the Box are outliers and
what's in the middle of the box is use
the data you're looking at welcome to
today's video tutorial on importing data
in R by simply learn in this video we
will learn how to read data from various
file types such as text file CSV Excel
file as well as a SAS 7 bdot file that
stands for SAS version 7 in binary data
file
we will learn the important packages you
need to install before importing the
data sets we will also see how to write
data to an Excel file using the r
programming language
so let's get started with our demo first
and foremost we need to install the
important packages
the first package we have is our Java
you can see it here
so the r Java is a low level R to Java
interface it allows creation of objects
calling methods and accessing fields
then we have
Excel SX jars
that collects all the external jars
required for the Excel XX package
it is used for importing Excel files and
then we have the Excel SX package that
provides our functions to read write and
format Excel data now let's load the
packages to the library so first of all
you need to install all the packages now
I have already installed all the
packages so before a package can be used
it has to be loaded to the current R
environment
you also need to load a package that is
already installed previously but not
available in the current environment
now let me just
load the packages using the library
function I'll hit Ctrl enter to
run these packages
okay
now to get the list of all the packages
installed you just write the library
function with parenthesis if I
run this line
it will open in a new window saying our
package is available and these are the
packages that are already installed
let me close this window
okay
so let's get started with importing a
text file onto our
now we will import a text file that has
some Credit Data let me show you the
file first
here
I have a folder on my desktop that says
data files and here you can see I have a
text file called credit if I open that
it is a text file that has some
information now we are going to import
this information onto R so let's see how
to do it
I'll go to my R Studio
okay
now to read a text file
we use the read.table function and
passing the location of the file so let
me show you how to do it I'll write
credit underscore data which is going to
be my variable name that will store the
file information that I am going to use
read Dot
table function
and inside this function I am going to
pass in the location of the file
followed by the file name and the
extension of the file
so I'll go to my location
which is this folder I'll just copy the
location
and I'll paste the location here
make sure these are all
double backslash
and it should be within quotes
and now
with
double backslash I'll give the file name
which is
credit
so I'll write
credit dot txt which is the extension of
the file and close the double quotes
let's run this
all right
if you see the result we have
successfully
loaded our
Text data to this variable called credit
underscore data now to
view the
data you can use the view function
and I'll pass in the variable which is
credit underscore data let's run this
using Ctrl enter
this will open in a new tab you can see
I have
five columns from V1 to V5 and there are
total 10 rows of information
now you can see that the rows and
columns are okay but
the column name
has no meaning at all so let's assign
some proper names to the columns and
convert it into a data frame
let me just scroll down
so here
I'll write my
variable name that is credit underscore
data
and then
I'll create a data frame using data dot
frame function
and inside this I am going to write my
column names
so the First Column will be the ID
column
and the ID column I am going to get from
the same variable which is credit
underscore data and this time I'm going
to slice the result
so I'll give a comma which means I need
all the rows and the first column that
is going to be my ID so if I go to my
table here I am going to consider the
First Column instead of V1 I am going to
assign the column name as ID
okay
now
I'll give a comma
and then we'll write the second column
name as name which is the name of the
person and I'm going to use the paste
function so that we can
merge
these two columns V2 and V3
so the way to do is I'll give my paste
function
followed by
I'll give the
variable name that is credit
and this will have
all the rows from the second column
you'll give a comma and then I'll write
credit underscore data and I'll merge it
or paste it
with all the rows from the
third column
I'll give another comma let me come to
the next line
okay now
the third column I'm going to create is
called type
I'll write credit
underscore data
I'll slice it
all the rows
from the
fourth column which is B4 here
let's give another comma
and my final column is going to be
let's say transaction
I'll give equal to
then write credit underscore data to
have all the information or all the rows
from the fifth column or V5
let's run this
you can hit the Run button here okay
now let me just display the data again
I'll write credit underscore data again
and run it there you go let me just
expand this
you have
The Columns renamed the First Column is
ID column then we have the name then we
have type and last column we created was
transaction that has
dollar values or some
currency values
okay
now
moving ahead
to the next example where we will read a
CSV file so CSV file has comma separated
values
so we are going to import a salary CSV
file let me show you the salary file
first
so on my data files folder I have a CSV
file called salaries let me open it
okay so this is my
salary file which has information about
ID the employee name job title we have
base pay overtime pay other pay benefits
total pay we have the agency
and other information so we are going to
import the CSP file data onto R now
let's do it
now in order to read a CSV file we are
going to use the function that is
read.csv so I'll first create a variable
called salary that will have
my CSV file stored in it and the
function I'm going to use is read.csv
and again
inside this I'm going to pass my file
location let me copy the file location
from the top which is here
I'll just copy this location and I'll
change the
file name and the extension of the file
let's copy this
scroll down and I'll
paste it here
okay we'll give a double quote here as
well and instead of credit dot txt I am
going to write
salaries dot CSV
since it is a CSV file all right
now let's run this
okay it has successfully loaded our CSV
file onto this variable called salary
now let me just display the head of the
salary
variable
now the head function displays the
top six rows from your table you can see
here we have the top six rows from our
table
which is this
okay
now if you want to view it you can use
the view function so if I write
View
followed by the variable name which is
salary I'll run it this will open in a
new window you can see it I'll close the
credit underscore data window
now you can view the entire file here
we have the ID the employee name job
title base p and if I scroll down you
can see all the rows loaded
now here it tells you the total number
of entries and the total number of
columns
all right
now moving ahead you can also check the
structure of the CSV data set and the
function is Str so the Str function will
help you see the structure of the data
set which is the internal structure
if I run this let's expand the output
window
and you have information about all the
columns you see here ID column is of
type integer these are the values we
have the employee name as character
column and these are some of the
employee names you have the job title
benefits total pay
these are the data types
okay
now if you want you can check the column
names as well using the column or the
call names function if I write call
names and I'll pass in my variable that
is salary
let's give a space here so I'll scroll
down a bit and hit enter
there you go you can see all the column
names so there are total 13 columns ID
employee name job title agency total pay
and others
cool
now
let's go ahead and
read data from an Excel file that has
Pokemon data
so let me first show you the Pokemon
Excel file so here in my data files
folder we have a file called Pokemon
which is an Excel file let me just open
it
okay you can see here there are total
four sheets in it one is Pokemon then we
have moves Evolution and type chart and
there are certain specific information
present in
these sheets so we are going to import
all this data onto R now
so for reading and writing data
using an Excel file you need to install
the packages read Excel and write Excel
I have already installed the packages
let me just run the library commands so
that I have these packages loaded to my
library
and let me run Library write Excel as
well okay
next if you want to
display all the Excel sheet names in the
workbook
you can do this using the Excel
underscore streets function and passing
the location of the file followed by the
file name and the
type of file so I'll give my function
name as Excel underscore sheets and
within this I'm going to pass in my
location let me just copy from the top
I'll just copy this location
and we'll change the file name and the
type of file or the extension of the
file
so here I am going to paste the location
and instead of salaries.csv I'm going to
give
Pokemon
Dot
x l s x which is for an Excel file I'll
go ahead and run this line there you go
if you see the output here we have the
different sheet names printed the first
sheet was Pokemon then we have moves
Evolution and chart type
all right
now to read data from the Pokemon Excel
file we'll use the read underscore Excel
function
so let's read data from one of the
sheets let's say I want to read data
from
moves sheet let me show you how to do it
I'll create a variable called DF
this will store my
moves sheet data I'll use the function
read underscore Excel
and then
within double quotes I'll give my
location let me just paste it here all
right and then instead of
salaries.csv I'll write
Pokemon
Dot xlsx
which is for an Excel file and then I'm
going to give
another parameter that is the sheet name
I'll give sheet equal to
and within single quotes I'll pass in my
sheet name that is moves
let's run it
okay we have imported the moves sheet
data to R now now let's say
we'll print the head of the data set
there you go so we have printed the
first six rows if I
maximize this you can see the first six
rows from the moves sheet is printed now
and you can also view this data using
the view function I'll run it
this is how the
entire data set looks like
close it
okay now if you want you can also
perform certain operations
on this data set let's say I want to
sum the power column
so there is a column here which is
called Power if you can see this we have
a column called power I want to find the
total power so I'll use the sum function
inside the sum function I'll give my
variable name which is TF and then
I'll write
power
and then I'll give a comma I'm going to
Omit or remove all the any values that
are present so that there are no
discrepancies while calculating the sum
I will say n a DOT RM which is to remove
the any values equal to T which means
true
let's run it and check the sum this is
the sum you can see it here 25 460.
you can also print the structure of the
data frame
by using Str function and then
will give the variable name that is TF
if I expand this you can see the
structure you have all the data types
and their columns
also if you want some summary statistics
you can use the summary function that
will return the
statistical summary of all the columns
if I write summary and within brackets
I'll give my data frame name that is DF
and run it you see it returns us some
very significant
statistical information regarding
minimum value
the first quadrant value median mean you
have the third quartile value the
maximum value
and other information
okay now moving ahead
now so far we have seen operations on
reading data from text CSV and Excel
files now let's see how to write data to
an Excel file now to write data to an
Excel file
I'll first create a variable called DF
and then I'll say
data dot frame
and
I'm going to create a matrix
and convert that Matrix into a data
frame
so my Matrix will have values from 1 to
50.
and then I am going to give my second
parameter which is n row basically I am
specifying the number of rows that I
want let's say my Matrix would have 10
rows and then I'll give the third
parameter which says n call which means
and column equal to 5
so this is how you create a matrix and
convert it into a data frame let me just
go ahead and print the data frame now
okay so first I'll run my
Matrix and then let's print it
okay let me expand this so this is my
Matrix that has
10 rows and five columns from X1 to X5
all right
now
we need to
write the information of this Matrix
that we created onto an Excel file for
that we are going to use the
right underscore Excel
SX function
within this function I am going to pass
in my data frame name that is DF and
then I am going to give the location of
the file let me paste it here
and instead of
salaries.csv I'll give a new file name
which will be output
and it will be of type
Excel
SX
so what this command will do is it is
going to write all the information
present inside the data frame into a new
Excel file called output and it will
store it in the location which I have
passed here
now let me just show you here now
currently we don't have any output Excel
file here once I
run this statement it will create an
output file
let's run it and see the difference
okay so I've created my output file let
me check the data files here there you
go you can see here we have an output
Excel file if I open this
you will find it has the same Matrix
that I created using r with the columns
X12 X5 and the 10 rows so it has values
from 1 to 50. let me close it
okay now you can also read this using
the read underscore Excel function
will
pass in the
location and I'll change this from
salaries.csv2 output
Dot xlsx
make sure to have the double quotations
now let's run it
there you go you can see here even in
our R output you can see we have the
Matrix ready all right let me just
minimize this
now finally
we will do a demo on reading a SAS file
so if I show my data files folder we
have a SAS file you can see here sas7b
dot file that has information regarding
movies so we are going to import this
SAS file onto R now
so I'll go to my R Studio let's scroll
this and I'll hit enter all right
now
to read a SAS file you need to install a
package so I'll write install.packages
that is SAS 7 B Dot this stands for
SAS version 7 binary data file
and then you are going to call the
Library function that will have the
SAS 7
B dat package now I've already installed
this package so you need to install it
first now I am going to just call this
package okay
now to
read a SAS file
I'll create a variable called movies
that will store the information and then
I'll use the function
read
Dot
SAS 7 B dat and then
within double quotes I'm going to pass
the
location
is the same location I'm only going to
change the file name and the extension
of the file so my file name is movies
and the extension or the type of file is
SAS 7 B dat
let me run this okay so we have
successfully imported the SAS file onto
R now now to check
whether it was
okay or not you can use the view
function and pass in the variable name
that is movies if I hit Ctrl enter
there you go so we have successfully
imported our
movies data set which was of type sash 7
B dat you can see we have the movie name
the type of movie which is basically the
genre rating the year in which the movie
was released and then you have
information about the numbers it got and
the director if I scroll down you can
see there are total
277 entries and there are total seven
columns in it all right so let me now
scroll to the top and show you what we
did in this demo so first we installed
all the important packages that were
necessary for importing the different
data sets or reading the data sets and
writing the data sets onto R so first we
saw how to read a text file using the
read dot table and then we
assigned names to the columns using
ID name type and transaction you also
show how to use the paste function in R
then the next example we saw was to read
a CSV file using read.csv function
wherein we saw how you could give the
file location and the
file name followed by the extension of
the file
we saw how to use the head function and
the view function
we checked the structure of the CSP data
set we looked at the unique columns
present
then we moved ahead and saw how to read
data from Excel files then we installed
two packages namely read Excel and write
Excel
then we displayed all the sheets present
in a Excel file finally we saw how to
write to Excel files wherein we created
a matrix and converted that into a data
frame and that Matrix we rooted to an
Excel file which was
output dot XLS
and in the end we saw how to read a SAS
7 betat file
so that brings us to the end of this
video on importing data in R let's learn
about data manipulation in R and here we
will learn about D plier package and
when we talk about this D player package
it is much faster and much easier to
read than base R so D player package is
used to transform and summarize tabular
data with rows and columns you might be
working on a data frame or you might be
getting in a inbuilt or data set which
can then be converted into a data frame
so we can get this package deployer by
just calling in library function and
this can be used for grouping by data
summarizing the data adding new
variables selecting different set of
columns filtering our data sets sorting
it selecting it arranging it or even
mutating that is basically creating new
columns using functions on existing
variables so let's see how we work with
d player now here I can basically get
the package here so I can just say
install dot packagesdp player now we
already see the the package here which
is showing up so I will just select this
one I can do a control enter and that
will basically set up the package
package deployer successfully unpacked
so that is done now you can start using
this package by just doing a library D
player and this was built it shows me my
version of R so let's also use a inbuilt
data set that is New York flights 13 so
we can do install.packages and that will
search and get that relevant data set
I can again Call It by using Library
function now once that is done we can
look at some sample data here by just
doing view flights and that shows me the
data in a neat and a tabular format
which shows me year month day departure
time schedule departure time and so on
now we can also do a head to look at
some initial data which can help us in
understanding the data better
so what is this data about how many
columns we have what are the data types
or object types here it shows me how
many variables we have so this is fine
now we can start using deployer and in
that we can use say filter function if
we would want to look in for specific
value now here we have the column as
month so I will do a filter now I'm
creating a variable F1 I'm using the
filter function on flights which we
already have
and then what we can do is we can
basically look at the month where the
month value is 0 7 so let's look at that
and this one you can do a view on F1
which shows me the data wherein you have
filtered out all the data based on month
being seven
so this is a simple usage of filter we
can take some other example we may want
to include multiple columns so we can
say F2 filter flights and here we will
say month is equal to 7 day is 3 and
then look at the value of F2 if you are
interested in seeing this
and that tells you the month 7 and days
three you could also look into a more
readable format by using view on F2 and
that gives me my selected result so we
are just extracting in some specific
value we can keep extending this so here
we can say flights is what we would want
to work on I'm using the filter function
so I can straight away
instead of creating a variable then then
doing a view I can also do a view in
this way I can just pass in my filter
within the view and within this I am
saying filter I would want to look at
the flights month being 0 9 day being 2
and origin being LGA and then that shows
me the value here and obviously you can
scroll and look at all the columns and
if you see the origin column it shows
the selected value so now we have
filtered out our data based on values in
three different columns now what we can
also do is we can use and or we can use
or operators so I could have done this
in a a little different way so I could
have said head which shows me initial
result I will do a flight So within my
head function I am passing in this
and what does that contain so you are
saying flights and in this flight's data
set you would want to pick up the month
being the column so we use the dollar
symbol here we're given a value and I'll
say and and I'll again say flights
wherein I will select the day being two
and and remember when you talk about and
it is going to check if all the values
are met true so then you say flights
origin LGA and you look at the value so
in this way I can filter out
specifically multiple values by
specifying columns now we could have
done it in this way we could have
created a view or we could have assigned
this to a variable and then done a view
on that where we could have selected
month being day and origin or you can be
more
specific in specifying all the columns
it makes the code more readable so let's
look at the values and here you are
looking at head which shows me based on
month day and then you can look for
further columns for other variables that
is origin being LGA now what we can also
do is we can do some slicing here to
select rows by particular position so I
can say slice and I would want to look
at rows 1 to 5 and I can do this so you
can always assign or look at the view of
this I can just do here so when I did a
slide one is to 5 it shows me my entries
for one to five now similarly we can do
is slice 5 to 10 and now you are looking
at five to ten values
so you can always look at the complete
data and then you can slice out
particular data now mutate is usually a
function which is used when you would
want to apply some variable on a
particular data set and then you would
want to add it to your existing data
frame or you would want to add a new
column so this is where you use mutate
which is mainly used to add new
variables so let's see how you work on
mutate so it's pretty simple so you
create a variable over delay now I would
want to do a mutate so that it adds a
new column so I am selecting my data
which is flights I will call the new
column as overall delay and then
basically
I can look at
overall delay being arrival delay minus
departure DeLay So let's create this and
let's look at view of this which shows
me or which should show me my new column
which is overall delay which was not in
my original data set so you can anytime
do a head on this one to compare the
value so this one shows me arrival delay
and then there are many other variables
what you can also do is you can do a
view and you could have just look at
flights if you would want to compare so
you can look at the flights and this one
would not have any
overall delay column so it basically
shows me 19 columns only
what we see here
and if you
do a view on overall delay then that
basically shows me 20 columns so we know
that the new column has been added
to
this overall DeLay So if you would want
to work with 20 columns you will use
overall delay if you would want to work
with your original data set you will use
flights now you can also use a transmute
function which is used to show only the
new column so we can do an overall delay
and at this time we will say transmute
we will say flights overall delay the
computation remains same but at this
time if I look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute result
based on two variables or two columns
and just look at the new value and then
we can decide if we would want to add it
to our existing structure now you can
also use summarize and summarize
basically helps us in getting a summary
based on certain criteria so we can
always do a summarize
and what we can do is we can look at our
data and we can say on what basis we
would want to summarize this particular
data so we can do a summarize function
now summarize on flights I will say
average airtime and I would want to
calculate an average so for that I am
using inbuilt function called mean I
will do that on airtime column
so
let's look at flights once again and
here we can see there is
arrival time not a time sorry arrival
time and we would want to do some
average on this particular data we would
want to summarize this so what I'll do
is I will use the summarize function I
will say average airtime and this one I
will look at mean of a time so let's see
if there is a a Time column I might be
let's look at this one and I will delay
and yes we have an airtime so we were
actually looking at summarizing based on
a time not the arrival time so air time
is how much time it takes in air for
this particular flight and we will want
to use the trans summarize function not
the transmute so summarize flights
average airtime and this one we will
calculate the mean of average airtime
and I will also do a n a removal which
is I am saying true so let's do this and
that basically shows me the average
airtime is 151 I can also do a total a
time where I am doing a summation of
values or I can get the standard
deviation or I can basically get
multiple values such as mean
I can say total air time where I am
doing a summation and then I can look at
other values which is if you would want
to put in standard deviation here you
could do that so let's look at the
result of this summarize and this
basically allows me to get some useful
information which is summarized based on
a particular function such as mean sum
standard deviation or
all three of them now
let's look at grouping by so sometimes
we may be interested in summarizing the
data by groups and that's where we use
the group by function so we can always
use the group by Clause now here we are
taking a different data set so we will
say for example let's look at head of Mt
cars and that is basically my data set
on empty cars now that shows me the
model of the car it shows me mileage
cylinder power of this and your
horsepower and various other
characteristics or variables in this
particular data set so here we can say
let's do a grouping by gear so there is
a column called gear so I will call it
by gear I will look at my data set and
then what I'm using here which you see
with these percentage and Creator symbol
is called
piping so that basically feeds your
previous data frame into next one so
this is sometimes useful and you can get
this by just saying Ctrl shift and M and
you can then use this so we are going to
have piping so I am saying empty cars
now this is my original data set where I
did a head or I could have done a view
on this one if you would want to see it
in a more readable format and that
basically shows me the data so we are
using a different data set so I want to
group it by the gear column so I'm going
to call it by gear and this one takes my
data that is empty cars I'm using the
piping and then I'm saying group the
data based on gear column that's done
now let's look at the value of by gear
or you can always do a view so remember
whenever you are doing a group by it is
giving you a internal object where your
data is grouped based on a particular
column
so we can look at the values here you
can do a view that shows you your data
grouped based on a particular column now
I can again use the summarize function
where I would want to Now work on the
new one where it was grouped based on
gear so I am doing a summarize and here
I am going to say Gear 1 which will be
having the value of summation on the
gear column and then I'm saying Gear 2
which is mean well you could give some
meaningful names to this and let's look
at the value of this one
where we are basically now looking at
the values which is sum and mean values
based on the gear
similarly we can use look at different
example so we can say by gear and I'm
again using piping
but earlier we had taken gear we had
grouped the data and we called it by
gear so we took our original data set Mt
cars but now within this particular data
which was grouped by gear I will take
this data set I will use the piping and
I will summarize it where I am saying
within this particular data set I would
want to get the sum or I would want to
get the mean and then you can look at
the values so what you are doing is
you are either looking at your original
data set or you are looking at the data
which was already grouped and then you
can look at the values now here what we
can do is we can Group by cylinder say
might be you are interested in looking
at data which is summarized based on the
cylinder column you can do that and then
for this buy cylinder I am doing a
piping where I am using the summarize
function and summarizing will then be
done based on the mean values of the
gear column or the horsepower so let's
do this
and then you can basically look at the
value at any point you may want to look
at the data set again so just go ahead
and you can look at what does the value
contain
and
by cylinder or by gear and do a head and
it gives you the value
so you can always do some summarizing or
grouping in these ways now here we are
going to use sample underscore n
function and Sample underscore
fraction for creating samples so for
this let's take the flights data set
again and we would want to get 15 random
values now that is done and it shows me
15 rows with some random values from the
data what you can also do is you can do
a portion of data by using sample
underscore fraction and here I'll say
flights I'll say 0.4 which will return
40 percent of the total data so this can
be useful when you are building your
machine learning where you would want to
split your data into training and test
might be you are interested in some
portion of the data so you can do this
which is very useful function and then
you can look at the value of that now
what we can also do is we can use a
range function so like we were doing a
grouping by or we were trying to pull
out a particular column so in the same
way we can use a range which is a
convenient way of sorting then your base
R sorting so for a range function let's
do a view based on a range so we will
work on the flights data set which we
have and here what we would want to do
is we would want to arrange the flight
status set which is based on year and
departure time and we are doing a view
out of it so that basically gives me the
data which is arranged based on your ear
and departure time now I can do a head
to give me some highlighting of that
data now the piping operator what we are
using
can be used in these ways also so here I
will say DF I will just assign the data
set empty cars to it let's look at the
DF which has basically your different
models you can obviously
look at the head or view of it to look
at useful information we can also go for
nesting options which can be useful so
we are creating a variable called result
here now that has the range function so
what does this arrange function do so
when we would want to use arrange to
sort the data so I would want to sort
the data but what data would I sort so I
will use sample n which will give me
some portion of the data or some sample
data now what is that sample data so
here we are using nesting that is
earlier when we did a sample we just
said data and how many random samples we
want but instead of giving that what we
are going to do is we are going to use
filter here now this filter will work on
DF
so filtering will happen based on the
mileage which is greater than 20 I will
say size is 5 and I would want to
basically arrange this in a descending
order so I'm using the Des on this
particular mileage column by default it
is always ascending so let's get the
result out of this
which will basically show me the mileage
details in a descending order so this is
my data frame and now we can look at the
result what we have created
so just do a view or do a head and look
at the view so here you see mileage
where the highest value is on the top
and we were only interested in five
values in a random sample so that's why
when you did a view it shows your five
values and it shows in a descending
order based on mileage so we have not
only used an inbuilt function we have
not only arranged the data that is we
have sorted the data but we have sorted
the data based on a descending order on
a particular column we have said the
value should be greater than 20 and we
have also said we just need five random
samples now let's look at some other
examples so you can always do a multi
assignment so I can say filter
wherein I'm going to use DF which was
assigned Mt cars I am going to say
mileage should be greater than 20 then I
say B which is going to get a sample out
of a and I just want five random values
so let's look at that so we have B which
is
going to get a
set of five values from a now I will
create a result variable which will
arrange B which is sample data in a
descending order now let's look at the
result of this and that basically shows
me what we were seeing earlier so you
can do a multi assignment where you can
create a variable get a sample out of it
and then basically whatever is that
result you can arrange that or sort that
in a descending or by default ascending
order
so same thing we can do it using pipe
operator so piping so here I will say
result I am passing in my DF that's the
data set I'm using piping and which
basically tells what you need to do on
this particular data set so I'm going to
filter out the data based on mileage 50
sorry mileage 20 then I'm going to push
that or forward it to
get the random sample and whatever is
this random sample is going to be pushed
so you are arranging this in a
descending order so this is one more way
of doing it and then basically you can
look at the result so these are some
simple examples where you can use your D
plier with multiple assignments or using
your nesting to filter out the data you
can also do a arrange which is to sort
the data you can get some random samples
out of it you can summarize the data you
can also summarize the data based on one
or two or multiple columns and you can
use some inbuilt functions to summarize
the data based on some functions which
are applied on the variables or on the
columns
you can transmute it where you would be
interested in only looking at one column
you can mutate it where you want to add
a new column
you can slice it
and you can give the conditions where
you can say and on or to filter out the
data so what we can also do is on this
particular data set which we have say
for example DF where I have my data
let's look at this one and if I just do
a DF at this point it shows me my data
set and if you would be interested only
in particular column then your D player
also allows you to either we can do a
filter or we can simply do a select now
for selecting we can choose
our data so for example I'll say DF
underscore I'm interested in mileage I'm
interested in Horsepower might be I am
interested in your cylinders in this and
for this one what I can do is when I
would want to do a select I can
basically say
selected DF let's call it some name I
can say control shift M which is for
piping and then basically what you can
do is you can do a select and you can
choose your columns so I was interested
in mileage I was interested in
horsepower
I was interested in cylinder and here
what I'm doing is I'm using a select
where I can look at the new data frame
so let's do this
and I'm sorry here we will have to give
it DF this is where you are passing in
your data
yeah now this one is done and we can
look at the value of this one by just
doing a DF or head on DF
underscore mileage horsepower cylinder
and look at the selected result so you
can be looking at selective columns I
could have done this filter but filter
will always look for
a condition say your mileage is greater
than 20 or might be your cylinders are
more than four or something else but
when you do a select you are selecting
specific columns so view always gives
you all the columns head gives you
highlight but then select can be useful
when we are interested in looking at
only specific data so this is how you
can use the player for manipulation
for your data transformation for
basically filtering out the data by
selecting particular data and then
working on it so similarly there is one
more package called tider and we'll see
how we can use data manipulation done
using your tider package let's learn
about that IDR package which makes it
easy to tidy your data and this
basically helps you creating a more
cleaner data so which is easy to
visualize and model now this comes with
the mainly four functions so you have
gather which makes your data wide or it
makes wide data longer so that is
basically used to stack up multiple
columns you have spread function which
makes long data wider that is stacking
the data together or stack if you would
want to unstack the data to data
and you are talking about data which has
same attributes
and then your spread can spread the data
across multiple columns you have
separate which is function with splits
single column into multiple columns and
to complement that you have one more
function which is unite and that
combines multiple columns into single
columns so these are four main functions
which are used in your tider package so
let's look how we work with this so let
me bring up my R Studio here now for
this first is let me just clean up my
screen here doing a control l so I will
install the package it is already
installed but we can just do a control
enter and then
I can say do you want to restart R prior
to reinstall Store install I'll say okay
and it is basically going to get the
package
now it says package did tidyr the rest
idrs has been successfully unpacked
let's use that package using our library
function
and that was built under R version 3.6
now I can basically start using these
functions so for example here we are
creating a data frame so let's say n is
10
and then we basically would say we will
call it white now that's the variable
name I'm using the data dot frame
function I am saying ID which will be 1
to n so that will take the values from 1
to 10 and then these are the values
which have
10 entries so this is a vector Phase 1
phase two phase three let's create a
data frame out of it now that's done we
can have a look at our data frame by
just doing a view wide and that shows me
the ID column and it has phase dot 1
phase.2 and phase.3 now we can use our
function so for example we can work with
gather that is reshaping the data from
wide format to Long format and basically
you can say stacking up multiple columns
so let's see how we do that here I'll
call it long I am working on White I am
using the piping
functionality and then I'm using gather
so this one I will say what will be the
data which I will use so we are using
wide as a data frame
then I am saying response time so that
will be basically one more column and
then you have your columns which you
would want to
basically stack so I'm saying from Phase
1 to phase three so let's do this and
once this is done let's have a look at
our variable long so this one shows me
that I have an ID column
I have the response time column and I
have the face column which we mentioned
and that basically has all the values
stacked in so you have phase dot one
phase.2 and phase.3 so I have all the
columns are being stacked here so all my
data so now I have totally 30 entries in
this one so this is basically using your
gather function now sometimes we may
want to use a separate function now
separate function is basically splitting
a single column into multiple columns so
which we would want to use when multiple
variables are captured in a single
variable column okay so let's look at an
example of this one so let's say long
separate that's what we will call we
will work on this long which has all the
data stacked in as the columns we
selected then I am saying separate I
want the face column and then I would
say when I separate the columns what are
my column names now I could add also
give a separator by giving a comma and
then mentioning the separator if that is
required so let's do this
now once this is done let's have a look
at our long separate so what we see here
is the column which we used so we were
doing a face column and that was to be
split and we wanted to split it into
Target and number so that's what we see
here so you have face being split into
Target and number and then you have the
response time so this is how you use a
separate function now there is also
something called as unite function which
is basically a complementing of separate
function so it takes multiple columns
and combines the elements to a single
column so for example here we will call
it long Unite and we will take long
separate which was separating the data
we want to unite so we will take phase
Target number and we want to have a
separator between them so let's
basically do this and now let's look at
the result of this unite so you see you
have the face and Target merge together
so you have phase dot one the separator
is dot as we have mentioned and we have
United multiple columns so this is one
more function of your tider which helps
you basically tidy up your data or put
it in a particular way now then you have
your spread function and this is
basically for unstacking so that is if
you have if you would want to convert a
stack to data or if you would want to
unstack the data which is of same
attributes spread can be used so that
you can spread the data across multiple
columns so it will take two columns say
key in value and spread it into multiple
columns so it makes long data wider so
we can look at this one we will say long
unite I'm using the piping I will use
the split function I'll work on the face
column and response time and let's do
this and then let's do a view on this so
it tells me our data is back in the
shape as it was in the beginning so
these are four functions which are very
helpful when we work with tider package
so let's learn about visualization
and here we will learn about R which can
be used for your visualization now one
thing which we need to understand is
because of our ability to see patterns
which is highly developed we can
understand the data better if we can
visualize it so the efficient way or
effective way to understand what is in
our data or what we have understood in
our data we should or we can use
graphical displays that is your data
visualization so there are actually two
types of data visualizations so you have
exploratory data visualization which
helps us to understand the data and then
you have explanatory visualization which
helps us to share our understanding with
others so when you talk about r r
provides various tools and packages to
create data visualizations
and which can be used for both kind of
data analysis or both kind of
visualizations so when you talk about
exploratory data and visualization the
key is to keep all the potentially
relevant details together
now the objective when we talk about
exploratory data analysis is to help you
see what is in your data and the main
question is how much details can we
interpret
now when you talk about different
functions which we see here such as plot
which is more for a generic uh plotting
you have bar plot which is used to plot
data using rectangular bar so you can
say creating bar charts you have
histogram or hist function to create
histograms where you look at the
frequency of the data are basically used
to look at the central tendency of the
data you have box plot which is used to
represent data in the form of quartiles
you have GG plot which is a package
which enables the user to create
sophisticated visualizations with the
little code using the grammar of
graphics and then you have plot LI or
plot l y it creates interactive
web-based graphs via the open source
JavaScript graphing library now before
we see some examples here let's also
talk about when you talk about plotting
let's also try to understand what kind
of plots you can have and what kind of
techniques you have so let me open up my
R Studio here
now for example I can pull out a
particular data set and let's look at
this one so here I can look at
all the panes and that shows me the
information now what I can do is I can
install
and get the inbuilt data sets and then I
can simply do a plot wherein I am doing
a plot on chickweed data set so let's
see what does that show it summarizes
the relationship between four variables
in check weight data frame which is in
our built-in data set package now from
these plots we can see for example
weight very systematically over time
you can also see that chicks were
assigned to four different diets now
when we talk about explanatory data
analysis
or visualization that shows others what
we found in the data this means we need
to make some editorial decisions what
features we would want to highlight for
emphasis
what features are distracting or
confusing and you want them to be
eliminated right so there are different
ways of doing it now when you talk about
your graphics or visualizations you have
I would say three different types or you
can say four so you have the base
Graphics which is easiest to learn now
here we are having an example of Base
Graphics where I can use the base
Graphics I can get a
data set using Library
then I can simply create using plot
function to take generate a simple
scatter plot of calories with sugar from
us serial data frame in the mass package
and then I can give it a title so this
is basically a simple example of Base
Graphics now you also have what we call
as grid Graphics which is powerful set
of modules for building other tools now
you also have latest Graphics which is
general purpose system based on grid
graphics and then you have your GG plot
2 which implements grammar of graphics
and is based on grid Graphics so you
have different ways now here since I
already have used library and I have the
data set I can just do a x so I can
assign the sugar related values to X and
calories related value to Y then I can
use one more which is Library function
and calling in Grid now I can basically
use functions such as push viewport if I
would want to create a plot using your
grid Graphics to create the similar kind
of plot which we created using base
Graphics but this will give you much
more power than base Graphics it will
have a steep learning curve but it is
usually useful so I can do this where
I'm saying push view port then I can
basically say I would want to have a
data viewport I would say different
functions of your grid package so I'm
saying rectangle you have x axis y-axis
given some points here and then
basically you can add details to the
graph by giving the names to the columns
and you can basically create a simple
grid Graphics based plot here now there
are different other options which we can
use to create plots now before we go
into understanding how you create plots
let me just give you a brief on what are
the different kind of plots and how they
can be used so here we will look at
these different plots now for example we
have a bar chart which is a graph which
shows comparisons across discrete
categories
so you have x-axis which will show the
categories being compared and y-axis
which represents a measured value and
height of the bars are proportional to
measured values Now to create different
kind of charts you can use ggplot which
is a package for creating graphs in r
it is basically a method of thinking
about and decomposing complex graphs
into logical subunits and that is a part
of Tidy words ecosystem so it takes each
component of graph accesses you can give
scales you can give colors you can give
the objects and you can build graphs on
particular data you can modify each of
those components in a way that's more
flexible and user friendly you can if
you are not providing details for the
components then tgplot will use sensible
defaults and this basically makes it a
powerful and flexible tool now here
are different options when you use your
GG plot such as you can use geom or what
we call as geometric objects to form the
basis of different type of graphs for
bar charts you have for line graphs you
have Scatter Plots that is underscore
point you have underscore box plot for
box plots you have quartile for
continuous X violin for richer display
of distribution and Jitter for small
data so here is some simple example
where I would not go into too many
details here but you can just have a
look at this one where we are using
Library function to get the ggplot2
package then basically we would want to
look into the mileage data we would want
to look at the structure of it and then
we can basically get the Tidy verse
package finally we can create a bar
chart using jio underscore bar
and we can basically also mention what
would be in x axis now you can also give
different colors to basically add more
meaning to your data you could also go
for stacked bar charts so here we are
actually telling ggplot to map the data
in the drive column to fill the
aesthetic so here I am giving
aesthetic access class and I'm saying
what is the data we need to have and
then we are using geom underscore bar so
you can also have dodged bar
in your GG plot that is not bar charts
which are stacked but next to each other
and you can create that by using your
position as position underscore Dodge
okay now you can obviously use your
different packages which are inbuilt and
you can create your bar charts and you
have other kind of graphs such as line
graph which is basically a type of graph
that displays information as a series of
data points connected by straight line
segments such as this one and for this
one we are using if you see jio
underscore line now you can also create
a scatter plot which is a two
dimensional data visualization that uses
points to graph the values of two
different variables one in an x-axis one
on y-axis like what we saw in base
Graphics example
and they are mainly used if you would
want to assess the relationship or lack
of relationship between two variables
and you also have histogram which I
mentioned is mainly to look at the
distribution of a data to look at the
central tendency of the data basically
looking at your large amount of data or
for a single variable you would be
interested in saying where is more data
found in terms of frequency whereas
lesser data found in the graph how close
the data is towards its mid point or
what we call as mean median mode
so you can use histogram where you can
categorize the data in what we call as
bins so these are some Basics on
different kind of graphs now we can look
at some examples and see how that works
so what we were seeing is some quick
examples of Base Graphics or grid
Graphics now here let's do an example of
pie chart for different products and
units sold so you want to create a graph
for this first let's create a vector and
pass in the value here now I can also
create labels which I would want to
assign to these values and then
basically I can plot the chart by saying
Pi so that's the kind of chart which I
would want to create and I would say the
data would be X and labels so let's do
this and that shows me a simple pie
chart now I can also give main details
here so instead of just doing a pi x
comma labels I can say what is the main
and then what kind of coloring it should
follow so this is the way you can create
a simple uh plot now I can also find out
what is the percentage and then
basically I would be interested in
plotting the pie chart which takes X
which takes the labels which will be the
percentage which we are calculating here
by doing a round function and then you
can basically give details to your graph
you can say what color it follows
you can basically look at the legend
where it needs to be in your chart
what are the values and then basically
fill up the colors so let's run this one
and that shows me the percentage which
was calculated and it gives me the
details and we can always have a look at
our plot now if you would want to go for
a 3D pie chart then you can get the
package which is plotrix let's use that
by calling in the library function let's
pass in some data to X and let's give
some values or labels which will make
more meaning to the data and then let's
plot the 3D graph so I'm saying Pi 3D
here where I'm using X and labels
then I'm basically doing an explode
which will basically control how your
graph looks like and basically give the
values so it also takes the title when
you say Main and by chart of countries
now let's create data for graph so again
we are having a variable here we are
created using the C function creating a
vector and then let's create a histogram
for this one
where I would say xlab what would be
your data around x axis what is the
color what is the border and here I am
creating a simple histogram which as I
discussed earlier will always show your
values on the x axis and y axis is more
of frequency and then you can look at
the set of values and what is their
frequency and we can basically use this
histogram for exploratory data analysis
look at the data try to understand what
is the central tendency of your data
values now we can also give some limits
by using the X Lim and Y Lim and then I
can also specify what is the limit so we
have given some values here wherein we
have said your X limit is 0 to 40 and Y
limit is 0 to 5. now if you compare this
with the previous one which we had
created this one based on the frequency
had taken the the limits but we can
assign limits explicitly by giving this
and then create a histogram which makes
more meaning
now let's take another data set that is
air quality let's view this to see what
does that data contain so you have ozone
solar wind temperature month and the day
so this is the kind of information we
have in the air quality now let's use
the plot function to draw a scatter plot
where as I mentioned you would be
interested in analyzing variables and
see what is the relationship between
them so to plot a graph between ozone
and wind values so we will say plot we
will say the data which is air quality
from that I would be interested in the
ozone column or ozone field and the wind
field I can create a plot based on this
now I can also be saying what should be
the color what is the type of the data
which you would want to create and you
can look at the info information so you
can create a histogram you can create a
scatter plot to basically understand the
data better and then infer some
information from that data so let's take
the air quality data set itself without
specifying any particular column and you
can create a plot which shows me all the
different values which you have in the
data and it basically shows you the
difference this is more of an example
like what we did for tick weight where
we did a base Graphics now you can
assign labels to the plot so that is
when you are creating a plot you can say
air quality you will say ozone and then
that's your ozone concentration you have
your ylab which is the number of
instances you have what is the title
ozone levels in New York City what is
the color so these are the details what
we have given with our plot function and
let's look at the data so it just tells
me that this is the ozone concentration
uh the number of instances what you have
and you are looking at the data now we
could also create a histogram by picking
up a particular column that is such as
solar from your air quality and that
basically shows me the frequency of
solar values and we can then try to find
out what is the made what is the mean
what is the standard deviation and so on
you can also look at your histogram and
try to understand if it is left skewed
and right skewed so we can do that now
here let's get the temperature out from
this particular data set let's create a
histogram on temperature and that
basically shows me the frequency of the
temperature values and what values have
the most frequency or most occurrence
now you can create a histogram with
labels
so let's do that with the limit
and then let's also use text to
basically given the values which also
takes the values and for each set of
frequency or each set of values it gives
me the labels now you can have a
histogram with non-uniform width so you
could do that by doing a hist function
and then
passing in your temperature you can say
what will be the main what is the title
what will be your xlab
it will tell you a limit around x axis
what is the color what is the Border
what are the breaks you would want to
have for your bars and you can simply
create a histogram using this so This
basically takes the breaks which we have
given such as 55 to 60 60 to 70 70 to 75
and so on so this is basically creating
a histogram with non-uniform width and
it purely depends on the kind of values
what you have
now you can also create a box plot which
sometimes helps us in understanding the
the data quartiles also understanding
our outliers so you can create multiple
box plots based on the data from air
quality so we'll select all the data and
then we'll do some slicing on the data
so let's create a box plot which tells
me the values and if you look at these
points here like single dots these are
basically your outliers we can learn
about that more in later sections so you
can use your ggplot to library to
analyze
a particular data set so for that we
will first
use the install.packages and get dgplot2
so it says do you want to restart R and
I can say yes so let it get the package
I think the package was already there
and now
let's look at
using ggplot2 so for that I have the
library function
and let's do a attach where I'm getting
a data set which is empty cars
now then I will create a variable P1 I
will use ggplot I will pass in my data
I'll give the Aesthetics what is the
columns which you would be interested in
and then you are using geom underscore
box plot to basically create a plot
which gives me the box plot for the
values here and this is based on the
cylinders which is there in your data so
we can always look at what does our data
contain and what kind of values or
features are available in the data now
let's create a box plot we will also use
the coordinate function and that
basically gives me based on the data so
I've changed the coordinates now if you
look at the previous one where we
created a plot we had mileage on the
y-axis and cylinders
on the x-axis now I did a coordinate
flip and that's like your transpose
function so you have created the box
plot but you have just flipped the
coordinates you can create a box plot
and then say fill which is the factor of
cylinder so that can be used to fill up
the values in your box plot now what we
can also do is we can create factors so
we have learned about factors earlier
which is usually used to work on
categorical variables so here let's
create a factor
which is empty cars and care you have am
you have cylinder and if you look at the
factors which we have created we have
passed our data what is the field or the
column we are interested in what is the
level of values there and what are the
labels for those values right so we have
learned about factors
you can always look into the previous
section and learn more about factors now
let's create a scatter plot by using the
ggplot function again we will use the
data as MD cars I will go for mapping
option and then I will give my
Aesthetics that is what would be x what
would be your Y and you also would want
to use what kind of function you are
using so let's go for geompon point and
that basically helps me in creating a
scatter plot now you can create a
scatter plot by factors so here we will
say GG plot so notice in all of these
cases depending on the kind of data you
have depending on the kind of plot you
are interested in you will use the GG
plot and then basically a function with
that or the inbuilt package so here I'm
saying data is empty cars I am going for
mapping which basically will take the
values for your X and Y what is the
color and the coloring will be done
based on the factor values now if you
remember factors will obviously have
some levels and those levels will
basically help you in differentiating
between your categorical variables so
I'm saying as dot Factor on cylinder and
then I'm using geompoint to basically
create the scatter plot so let's do this
and I can look at the values of this one
so it says must be there is an error
which says must at least one color from
the Hue palette so let's look at that
one so the error which we were facing
when we gave color as the factor values
was because when you look at these
factors which were created with some
labels if we look at the values of these
it tells me there are any values in that
particular column similarly your gear or
similarly you can completely look at the
complete data set it tells me cylinder
you have am you have care now these have
some we have created some labels but
these have any values so what we can do
is we can create a scatter plot as we
did earlier by giving the Aesthetics and
that's a simple scatter plot
wherein I'm also using geompoint so that
I can have these points by defaults or
with defaults you can also give a color
specific basically if you would want to
have different kind of data in the same
plot or I can create Scatter Plots by
different sizes by giving a size or I
can give a color and size and that's
again one way in which you can create
your Scatter Plots now let's also see
how you can visualize one more data set
which is MPG so I can also do it in this
way where I set GG plot 2 and then pass
and look at the data set what we have
here you can just do a view on this to
see what my data contains if the fields
have any any values if that's going to
affect your plotting so now what we can
do is we can create a bar plot or a bar
chart so I'm saying GG plot the data
would be as we have given in previous
lines that is ggplot2 MPG then I will
say what should be in my Aesthetics and
what kind of
chart are you going to create so I'm
saying geom underscore bar so that's my
bar chart and that has basically your
class and count now you can create a
stacked bar chart where your information
is stacked in the same bars and we are
still using the same data we are going
for Aesthetics which is class and then
when you say geom bar which creates your
stack bar we will use fill which is
drive and we can always go back and look
at our data for example you can always
look into this so you have the drive
column here and you are also working on
this complete data set so let's go ahead
and create a stacked bar chart and that
basically gives me the information where
you have the drive information which is
stacked here now you can do a Dodge by
giving the position as Dodge so we are
still going to go for a stack chart but
this time the bars will be next to each
other and that can also be done which is
very useful you can use this by using
geompoint where you are mapping and you
are specifying what are your Aesthetics
so we were creating a scatter plot
now you can also use or give more
details where you can say color can be
based on the class and we have different
classes and based on that my points have
been colored now you can also use a plot
lyu or plotly Library so let's install
this one
I will say yes for example let it
basically restart so that all my
packages are updated
then I can access that package using
Library function and then create a
variable to which you are assigning your
plot underscore l y plot so data is
empty cars what will be your x-axis what
will be your y-axis and details on your
marker which we have given wherein I
will give a list which is size color
which is a combination and then you have
your line
what kind of color it will have and what
will be the width so this is where I'm
going to use plot l y
and let's look at this plot
so it basically gives me some
information now we see some warnings
which are getting generated but there is
you don't need to worry about that so
you can look at the packages what you
have and what options you are using so
similarly we can create one more plot
using plot l y and look at the values of
those so that's a plot with a trend
which explains me about my data so this
is a simple small tutorial on
understanding or how you can have your
graphics or visualization used to
understand your data obviously there are
much more examples much more ways in
which you can pass into your plot
functions or your GG plot and the
inbuilt packages which are available in
R for your visualization now that could
be for exploratory data analysis or
explanatory data analysis so try these
graphs and see if you can change these
options and try or create new
visualizations let let's dive into why
linear regression now that we have come
this far I'm planning to take a closer
look at our cells so that we can
estimate cells in the future how about
we hire a data scientist you can see our
two corporate individuals looks more
like they should be agents or secret
agents someplace discussing how to
better forward their company and so
they're going to come in and ask the
data scientist to come in good idea this
will help us to keep a constant track of
our cells so why do we need linear
regression let's assume that we need to
predict the number of skiers based on
snowfall so this happens to be we've
kind of jumped one business to the next
we're looking at the skiing business
very popular in a lot of areas and it's
based on snowfall a lot of times you
figure you don't have snow you don't
have skiers but can we actually use
something more specific instead of look
it's snowing and instead of saying Hey
look it's snowing we can actually start
drawing graphs and the graph shows that
with an increase in snowfall the
frequency of skiers also increases so
and there's a pretty direct correlation
if you've ever been up to ski areas when
there's a lot of snow falls the skiers
all show up because they know it's going
to be better skiing right afterward so
it's kind of easy to see why skiers and
snowfall would go together and usually
draws a nice straight line and you can
easily predict how many skiers and that
way you can also predict how many people
you need to service them how many lifts
they have up and running and all the
stuff that goes with running a ski area
thus we see that the number of skiers
are directly proportional to the amount
of snowfall regression models a relation
between a dependent Y and an independent
X variable this is real important to
understand regression because when we
talk about linear regression it's the
basis of almost all our machine learning
algorithms out there and it's usually an
underlying part of the math in our deep
learning so it all starts here with
linear regression and when we talk about
a dependent Y and an independent X
variable these are numbers we're usually
talking about floats so we want to have
an actual number value coming out and
that's different than something that's
categorical or we want to know yes or no
true false so regression means we're
looking for a number the independent
variable is known as predictor variable
and dependent variable is known as the
response variable so we have one
predictor variable the amount of
snowfall and one response variable how
many skiers are going to show up and
then we can take this relationship and
it can be expressed as y equals beta
we're going to use the Greek letter beta
and we have beta naught plus beta1 X1
and if you continue out it'd be plus
beta 2 x 2 and so on till the nth degree
in this case snowfall is an independent
variable and skiers is a dependent
variable so we kind of had a little
quick overview let's go ahead and talk a
little bit more about what is linear
regression so we're going to go from y
predicting a number of skiers for
snowfall and we've looked at the formula
a little bit but let's look a little bit
closer at what exactly is going on with
linear regression and the question is
going to come up in an interview what is
linear regression linear regression is a
type of statistical analysis that
attempts to show the relationship
between two variables linear regression
creates a predictive model on any data
showing Trends in data the model is
found by using the least Square method
there are other methods the least Square
method happens to be the most commonly
used Al out there and we usually start
with the least Square method since it's
the most common and usually works the
best on most models and we're already
looking at how linear regression works
but let's dig deeper into it and let's
take a closer look how linear regression
works I will provide you with a data set
which has rent area other information in
it looks like our secret agents have put
on their casual wear for this one you
need to predict rent accordingly we are
given area and rent here so you can do
linear regression with more variables
but we're just going to look at the area
and then from that try to figure out
what the rent should be we plot the
graph if you look at it here you can see
that the graph kind of a linear pattern
with a little dip in it so the area
seems the rent seems to be based on the
area in most of our work as data
scientists we usually try to start with
a physical graph if we can so we can
actually look at it and say hey does
what I'm fitting to this graph look
right you can solve a lot of problems
that arise by looking at the graph and
saying no that doesn't look right at all
or well I should be looking over here
for this then we find the mean of area
and rent so the mean just means average
and if you take one two three four five
and add them all together and divide by
in this case there's five areas you get
three and the rent is two four six five
and eight if you add them all together
and divide by five you get five and we
plot the mean on the graph so you can
see right here here's the mean of the
rent and the area it's kind of a very
Central Point which is what we're
looking for the average of everything in
there the best fit line passes through
the mean this is real important when
you're eyeballing it as humans we can do
this fairly easy if it's a straight line
through a bunch of data it gets more
complicated mathematically when you
start adding multiple variables and
instead of a line you have a curve but
for basic linear regression we're going
to draw a line through the data and the
line should go through the means that's
going to be part of the best fit for
that line but we see there are multiple
lines that can pass through the means so
depending on how you look at it you can
kind of Wiggle the line around back and
forth so we keep moving the line to
ensure that the best fit line has the
least squared distance from the data
points and this is you can see right
here residual we have our data point and
then we look at this distance between
them and we square that distance and
that's what they mean by the least
squared distance we want all those
distances to add up to the smallest
amount we can we talk about that
distance we call it the residual it
equals the Y actual minus the Y
predicted very straightforward we're
just looking at the distance you can
accidentally switch these and it'll come
out the same because we're going to
square it but when you're working with
other sets of linear regression you want
to make sure you do the Y axial minus
the Y predicted the value of M and C for
the best fit line Y equals MX plus C can
be calculated using the mentioned
formula and you can see here we have m
equals the number of points that's what
n stands for then we have the sigma the
Greek symbol is there which is a
summation of x times y minus the
summation of x times the summation of Y
over the number of the summation of
squared minus the summation of x squared
of X all of it squared that can be a
little confusing trying to say that and
then of course your C value is going to
be the summation of Y times the
summation of x squared minus the
summation of x times the summation of x
times y over the total count of the
summation x squared minus the summation
of x squared that's a mouthful normally
we don't worry too much about these
formulas other than to know they're
there now if you're a mathematician you
might go back in there and work on those
and those people who originally started
to put together the different models in
R of course had to know all this math to
build them and had to test it out that's
one of the nice things about R what is
important is that you know about these
formulas so that you know where it's
coming from so if you're using one
linear regression model this is how this
one works there's other linear
regression models based on different
math and so you'd have to be aware when
that math changes and how that changes
the model we find the corresponding
values so in this case if you're going
to break this up and you're building
your own model instead of using the one
in R you would have your rent you would
have your area you would find your rent
squared your area squared and your rent
times area and if we go back one we can
see that that's all the different little
pieces in this model we have x times y
we have x squared we have the sum of X
which is going to be squared we have the
sum of X the sum of Y this is the same
these are all the little pieces in here
that we see for m equals and C equals
and so once we compute all these we have
15 25 55 145 88 very easy to do on a
computer thankfully you could have
millions of these points and it would do
it in a very short period we can then
plug in those values very easily into
this formula and get a final answer and
we'll see that m equals 1.3 and C equals
1.1 and then when we take this for the Y
predicted equals m of i x of I plus C we
can take these and actually run the data
we have so we're going to see how it
predicts so now we find the Y the value
of Y predicted so we have our X in and
we want to know what Y what we think y
will be based on our formula we
generated the linear regression formula
and so when we come in here we have our
X we have our actual y then we have our
y predict what we think it's going to be
and then we have we take y minus y
predict and we get those values minus
0.4 it's off by 0.3 this one's off by
one this one's on off by minus 1.3 by
0.4 and we go ahead and square that and
then we can sum that square and average
it out and we'll get a value this is
just a summation down here of Y minus y
predicted square is 3.1 and we call that
the least Square value for this line is
3.1 and we go ahead and divide that by
five so when we plot the Y predict and
this is the best fit line and you can
see that it does a pretty good job going
right through the middle of lines and in
something like rent versus area if
you're trying to figure out how much
rent to charge or how many people are
allowed to be in the area that's going
to work work but if you're looking for
the rent value compared to the area this
gives you a good idea based on the area
of what you should rent the place for
it's close enough that in the business
world this would work you're not
Computing something down to the
millimeters or micrometers or Nuclear
Physics we're just charging people and
so if you're off by a couple dollars
it's not a big deal you'll be pretty
close to what you think it's worth and
get the right value for your property
use case predicting the revenue using
linear regression now that you have a
good idea of how linear regression works
and we're kicking back on our lounging
sofa today let's work on a real life
scenario where you have to predict the
revenue so we're going to take a data
set and we'll pull this up in just a
minute we'll have a paid organic social
and revenue there are three attributes
we'll be working on the first one is our
paid traffic so all the traffic through
the advertisement that comes in the
non-paid traffic from search engines so
these are people coming to the website
and are doing so because they did a
search for something specific so it's
pulling it from your website all the
traffic coming from social networking
sites so we want to know what's coming
from Twitter and Facebook and somehow
they've linked into your website and
coming into your marketing area to buy
something and we'll use this to predict
the revenue so we want to know how all
this traffic comes together and how it's
going to affect our cells if the
traffic's coming in we're going to make
use of the multiple linear regression
model so you'll see that this is very
similar to we had before where we had y
equals m times X plus C but instead we
have y equals M1 X1 plus M2 X2 plus m3x3
plus c m is the slope so you have M1 M2
M3 the three different slopes of three
different lines Why is the revenue so
we're only looking for one variable and
remember this is regression so we're
looking for a number X1 is going to be
the paid traffic and of course M1 the
corresponding slope X2 the organic
traffic and X3 the social traffic we
will follow these steps to create the
regression model we'll start by
generating inputs using the CSV files
we'll then import the libraries
splitting the data into train test very
important whenever you're doing any kind
of data science applying regression on
paid traffic organic traffic social
traffic so we're going to apply a
regression model on them and then we're
going to validate the model that's the
whole reason we split it to a training
and testing is so we can now validate to
see just how good our model is now
before we open up our I always like to
just take a quick look at the data
itself and we're using the rev.csv file
and this is a CS file or comma separated
variable file we'll just open that with
wordpad any kind of text editor would be
nice to show you what's going on and you
can see we have paid organic social and
revenue across the top so those are
titles for your columns and the values
going down and this is the same as what
we saw on the slide just a minute ago
paid organic social and then revenue
from them they probably have it in more
of a spreadsheet than just a word pad
and I'm using the newer version of our
studio which already has a nice layout
automatically opens up with your console
and terminal window down and left you
have your script and we'll run it in
script and then when I run it line by
line in script you'll see it show up on
the console bottom left I could type it
straight into the console and it would
do the same thing and then on the right
we have our environment and under the
environment we'll see plots if you're in
an older version the plots will pop up
and you usually are running just in the
console and then you have to open up a
different window to run the script and
you can run the script from there this
opens up everything at the same time
when you use the new R Studio setup and
the first thing we want to do is we want
to go ahead and generate a variable
we'll call it cells and we want to load
this with our data set and so in R we
use the less than minus sign that's the
same as assigned to it's like an arrow
pointing at cells it says whatever it
goes past here is going to be assigned
to cells we want to read in our CSV file
and then I went ahead and fixed the CSV
file up a little bit when I say the CSV
file I mean the path to it
um and we'll go ahead and just paste
that in there and this is my edited
version and you'll see I took wherever
we had the backward slash I switched it
for a forward slash because a backwards
slash is an escape character and
whenever you're programming in just
about any scripting language you want to
do the forward slash instead so like a
good Chef I prep this and copied it into
my clipboard and we can see the full
path here and the full path ends in our
rev.csv files that's the path on my
machine and then I'm going to run that
and now we have down here you see it
appear right here oh must have an error
in my path it says object rev not found
let me fix that real quick and run it
again and this time it does assign the
cells the data set and then we'll just
type in cells and this is the same as
printing it so if you work in other
languages you'll do like print and then
sales or maybe print sales.head if
you're in pandas in python or something
like that but in R you just type in the
variable we'll run this and you can see
it printed out all those columns so
that's the same thing we just looked at
and it says Max print so it emitted 750
rows so so it has a total of a thousand
rows and we can scroll up here on our
console where the answer came in and if
I scroll up to the top whoops way up to
the top there we go you'll see paid
organic social and revenue so everything
looks good on this and there's a lot of
cool things we can do with it one of the
things we can do is I can summary it so
let's do a summary of cells and we'll
run that and the summary of cells comes
in it tells you your Min first quarter
median mean third quarter Max for paid
organic social breaks it up and you can
actually get kind of a quick view as to
what the data is doing you can take more
time to study this a lot of people look
at this and you can see from the median
the mean that tells you a lot and it's
divided into quarters so you have your
first quarter value and Max it just
gives you a quick idea what's going on
in the data summary is a really
wonderful tool one of the reasons I like
to jump into R before I might do a major
project in something else or you can run
everything enough and let's take a look
at the head head of cells and let me run
this and you can see it just shows the
head of our data the first six rows in
this case and it starts with one
important to know the other different
systems start with zero and go up R is
one that starts with the first is one
and then if we want to do a plot I'll go
ahead and do a plot cells another really
powerful tool that you can just jump
right into with r once you have your
data in here and you'll see that the
plot comes over on the right hand side
and what it does is it Compares them so
if I look at my paid and my organic and
you cross a two you'll see there's a
nice line down the middle big black line
where plots a two together let me just
widen this a little bit so we can see
more of it there we go the same thing
with paid and social paid and revenue so
each one of these has a clear connection
to each other so that's a good sign we
have a nice correlation between the data
and you can just eyeball that that's a
good way to jump in and explore your
data rather quickly and see what's going
on so we'll go ahead and I'll put a
pound sign there uh tag and splitting
the data into training and test data and
we want to split it so that we have
something to work with to train our data
set and when we do our data set you do
this with any data set because you want
to make sure you have a good model and
then once we've trained it we're going
to take the other set of data we pulled
off to the side and we'll test it to see
how good it is if you test it with the
training data it's already got that
memorized and should give you a really
good answer in fact when you get into
more advanced machine learning tools you
watch those very closely you watch your
training set and how it does versus your
testing set and if your training set
starts doing better than your testing
set then you're starting to over train
it now that's more with deep learning
and some other packages that are beyond
what we're working with today but you
know this is important it's very
important to understand that that test
and that training correlate with each
other and gives you an idea what's going
on and make sure that you're set up
correctly and we'll go ahead and set a
seed of two and that's for our random
generators so that when we run them you
could see them with just a red there's
ways to randomize a number or you could
do like date and stuff like that but
that way we always use the same random
numbers so we'll seat it with two and
then we're going to need a library in
this case we're going to import the
library and we want to import CA tools
and CA tools has our split function so
we're going to be able to split our data
along with many other tools we're going
to need for this example so they're all
built into the ca tools that's why we
need to import that a lot of times they
call them library or sometimes you hear
them referred to as packages so let's go
ahead and run that line and that brings
the library in so now we can use all
those different tools that are in there
and then I'm going to do a split and
we're going to assign to the split
that's going to be our variable sample
split okay so that's one of the tools we
just brought in is to sample is the
actual keyword or the function word
sample.split and we're going to take our
cells and we're going to go ahead and
with split ratio equals 2.7 and let's do
0.7 so we make sure knows it's a decimal
point or float and what this is saying
is that we're going to take our cells
data the variable we created called
cells that has the data in there and I
want to split it and I'm going to split
it so that 70 percent of it goes in one
side we'll use that for training and 30
percent will go into the other side
which we'll use then for testing out our
model let me go ahead and run that and
oops hold on one second got an error
there spit is definitely very different
than split I don't think we want to spit
our data out we which is actually kind
of what we're doing is spitting it out
but we want to split we want to split
the data something get that spelled
correctly and then when I type in Split
we can just run that because that's now
a variable you'll see that it has true
false false true so it generates a
number of interesting different
statistics going across there as far as
the way it splits the data and right
here if you have not used R in a while
or if you're new to R completely that
line one that's what that little one
means down there and then true false
false true that means that's how we're
looking looking at the data we're
splitting all those different pieces of
data in line one different directions
and so we now want to create our trained
set and we're going to assign that and
when we take it and we assign to the
train set a subset of cells and then the
subset of cells is going to be based on
split equal let me put this in Brackets
true so you can see the values down here
is capital T capital r capital u capital
E so I just want to reflect that on the
train and this is going to take
everything where our split variable is
equal to true and it's going to set
cells equal to that and we'll go ahead
and run that and then we're going to set
our test variable as a subset of cells
and if we assign the true to the train
set then we want to assign the false to
our test set so now we'll have this will
have 30 percent of the variables in it
and train will have 70 percent we'll go
ahead and run that so we've now created
both our training set and our test set
and we can just just real quickly type
in train hit the run on there and you
can see our train set if we scroll way
up to the top I'll have the column names
on there which should match what we had
before paid organic social and revenue
and then we'll type in test when I hit
run on there that's going to do the same
thing it'll spit out all the test
variables going out so now that we have
the test and train variables we want to
go ahead and create the model and you'll
see this in any of the machine learning
tutorials they always refer to them as
models we're modeling a function of some
kind on the data to fit the data and
then we're going to put the test data
through there to see how well it does
and so we're going to create the
variable called models and I'm going to
assign that LM that is our linear
regression model I love how simplified R
makes it just LM linear regression and
then model M
I guess it dates back because the linear
regression model is like one of the
first major models used so they kept it
easy on there and revenue happens to be
the main main variable that we want to
track so if you remember correctly from
our formula why is the revenue and then
we have X is our paid traffic X2 organic
traffic and X3 are social traffic so why
is what we want to predict in here and
then you'll see this notation where we
have our squiggle and the period which
means we're going to match up the
revenue lines with the lines of the data
we're putting in here and then I'll put
comma and then our data equals train and
of course that's the training data that
we created so when I hit the Run
remember we did all the discussion about
all those different functions and
formulas to compute our model and how
that's set up when it comes down to it
we spend all our time setting up our
data and then we hit the Run button on
the single line and our model's been
trained so we now have a trained model
here and we can do a summary of the
model summary is such a wonderful
command because you can do that on r
that works on all kinds of different
things on there oops and of course it
does help if I remember that my model
has a capital N when I run it and you'll
see right here it tells you a little bit
about the model use a summary on there
comes down here has our residuals this
is all the information on there as far
as like the minimum the median the Max
has all our coefficients in there if you
remember correctly from our formula
let's just go ahead and switch back over
to that we have M1 X1 M2 X2 M3 X3 plus C
well this right here here's our
intercept and then we have our different
values for each of these so you have our
intercept our paid organic and social
and then it also shows us error and
information on the error and one of the
really nice things about when you're
working with r you can come down here
and you see where we have our Stars down
here and it says three stars really good
two stars maybe one star probably no
correlation and we can see with all of
these it has three stars on them so out
of three stars we get three stars on all
of these there's no four stars four
stars would mean that you have the exact
same data going in as coming out and
then if we're going to do this we want
to actually run a prediction on here and
that's that we saved our test data 4. so
let's come down here we'll do our
prediction we'll take this variable and
we'll assign it predict model remember
the predict comes from when we imported
that package the ca tools that's all
part of the ca Tools in there so we're
going to predict we're going to use the
model and then we're going to use our
test data pretty straightforward quick
and easy we'll run this and then if we
go ahead and type in the predict it'll
print out what's in that variable and
you'll see down here the predicted
values expects to come out it's going to
say our revenue is and it goes through
and it gives it both the line number and
the actual Revenue value so that's quick
and easy boy we got to prediction really
fast and this is also how you would do
it if you had new data coming in after
this you could predict the revenue based
on these other factors so now that we
have a training model which or we train
the data with our training data or we
trained the model with our training data
and we've done a prediction on our model
with our test data we want to look this
up and we took a quick glance from our
training thing our training said it
trained really well but that's not the
final word on it the final word is going
to be comparing it so we want to go
ahead and do comparing predicted versus
actual values what I'm going to do is
I'm going to do a plot and I'm going to
do our test and we're going to do test
Revenue DOT type equals and we can put
this in as a type type 1 and then or L
and then we have lty equals 1.8 and
we're going to set up for column blue
that's a lot of stuff in there let's go
ahead and just run that so we can see
what that looks like and what's that's
doing it's going to generate this nice
graph we see on the right there's our
graph you can see the data comes up and
down we're plotting the prediction on
there so this is the values we predicted
and then let's go ahead and do lines and
I actually did this backwards so let me
try that again and we'll start with the
red one we're going to do the first one
in red and I want to start with the
actual test Revenue so here's our test
revenue and we'll go ahead and run this
and so we have our red plot over here
and red go ahead and take a look at that
and pull that over you can see how that
looks goes up and down hard to track
there and then we're going to do a
couple things here we'll plot our test
Revenue
and then we'll make it a little pretty
although it's kind of hard to say see
the way I was crunched up here on the
right as far as size and sizing and
everything but we'll go ahead and have
our columns in blue and run our
prediction on there too you can see they
overlapped the two graphs so we have our
test revenue and our prediction and then
finally what I started with is we'll go
ahead and plot the prediction fully on
the bottom and run that and if you look
over here on the graph we put the blue
lines over the red lines and so you'll
see a couple spots where there's red
underneath there but for the most part
our prediction is pretty right on so it
looks really tight looks like a good set
of predictions for what we're working on
and this is where we're looking at the
slide right before we started diving
into the r Studio we can see in the
slide here here's a red this a little
bit better spread out than what I have
on my screen from AR studio and the
graph shows a predicted Revenue we see
that the two lines are very close so
again they're tight it's right on this
is what we're looking for in our
prediction model but it's not good
enough just having a graph and you
always do both and the reason we do both
is you want to have a visual of it
because sometimes you look at these you
get to the graph you're like oh my gosh
what is that and then sometimes you look
at the graph you go that's right on how
come my accuracy doesn't look right and
you realize that your accuracy might be
off or you're plotting it incorrectly so
let's go ahead and look up the accuracy
and we'll use rmsc that's going to be
the variable name we're going to give it
and sqrt the square root of the mean and
mean just means average and then we want
prediction minus
sales revenue and then we're going to
take this whole thing and we're going to
square it so what we've got here is
we're going to go through let's just
explain this formula we're using is I'm
going to look at the what I predicted
for to be and what the actual sales
what's our prediction versus our sales
comparison to the revenue and when we
compare those two we're going to find
the average and then I'm going or we're
going to square each one of those values
and then we're going to average the
square and then find the square root of
that and that's quite a mouthful the
reason we do it this way the reason we
Square the value and then we find the
means is to generate an answer based on
doesn't matter whether it's plus or
minus there's a lot of other formulas
you can use there to check your accuracy
and all kinds of other things you can do
but a quick straightforward way of doing
is just like this and then let's go
ahead and run this
and then we type in the rmsc and they'll
give us an actual printed value out
let's just see what that looks like and
so we have
866.6338 for our accuracy and so we look
at the
866.63 and we compare that to say 50
000. that's pretty close that's that's
actually a pretty good accuracy given
this model takes a little bit more when
you're playing with accuracies and start
dividing out other different aspects of
it to get something you can communicate
better with but you always start with
the square root means that's always a
good place to start use case we'll start
with linear regression and then we'll
jump in and also do a decision tree so
you can see how they are same and how
they differ in the way they function and
what they're used for and while we're
going through the use case you can start
linking the theory behind it connected
to the actual use and as you connect
those dots you can see that by making
changes in the model based on the theory
you can also fine tune it we'll talk
about that briefly as we go through this
for this analysis we'll use the default
cars data set to find the correlation
between variables cars is a standard
built-in data set that makes it
convenient to show linear regression in
a simple and easy to understand fashion
and we'll start with head cars and
stream cards now I've gone ahead and
removed the script on here to make this
easier to see and we don't have to do
any kind of importing of data because
it's already in there I'm just going to
type in head and cars and hit enter and
what you're going to notice is it's
going to display the first six rows one
two three four five six and you'll see
speed and distance now this is a little
bit like a spreadsheet so if you're
using an Excel spreadsheet it should
look the same and this is a standard
data frame kind of setup in this case
whenever you say head it usually lists
the first number of rows depending on
your package in R it starts with one and
then it does the first six rows string
when we do a string of cars it's going
to break it down and show us that it's a
data frame it has 50 objects that's what
the 50 OBS of two variables and then we
have speed the first variable is going
to be at numbers but num stands for 4477
it just starts listing the data there
and distance now I'm assuming the speed
is the speed of the engine otherwise if
it's the speed of the car then the
distance should always be the same and
that would be to be kind of silly but
this is the speed of the engine and
based on the speed of the engine can we
correlate that to the distance let us
visualize the data using scatter plot to
understand the relationship between
predictor and response and I want you to
notice that in this slide a line has
been drawn through the data now when we
first start with data you don't have
that line so as we plot it I want you to
kind of visualize that line there and
just kind of say hey does this stuff
kind of scatter around a line or not
before we actually create the model and
we simply do plot and I'm going to do a
shorthand here cars and I hit enter and
it comes over here to the right and
plots our data for us now because
there's only two variables I don't have
to do anything special I'm going to
expand this over environments we can see
it and you can see you can just
visualize a line right through the data
and it's all clumped along that line
which makes it really nice for doing a
linear regression model now I did
something a little tricky here because
I'm very lazy I typed in plot cars a lot
of times you don't want to do that
because you don't want to plot all the
data we could do plot in this case cars
dollar sign speed the first variable
cars dollar sign distance when I do that
I get the same plot all I'm doing is
telling it to use just these two columns
of data and although the first one is
quick and easy if you only have two
columns of data the second one is what
you really want to do when you're
plotting data like this you want to
control which columns you're using and
then we want to do a correlation
correlation analysis studies the
strength of relationship between two
continuous variables it involves
Computing the correlation coefficient
between the two variables if one
variable consistently increases with
increasing value of the other then they
have a strong positive correlation of
value close to one and again and I can
just type in correlation cars the short
form and we can see we have a nice
correlation going on there between the
two what we really want to do though is
we want to do we want to correlate cars
and then we're going to do the speed
comma cars and the distance and so when
you look at this and actually hit the
enter key in the middle of that which is
fine you can in R do it line by line so
if you're trying to do a bunch of
different columns you might want to do
that to make it easier to read and you
can see here I get the
0.806894 the closer this is to one the
more these correlate so we're saying
there's a pretty good correlation a
positive correlation between the two
variables and if you look at it when I
did just cars which did the correlation
over all the variables you'll see that
speed correlates with speed 100 because
they're the same that's just the nature
of that but when you look at speed
versus distance we get the
0.806849 and if you do distance to
distance you get also one since they're
identical variables so now it's time to
build our linear regress model on the
entire data set to build the
coefficients let's just take a look and
see what that looks like back in our
console I'm going to type in linear mod
and in R we want to do the arrow kind of
like an arrow and a line or in this case
the less than minus sign that's the same
as assigning whatever we're going to put
after it to this variable so we're
creating the linear variable LM stands
for linear module and we're going to
look at speed and distance so we put the
little squiggly bracket between them
this lets R know we're going to deal
with these two columns comma data equals
cars and when I hit enter on here we've
generated our linear mod now we want to
go ahead and summarize it and we simply
do a summary and then brackets linear
mod and it generates all kinds of
information on our model so we can
explore just how well this model is
fitting the data we have right now now
if you've done linear regression and
other packages and scripts you're going
to see that this is so easy to explore
data in R so even some somebody who's
working in say python or or spark Hadoop
coming back to the r console to do some
basic exploration of the data is very
beneficial and if you use just our R
goes into all kinds of different
packages and you can even do cluster
computations through H2O are there's a
lot of cool things this is what makes
ours so wonderful is how easily we can
summarize something like a linear model
and to explore this data let's go back
to the slide and we'll see here where it
says the residuals the first one Q
stands for first quadrant median third
quadrant Max coefficients and we first
want to do is look at the estimate
standard deviation on here and you'll
see The Intercept is at minus
17.5791 and speed
3.9324 so we can compute the distance
equals to The Intercept plus the beta
times the speed which just means that we
can assign a distance equal to minus
17.579 plus the 3.932 times the speed
the value of P should be less than 0.05
for the model to be statistically
significant and this is one of the
things I love about R you can see right
down here we punched in the numbers and
it even tells you the significant codes
so if you're trying to guess or remember
it tells you right away uh hey this 1.49
to the minus 12 is way below 0.001 on
there and even puts three stars next to
it so you can see that that is a very
high correlation and you can see the
0.0123 gets one star because it is
greater than the 0.05 or it's less than
the 0.05 so this shows that there's a
very high correlation statistically is
very significant so now we're going to
go ahead and create a training and a
test data set and the first thing we
want to do is we want to set the seed so
the sample can be recreated for future
use remember in all these different
regression models they usually have some
randomization going on in the back to
kind of fit it and guess where it's
going to go and if you want everything
to match you want to start with the same
seed in that randomizer that way it
recreates it identical every time you
run it on a different computer and just
like working with data in any package
we're going to create indices for the
training data and we're going to model
the training data and then we're also
going to do the test data and build our
model on the training data let's walk
through that and see what that looks
like in R and I actually mistyped that
one let's type in set dot seed to set
our seed for the 100 let's go training
row index and that's our name we're
making up for our variable and we're
going to set that to sample Now sample
is a command in R so we're going to take
a random sample of some of the data and
then we're going to do one colon in rows
cars so this is the number of rows in
cars and we're going to start with one
and Sample them so Row one of the data
we're skipping any of the titles on the
top and then in the sample it has two
variables that go in the first one is
the in rows of cars and then you want to
do
0.8 times in rows of cars this basically
says that we're going to take 80 percent
of all the rows in the car sample we'll
hit enter to go and run that and we see
here that I had an error and that is
because it's in row actually put an S on
there that's something I do a lot on
we'll just fix that real quick brings up
a point that if you use your up down
arrow you can quickly paste through the
last things you typed in and then you
can reuse them so there we go now I have
my training row index which is basically
a list of all the rows we're going to
use and now that we have a training row
index we'll go ahead and create our
training data variable and we'll assign
that cars and we'll put that as a
training row index and this is supposed
to be brackets because we're dealing
with a array type format we want to do
the training row index comma so we just
need the index of the row and as far as
the columns we want all the columns so
here we have our training data and now
we set up a training data we also need
our test data and with our test data
we'll assign that also to cars and
because we use the training row index
and we use the sample to create it we
can simply do a minus sign training
index comma so it's identical to the
training data but the test data is going
to be the ones the rows that were not
included in the random sample of 80
percent so it's going to be twenty
percent of the data and of course it's
very easy to do mistakes on here so
we'll come back into this bring back up
the error and then we have training the
training index training row index there
we go very easy quick error is in R so
now we have our training data and our
test data so we have 80 in training data
and 20 percent in test data and let's go
ahead and create our model we'll call it
LM mod and this is identical to what we
did earlier here's our linear model
we're going to have our two different
columns if remember above we had to tell
out which columns we wanted and we'll do
distance
and speed and then the data we're going
to set equal to training data so as
opposed to doing all of cars we want to
use just the training data on here and
now that we've created a model off of
the training data we need to go ahead
and run our prediction off of our test
data we want to see how the test data
which has nothing to do with the model
so far how well it fits and we'll go
ahead and call it distance predict
there's our assignment so we're going to
assign the value to it and with r we
type in predict and then we called our
model we go ahead and pull up our model
LM mod and so we're going to use that
model and then we want to put in the
test data here's our test data and so
now we're creating the distance predict
variable and we're going to put all the
information as far as predicting on our
tested data and we'll run that just hit
the enter key and then if you remember
from before we want to review the model
diagnostic measures and so we're going
to go in here and do a summary and
you'll here we have a couple different
things going on but let's go ahead and
take a summary of this and just walk
through what this means so summary and
then we called it LM mod and we hit
enter and it pulls it up and we have a
nice summary of our LM mod and the first
thing we're going to note is that the
data that's right now in our LM mod that
we're summarizing is our training data
and let's go back to the slide and
highlight this so the data equals the
training data that's where the lmod
comes in residuals we have our minimum
our first quarter medium third quarter
and the max or quadrant not quarter
you'd think I was doing a business
analysis as opposed uh into the year
taxes in first quarter versus quadrant
we look at our coefficient we can see
where our intercept is and our speed is
and we note over here our significance
codes so they all match up so a simple
correlation between the actuals and the
predicted values can be used as a form
of accuracy measurement so we took a
look at the model we created and now we
need to take our predictions and
accurate it is on the data that we
didn't use to program the linear model
so let's create a variable called
actuals underscore predicts and assign
it data frame this is how we create a
data frame as we just assign data.frame
and we'll do a c bind and in our C bind
we're going to take our data and we're
going to create a column called actuals
so this is our choice to name actuals
this is going to equal test data and I'm
going to use a dollar sign and distance
we're running out a little room there so
let me pull this over so we can see it
better there we go distance and then we
also want to take and compare that to
what we predicted for the our other data
and we'll call this column predicted and
that's going to equal our distance
predict and remember distance predict is
set to the predicted values of our test
data so what this is is we're saying hey
here's our test data the actual data and
the distance and then we have what we
predicted that distance to be and we'll
go ahead and assign that and we can do a
quick head
actuals predicts there we go remember
head shows this it's a data frame so
it's going to show us the labels and the
first set of data in this case you'll
notice that the rows have a different
count they're not one two three four
five six well we randomly picked 20 of
the data so this is the first six rows
of that random selection which comes out
as 1 4 8 20 26 31 and we have the
actuals so the actual value is 2 and the
predicted value in this first one is is
minus five so they're way off 22 7 26 20
26 37 54 to 42 50 to 50. so one of these
is actually pretty right on where a lot
of them are really off at the beginning
let's just see what that looks like
though because just eyeballing the first
six rows does not tell us what's really
going on so let's create another
variable correlation accuracy and we're
going to assign this correlation cor
remember we do a COR and we have our
actual predictions so let's just see how
our actual values versus the prediction
correlate with each other and we sign
that One X
score predicts there we go let it auto
finish for me and we can just go ahead
and type in correlation accuracy and see
what that looks like so we have an
actual one a predicts 0.8 and you can
see how they kind of correlate we have
the 0.82 and if you remember from before
we're looking for either 0.001 0.01 0.05
0.1 that is the p-value which we're not
looking at here this is not based on the
p-value this is based on we looked at
earlier with correlation that the closer
to one the closer the value is r and so
0.82 gets upwards of one so you see that
there's a normal pretty much a
correlation in here but we want to dig a
Little Deeper because it doesn't really
tell us how accurate it is for that
we're going to use another tool for that
we're going to calculate the min max
accuracy and make and the min max
accuracy equals the mean value of the
minimal actuals and predicts over the
max value of the actuals and predicts
and and then the mean absolute
percentage error or mape as it's called
Equals the mean of the absolutes predict
it's minus actuals over the actuals
that's a lot to follow as far as
remembering all these different math and
theory behind it cool thing though is
it's all done pretty much for you so you
can compute all the error matrixes in
one go using the regress eval function
in dmwr package since this is the first
time I've used this install I'm going to
have to install the dmwr package so we
can actually install it two different
ways if we remember we talked about
installing package earlier we can go
under Tools and install packages and I
certainly could type in
dmwr it even comes up and lets me know
that's one of the main packages up there
well that's a tool of the rstudio setup
you can also install this using the
console we simply type in install dot
you can even see here it comes up
install packages and then
dmwr and when I hit enter I should do
the same thing as the other one does it
goes through and installs the dmwr
package it takes just a moment to zip
through all the different package setup
and then the format for dmwr is DM WR
we're going to go colon colon we are
specifically looking at the
regression.eval and then we're going to
do actuals underscore predicts and we'll
go ahead and put in the individual
columns on this one so we have actuals I
love the auto type typing and then again
actuals predicts and this time we want
to do it against the predicteds and
we'll go ahead and hit enter on here and
you'll see in here it comes up with our
Mae MSE rmsc and the mape values today
we're going to cover logistic regression
in the our programming language logistic
regression is kind of a misnomer in that
one most people think of regression they
think of linear regression which is a
machine learning algorithm for
continuous variables however logistic
regression is a classification algorithm
not a continuous variable prediction
algorithm logistic regression is also
sometimes called logic regression in
this video we are going to learn why we
would use regression as a predictive
algorithm what is regression the
different types of regression as I've
already mentioned some regression
algorithms are classification algorithms
and some are continuous variable
algorithms why use logistic regression
what is logistic regression and then
we'll look at a use case a College
admission using logistic regression so
why would we use regression well let's
say we had a website and our Revenue was
based on the traffic that we could drive
to that website whether through r d or
marketing and we wanted to predict the
revenue based on site traffic and the
website traffic would be related to the
revenue we could generate the more
traffic driven to our website then the
higher our revenue or at least that's
what we would intuitively assume and so
we need to predict the revenue based on
our website traffic here we have the
plot of Revenue versus website traffic
traffic would be considered the
independent variable and revenue would
be the dependent variable often the
independent variable or variables if we
had more than one could be called the
explanatory variables and the dependent
variable would be called the response
variable however we typically refer to
them as independent and dependent
variables so our intuition tells us that
the independent variable drives the
dependent variable and if there is some
relationship between the two variables
and we would say that there is a
correlation between the two variables
and then we may be able to use the
independent variable to make predictions
about the dependent variable if you look
at the chart on the right you'll see
there is a clear Trend between website
traffic and revenue as website traffic
increases the revenue increases and we
could draw a line to show that
relationship and then we could use that
line as a predictor line so for example
what will Revenue be if our traffic is
4.5 K we see that when the traffic is
around 4 500 the revenue is around 13
000 and if we could draw a perpendicular
line from 4.5 K on the axis on the
x-axis the traffic axis up to the orange
regression line sometimes called the
line of best fit then we could draw
another line over to the y-axis the
revenue axis and we could see where it
lands and that would be the prediction
so in this exam simple when the traffic
is around 45
000 hits the predicted revenue is around
thirteen thousand normally we wouldn't
actually draw those lines we would
generate an equation and we would call
that equation a model and we could plug
the independent variable into the
equation to generate the dependent
variable output which we would call our
prediction so what is regression
regression is a statistical relationship
between two or more variables where a
change in the independent variable is
associated with a change in the
dependent variable it's important to
note that at all variables are related
to each other for example a person's
favorite color may not be related to
revenue from a website here the change
in one variable height is closely
associated with the change in the other
variable age this makes intuitive sense
as you get older from when you're born
you get taller and it seems to make
sense if we plot that data we would see
those green points on the graph up to
some certain age where growth would
taper off and the plot in the middle of
the screen we see the clear linear
relationship between age and height
which is indicated by the solid red line
we sometimes call that line a trend line
or a regression line or the line of best
fit and we see that the height is the
dependent variable and age is the
independent variable of course you might
ask doesn't height depend on other
factors of course it does but here we're
looking at the relationship between two
variables one independent and one
dependent age and height there are
various types of regression linear
regression logistic regression multiple
linear regression polynomial regression
and there are others decision tree
regression random Forest regression but
linear regression is probably the most
well known by definition when there is a
linear relationship between a dependent
variable which is continuous in an
independent variable which is continuous
or discrete we would use linear
regression when the Y value in the graph
is categorical such as yes or no true or
false they voted they did not vote they
purchased something they did not
purchase something it depends on the X
variable logistic regression is when the
Y value in the graph is categorical in
nature for example yes no purchased
don't purchase voted did not vote and it
depends on the X variable notice the
trend line for linear regression and the
line for logistic regression they're
different more on that later and there's
polynomial regression as well when the
relation between the dependent variable
Y and the independent variable X is in
the nth degree of X sometimes we say an
nth degree polynomial of X in this
picture you can see that the
relationship is not linear there's a
curve to that best fit trend line so why
would we use logistic regression and we
need to understand why we would use
Logistics Russian and that linear
regression picking the machine learning
algorithm for your problem is no small
task and it really behooves us to
understand the difference between these
machine learning algorithms linear
regression answers the question how much
so in our earlier example if website
traffic grows then how much would
Revenue grow or as logistic regression
would answer what will happen or not
happen linear regression in general is
used to predict a continuous variable
like height and weight logistic
regression is used when a response
variable only has two outcomes yes or no
true or false often we refer to logistic
regression as a binary classifier since
there are only two outcomes so let's try
to understand this with an example let's
say we have a startup company and we are
trying to figure out whether the startup
will be profitable or not that's binary
with two possible outcomes profitable or
not profitable and let's use initial
funding to be the independent variable
here we have a graph that shows funding
versus profit and it appears linear once
again our intuition tells us that the
more funding a startup has the more
profitable it will be but of course data
science doesn't depend on intuition it
depends on data but this graph does not
tell whether the startup will be
profitable yes or no it only states that
with an increase in funding The Profit
also increases that's not binary if we
wanted to predict how much profit then
linear regression would be useful but
that's not what we are being asked hence
we need to make use of logistic
regression which has two outcomes in our
case profitable and not profitable so
let's draw a graph again the x-axis will
be our independent variable funding and
the y-axis will no longer be the
dependent variable profit but it will be
the probability of profit for example if
you look at a company with a funding of
say 40 then the probability that that
that company will be profitable is
around 0.8 or 80 percent based on the
best fit line called a sigmaid curve in
the example we plotted several companies
some with 10 15 20 some with 50 60 or 70
or 65 and we indicated whether they were
zero not profitable or a one profitable
on the graph and this is how we should
think of logistic regression in this
example given the amount of funding we
calculate the probability that a company
will be profitable or not profitable and
if we use the threshold line of 50 then
we have our classifier if the
probability is fifty percent or higher
the company is profitable if the
probability is lower than 50 it's not
profitable so what is logistic
regression this is a linear regression
graph so let's compare linear regression
to logistic regression and take a look
at the trend line that describes the
model it's a straight line which is why
we call it linear regression but using
linear regression we can't really divide
the output into two two distinct
categories yes or no to divide our
results into two categories we would
have to clip the line between zero and
one if you recall probabilities can only
be between zero and one and if we're
going to use probability on the y-axis
then we can't have anything that is
below zero or above one thus we would
have to clip the line and once we
clipped the line we see that the
resulting curve cannot be represented in
a linear equation so for logistic
regression we will make use of a sigmoid
function and the sigmoid curve is the
line of best fit notice that it's not
linear but it does satisfy our
requirement of using a single line that
does not need to be clipped for linear
regression we would use an equation of a
straight line Y equals B sub zero plus b
sub 1 times x x being the independent
variable y being the dependent variable
but as we've said we cannot use a linear
equation for binary predictions so we
need to use the sigmoid function which
is represented by the equation P equals
one divided by the quantity one plus e
to the minus y e being the base of the
natural logs then taking the log of both
sides and solving we get our sigmoid
function and graphing it we get our
logistic regression line of best fit the
applications for logistic regression are
endless here we might have a couple of
gardeners or farmers and one farmer says
I am planning to grow plants in my
backyard and I want to know whether my
trees will get infested with bugs which
I'm sure is a huge problem and these
days the fewer pesticides we use the
better off we are for health reasons the
young lady says I can use logistic
regression in a model to predict it for
you and the other farmer says well how
is logistic regression going to help but
we know that healthy versus not healthy
is a binary classification and we can
use a binary classifier like logistic
regression to solve this problem which
is what the young lady has in mind if we
have the data we can model the the data
and generate a sigmoid function that
best fits our data and then use the
probability of a healthy tree versus a
not healthy tree or an infested tree
once again we see our sigmoid line of
best fit and some points that represent
healthy trees and not healthy trees once
again we plot our sigmoid curve scratch
that and once again once our sigmoid
curve is plotted and our threshold is
set almost always at 50 percent we can
use the sigmoid curve and calculate the
probabilities and here the independent
variable of width which I assume is an
application of pesticides or no
pesticides to determine whether or not
the probability of healthy is greater
than 50 percent the threshold or less
than 50 percent the threshold and now
let's take a use case of a College
admission problem of course we can't
solve anything using data science if we
don't know what the problem is so we
need a problem statement and here the
problem statement is simple we are given
a data set and we need to predict
whether a candidate will get admission
in a desired college or not based on
their GPA and college rank so the very
first thing we need to do is import the
data set and if it's a small enough data
set and it can fit into our computer
memory then we are golden otherwise we
have some work to do the data set that
we were given is in CSV format comma
separated values CSV files are easily
imported into our environment once we
import the data we next need to select
and import the libraries that we will
need although R is a great programming
language with a lot of built-in
functions it is easily and powerfully
extended by the use of libraries and
packages then we need to split the data
set into a training set and a test set
it's important to note that the data set
that we've imported that we were given
has the GPS and college ranks for
several students but it also has is a
column that indicates whether those
students were admitted or not so what
we're saying is that the data set has
the answers and if you think about it it
must how could we possibly train a model
have a model learn if we didn't know the
answers already that's why it's called
machine learning so we train the model
and then we test the model once we split
the data into training and test sets we
will apply our regression on the two
independent variables GPA and rank
generate the model and then run the test
set through the model once that is
complete we will validate the model to
see how well it performed so now it's
demo time so here we have our studio my
favorite IDE or integrated development
environment and I have a script already
composed to run our logistic regression
on the problem at hand which is our
College admissions problem so let's just
walk down the script before I run it and
talk about the various points in the
script so first Define the problem while
the problem was defined and you really
can't do anything in data science
without a clear problem definition once
the problem is defined you can load your
libraries acquire your data set the
working directory in my case I'm on
Windows explore the data Munch the data
if necessary and then prepare the data
scale the data if necessary split the
data into train and test data sets and
train the model using the training data
and run the test data through the model
and then validate the model for accuracy
and precision Etc so here we are going
to load our libraries I'm going to use a
package called CA tools and now that the
library is loaded I'm going to set my
working directory and if I come over
here to the files tab you'll see that
there is my working directory and
networking directory there's a file
called binary.csv and that's the CSV the
comma separated value file that the
college gave me I'm going to ingest and
then look at that data and as you can
see it has four columns GRE GPA rank and
then the answer column admit whether or
not someone was admitted which would be
a one or not admitted which would be a
zero and if we come over to the right
and we can look and see some of the
first few values of each of those four
columns now let's split the data we're
going to take this my data frame and
split it into two a training set and a
test set and the ratio we're going to
use is 80 20. so 80 percent of the data
will go into the training set and 20
will go into the test set now that ratio
could be 60 40 it could be 70 30.
typically it really depends on the size
of your data how much data you have but
this is for our example and for our
purposes 80 20 is perfect next we'll do
a little data munging in general you
munch the data early on after ingestion
and you really have to be careful in
this case we don't have any missing
values we don't have any real outliers
our data was pretty clean when we got it
and ingested it but in general that's
not the case and a lot of work and a lot
of attention needs to be paid to the
munging process here we're just going to
take our data the admission column and
the rank column and convert them to
categorical variables right now they're
integers as you can see on the right
hand side and once I run these two lines
they will be converted to factors and
all the fun stuff we're going to use the
glm function the general linear model
function to train our logistic
regression model and the dependent
variable is admit and the independent
variables are GPA and rank and the
little tilde sign here says the
dependent variable will be a function of
GPA and rank the two independent
variables the data will be the training
set and the family will be binomial and
binomial indicates that it's a binary
classifier it's a logistic regression
problem there is it is we ran our model
and there's a summary of our model you
can see that there is some statistical
significance in GPA and in Rank by the
coefficients and output of the model so
next let's run the test data through the
model
and once we have done all that we can
now set up a confusion Matrix and look
at our predictions versus the actual
values again this is important we had
the answers and now we took and we
predicted some answers so hopefully our
predicted answers match up with the
actual answers we'll run a confusion
Matrix as you can see the predicted
values versus the actual values and it's
important here to note that if it was
predicted false and it was actually
false and we see 189 or if it was
predicted true and it was actually true
which is 27 we did well on those but
there are a few that were predicted
incorrectly some were predicted true but
were actually false some were predicted
false that were actually true and now
we'll confirm what our percentage
accuracy is 72 percent not bad but we
could probably do better how we'll leave
that to another video we'll be doing
part one in a two-part series decision
tree followed by random Forest because
decision tree is part of the random
Forest what's in it for you first we'll
cover what is a decision tree what
problems can be solved using decision
trees how does a decision tree work and
then we'll dive into a use case survival
prediction in R so I'll be using the r
platform on this one so what is a
decision tree and here we have kind of a
new looking front panel of a car driving
down the street and we have left or
right should come into an intersection
you got to decide which way to go you're
going to go left are you going to go
right away or go so do you go right away
we have a green light so probably want
to go right away after you check for
cross traffic make sure no one is asleep
at the will or talking on their cell
phone decision tree is a tree shaped
algorithm used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so another
example is we have a shopkeeper very
nondescript shopkeeper kind of a little
spooky without the eyes so we have a
shopkeeper and he wants to organize his
stall so I must organize my stallions
looking around trying to figure out what
the best way to stack all his goods are
and he has some broccoli some oranges
and some carrots this is kind of a nice
example because we can see where some of
the colors and shapes overlap or others
don't and so you can create a tree out
of this very easily and say is it
colored orange if it's not well it goes
into one stack well that happens to be
all their broccoli and if it is colored
orange then it goes into another stack
and you're like well that's still kind
of chaotic you know people are looking
at carrots and oranges a very strange
combination to put in a box so the next
question might be is it round and if it
is then yes you put the oranges into one
box and no that means it's carrots we
put it in the other box and you can see
that a lot of stuff we do in life easily
can fall into like a decision tree how
do you decide something you know does it
go left does it go right yes or no and
even with this we even have a number of
different end choices broccoli carrots
and oranges so what kind of problems
does this solve what problems can be
solved by using a decision tree
classification we're dealing with a
classification object belong things and
from our example we just looked at a
character's orange well broccoli is
green I guess it's nondescript day
without the faces I love it because a
lot of times you're looking at data you
really don't want to know what exactly
the data is but you're sorting it so you
know like this kind of represents data
that you really don't know exactly where
it's coming from just kind of a fun
thing regression regression is another
problem the biggest can be solved
regression problems have continuous or
numerical valued output variables
example predicting the profits of a
company so we have two different primary
problems we solve for we solve for
classification is it green or is it
orange and we solve for regression which
is a continual number so you know if
you're doing stocks this would be a
dollar value that ranges anywhere from
zero to thousands of dollars how does a
decision tree work terms you must know
first so before we dive into the
decision tree let's look at some of the
terminology for the decision tree we
have notes each internal node in a
decision tree is a test which splits the
objects into different categories and
continuing with our vegetable stand
example we have broccoli no it's not
orange and oranges and carrots are and
so on so you can see right there where
it splits that's a note where the Orange
is split and the carrots split into each
of their own groups and each one of the
splits is a node the very top node of
the decision tree is called the root
node so the very first one we started
off where we split it is a colored
orange and you can see that pointed out
nice and neatly there this is a note at
the top each external node in a decision
tree is called the leaf node the leaf
node is the output and you can see down
here we have our broccoli and we have
our carrots and our oranges each one of
those is a leaf node so to quickly
rehash our terms we have anywhere there
is a split that's a node and if it's at
the very top of the tree that's the root
node and if you're at the very bottom of
the tree where you have a final answer
that is the leaf nodes you have a root
note a leaf node and then everything
else is just a generic node so one of
the most important terms or concepts
that powers a decision tree is entropy
entropy is a measure of the messiness of
your data collection the Messier or more
random your data higher will be the
entropy so we can see here we have
broccoli oranges and carrots are all
mixed together and it's very chaotic and
you could say this collection has high
entropy and if we sort out the carrots
out of here in I guess just one of the
broccoli I don't know where the other
broccoli went you could say if you have
just the oranges and the broccoli this
is a lower entropy they say this
collection has low entropy but really
it's higher and lower one is higher
lower than the other one and from
entropy we get Information Gain
information is the decrease obtained in
entropy by splitting the data set u
based on some conditioning so we have
our information one which we can
actually there's actual computations and
so we have our E1 which is put in there
for our entropy value at the base node
or root node and we have 2 A2 which is a
leaf node and so we can actually
calculate there's calculations for an
entropy and we actually look at those
two values the entropy and we take that
we have E1 is greater than E2 therefore
the Information Gain equals E1 minus E2
so here we have another example we're
actually going to attach some values to
this one in just a moment so we're going
to move away from the fruit and we're
going to go to everybody's favorite
thing organizing a child's closet and
here we have a young lady waving at us
hi my cupboard is a mess I must organize
my stuff and we're going to classify the
objects based on their attribute set
using a decision tree we can look at it
we have a shape a size and a label and a
number and I'm going to go ahead and
look at the labels because that's really
what's key on this one is we have a
couple balls in here some books cards
and blocks and if you look at that when
you have something that's a ball that's
round so it's a very different shape the
book card and blocks are all rectangular
but the books are a different size so
the books have like a size six I guess
you think of them as very large cards a
size four so they're not quite as big
and the blocks or little Lego blocks it
looks like kind of fun to stack on there
and then we can actually quantify this
and we can actually say hey we got we
have different number is we have two
balls two books one card four blocks and
we split at each level based on certain
conditions on the attributes so
splitting aims at reducing the entropy
and we have a formula our first actual
formula you'll see happens in the
background when we're running these
different modules in R and it looks a
little complicated but we can break that
up and simplify that for you so we see
this formula the negative sum of I of x
equals the probability of one value of x
times the log of two probability value
of x the term probability value of x
it's probably easiest to understand if
we go ahead and put the numbers in there
so you can actually see what we're
looking at and so we plug the numbers in
there we look at the probability of the
value of x well if we do the number of
balls there's two balls and the total
number of items is nine so we have a
probability of any one object being two
out of nine so that's pretty
straightforward math when you look at
the numbers you can actually see that
very easily and so we can calculate our
entropy of two over nine times the
squared log of 2 over 9 plus 1 9 the log
squared of one over nine plus four over
nine times the log square root of 4 over
9. so our whole group is the sum of all
the entropies and so when we look at
that we have the entropy of the balls
which is the two over nine rectangles
two over nine are mean books two over
nine cards one over nine in the blocks
four over nine and we just plug those
numbers in there and we get an actual
value of
1.8282 so what the heck does a module do
with that number well now we must find
the conditions for our split every split
must give us the maximum achievable
Information Gain and so we have our
first entropy value 1.8282 and it turns
out when you compare all the different
individual entropy values for the balls
for the books for the cards for the
blocks rectangles you find out that the
biggest split is going to to be in the
shape and it's going to be our first
split will be on the shape that will
directly segregate the balls out so that
they'll split up a huge group from one
from the other and so when we compute
that we end up with E2 which is all of
our rectangles and then we have a leaf
node which is the balls and so with our
E2 we see that 1.3784 is much less than
the 1.8282 and so our second split will
be on the size as that will directly
sacred bucks and so how we do that we
can see that if its size is greater than
5 all the books go to one side while the
cards and the blocks go to the other and
again we have our E3 which equals 0.716
which because it hits zero we can say
all our objects are now classified with
a hundred percent accuracy if it was
only that easy to clean the kids closets
and you can see we have a nice drawing
that shows you where all the leaf nodes
are in this in which case we have the
balls the books the blocks and the cars
are part of the leaf node and the root
node is our first split and we have all
the objects and we're splitting them by
rectangle by shape so we're going to
dive into the use case and in this case
we're going to get a little morbid there
I am behind my desk that's definitely
not me I don't have that big of a chin
but I do usually have a cup of coffee
and it looks kind of like that it's
sitting next to me on my desk so the use
case is going to be survival prediction
in R and let's Implement a
classification of data set based on
Information Gain this is going to use
the ID3 algorithm don't let that scare
you that's the most common algorithm
they use to calculate the decision tree
there's a couple different ways they can
calculate the entropy but the formula is
all the same behind it so ID3 is most
common in R and then we'll be using the
r studio for our interface for our IDE
so our studio is free to download
There's the free version of course
there's an Enterprise version and
there's all kinds of different choices
in there but one of the wonderful things
about R is that it's been an open source
for a very long time and is very well
developed it's also very quick and easy
to use on a lot of things so this is
going to be in the r Studio IDE there's
some other interfaces but this is I
would suggest using the r Studio it's
the most common one and if you remember
I said this is going to be a little
morbid because we're talking about how
many people survived and died on these
ships so in this case we have a nice
vacation cruise ship going on there or
I'm not sure what that is with the
tugboat so we have a ship and it had 20
lifeboats the lifeboats were distributed
based on the class gender and age of the
passengers we will develop a model that
recognizes the relationship between
these factors and predicts the survival
of a passenger accordingly so we want to
predict whether the person is going to
survive or die in a shipwreck and we'll
be using a data set which specifies if a
passenger on a ship survived its wreck
or not so we're going to look at this
data and if you open it up into a
spreadsheet and don't forget you can
always put a note on the YouTube video
down below and we will be monitoring
that you can request the data set sent
to you or more correspondence you can
also go to www
www.simplylearn.com and request this
data set too it's just a simple CSV file
we'll send out and you can see right
here we have survived so one indicates a
person survived the wreck zero they
didn't make it they were under the water
and the luxury class of the cabin so if
they were in you know what what value is
like one two three depending on what
luxury class they were and then we have
this is kind of interesting how many
siblings they had so it's kind of an
interesting added statistic in there
number of parents on board and disembark
location so where the destination is
so here we've opened up our studio and
if this is your first time in our studio
you'll notice that it opens up
standardly in three panes the upper left
is for text documents you're bringing in
and then the bottom left is the actual
commands is their process
and then on the right hand side you have
your environment set up on there now
I've zoomed in with my font a little
oversized in fact we can even take that
up one more size and see if we can get a
larger setup view here we go so I've set
the font for 18 probably a lot larger
than you need to work on a project and
the first thing I'm going to do is on
the right hand panel we're going to be
working with plots so I'm going to click
on the little plot tab up there and I'm
just going to collapse that over to the
side for right now and then I'm going to
open up the bottom one and you'll see on
the top I actually have two different
tabs team in the back was really nice to
set up the whole package for what we're
working on here and we'll go through
this line by line and then you'll see as
we execute the different lines are going
to appear down below so I'll be flipping
between these two left panels and let me
go backwards just for a second here
we're going to do this part so let's
take a look at the installs
and if you look at the installs and when
I'm not going to actually run the
installs because I've already run them
on my computer so these are already
installed in my R packages and I don't
have to rerun them we have a number of
packages we're bringing in to our
because that's how our functions and the
first number of packages are all part of
our decision tree so our F selector our
R part our carrot with the dependencies
equal true and our dplyr and our R part
plot oh that's a mouthful you'll need to
import all of these in your setup
and the first one which is your F
selector compute your Chi Squared your
information gain your entropy all of
those formulas are a part of the bring
it in that's what that package is the r
part is your partitioning of your
decision tree so these are your primary
two decision tree modules that we're
bringing in
the carrot is apart for actually
splitting apart the data because we
always want to do a test set a train set
so they built a package carrot to kind
of handle all those you'll see carrot
used a lot of other machine learning
packages when you're doing the r the d p
l y r is for mutating your data so you
can sum it you can classify it you can
filter it that's all part of the DPL yr
and then our part has another piece
called plot and that's where helping us
plot the data as we sort out the tree
because the r part creates a tree but
you still want to be able to plot it and
then we come down here and we have some
additional tools we're going to work
with a spreadsheet this is a Microsoft
Access spreadsheet so we're going to use
the xlsx package to import it and you
might think that's a little outdated
because I know when I'm doing any new
projects I try to save my data into a
comma separated variable file or
something more standardized but a lot of
times you'll end up with these old
databases where they're exporting data
and their export comes in an Excel
spreadsheet and guess what this is a
Time Saver instead of opening up the
spreadsheet re-saving it as a comma
separated variable file you can just
open it right up in R which is really
nice and then we have our data tree
which goes right along with displaying
the data so we have our rpart.plot and
we're going to put that into the data
tree so if a nice visual and finally you
need to install the package C8 tools and
CA tools is another package used for
General manipulation of your data and
your vectors so it also has a split
function for training data I know we
have another package for that but both
those packages fit in there as far as
the working with the data so a lot of
times you'll see these loaded in there
together and you'll see in a moment
we'll import the elementary stat learn
package also which is very generic
working with data setup as far as
statistics and data processing now
because my Java setup is a little
different because I use a developer
package well the latest update of the
developer package and the r are
struggling to see each other so I need
to go ahead and add this in chances are
you don't need to worry about this but
if you do get an R Java error you'll
need to go ahead and add an align to set
your environment and I'm just going to
set the Java home I went ahead and
looked up the last solid JRE folder and
you'll see under program files Java you
can look them all up to make sure it's
the JRE and not the jdk the difference
between those is one is a standard
executable that's a JRE folder that is a
folder not an actual file and the jdk
deals more with developer side on things
and I'm going to go ahead and run this
and if you're in R you can run these
lines individually by holding your
control key down and entering the enter
button so I've now loaded my workspace
and set my environment here and we can
actually look and just make sure a
system Dot
git environment is the opposite one and
I can just look real quick and say hey
what's my Java home set to
and if I run that
whoops I forgot to put brackets around
it there we go
if I do that you'll see that it's set to
the jdk18025
and again we're looking at the split
screen and let me just move this up here
a little bit and let me hit the enter
key a bunch of times it comes up on the
screen
when I run it and I'm running it line by
line the Run text then appears down here
and this is what's actually being
executed so I could just as easily type
it in down here as putting it up here on
the top part
that's just a little bit of R studio and
working with our studio
so I've shown you the installs and again
I've already installed it on my computer
so it takes a minute or two to install
it
we need to go ahead and then bring those
libraries in to work with so basically
we're going through all the different
libraries we're using element stat learn
is a standard R Library so it should
already be installed you don't have to
install that one and I can just go right
down them and you'll see as I install
them if they show up on the bottom and
every time you go to run a new setup
you need to go ahead and install these
pull the libraries in you got to tell
the tell your r or Studio these are the
libraries you're using
and you can see right down here that
as it executes them
it has all the different things one of
them had like a couple different parts
to it so loaded the lattice and the
ggplot2
really nothing to worry too much unless
you see errors down here so if you start
getting error codes then you might have
to go troubleshoot and find out why it's
not installing correctly or did it
install correctly
but it's pretty straightforward we've
covered all the libraries
and again if you want a copy of this
code simply add a comment Down Below on
the YouTube video or visit
www.simplylearn.com and they'll be happy
to send you a copy of the base code
the next step is we want to go ahead and
load the Excel file
after setting the working directory
so let's go ahead and set the working
directory scwwd is a command for that in
r
and then this is wherever you have
downloaded your data to in your files
too A lot of times if you get the zipped
framework sent to you it will unzip all
into one location and then you got to
let that location up and put that in
here a lot of times it automatically
sets up for you if you all if you're
working the same directory in this case
you can see I've pasted in
a very lengthy
path because I have this as part of my
documents my business docs and simply
learn and marketing videos and so on I'm
going to go ahead and do the control
enter and run that so now my working
directory is set and you can see down
below it's executed this on the console
down here
and if I open up that working directory
you can see I have a ship XLS file
that's the data we're going to look at
and we looked at that on the slide you
could also open this up and I will want
to go ahead and open it up with a
notepad
by default it'll open up as a
spreadsheet I hope it is an Excel file
so I would have to open it up as an
actual spreadsheet wasn't thinking that
one through this is one of the problems
with saving stuff as a proprietary ships
file even as something as widely used as
Microsoft Excel spreadsheet but when we
open up the spreadsheet you can see here
the same data we looked at before
this was coming up in this file and so I
take this file we can go ahead and let's
um create a variable we'll call it add
and we're going to assign it
that's what the lesser than Dash means
if you've never used R before we're just
going to assign it a ship XLS
and then I'll do my control enter and
you'll see it run down here ship
add is assigned ship.xls our Excel
spreadsheet on there
and then let's have another variable
we'll call it DF for data frame and
we're going to assign this read
LSX and that's from the library SLX so
we just import it
and we want to read the file add
because we just created that variable
with the ship.xls
and I didn't catch this right away but
you'll see when we open it up in a
spreadsheet
it might be hard to see in your video
screen it has a the first sheet is
called ship one so this data is on the
page ship one and the Excel spreadsheet
and we got to make sure that we tell the
reader to look for that
and so we can simply do that in our
command line
to name
equals
and it was ship one on there
so we go ahead and hit the control enter
and run this line and it brings it down
below and executes it it's now reading
in that data from that spreadsheet
that's what's going on and it takes just
a moment to go ahead and read it in
and then with any data processing we
need to select the meaningful columns
for the prediction so this is important
that we sort through our data and set it
correctly so that whatever we're feeding
it into can read it correctly
we can do this with DF
we're going to reassign it and we're
going to select
and from there we're going to select DF
as our main data frame going in
and then list the columns that we want
if we look at the data we have survived
we have a class we have a name sex and
age
and then there's siblings and parents we
really don't want to know the name
because we don't need the name to run
this on here and then we got to decide
which one of these we want to work with
and the guys in the back played with the
data a little bit and they came up with
the following columns
survived which we need definitely
because that's what we're actually
trying to figure out is whether we're
going to survive or not what class there
which which class of the boat they're
riding in with their first class second
class
six and age we went ahead and dropped
the rest of them at least for this
example
and so I can go ahead and do my control
enter and you'll see it execute down
below
and now DF equals these three columns or
four columns plus our answer is one of
those so I always think of it as three
columns plus one but it is four columns
and then for the next step we want to
make sure that data is in the right
format so again I'm going to resign the
DF and we're going to mutate the data
and that means we're going to take each
one of these columns and we're going to
let it know what kind of data that is
so our first one is I'm going to put the
database in or the data frame in there
DF
and then we want to go ahead and do
survived equals a factor of survived so
this is a yes no it's letting us know
that this is a zero or a one on here
and then for the class and the age those
are as numeric
there's other ways to process class
since it is a very restricted number on
there but for this we're just going to
do it as a numeric value same thing with
age and you see we didn't do anything
with sex we're just going to leave that
as male or female and that's fine for
this because it'll pick up on that when
we run the decision tree
and we'll do our control enter so now
I've assigned the new DF and you can see
it comes down below as we run it on
there so this is now loaded in DF now is
a mutated data frame that we started
with and we've set it up with our
specific columns we want to work with in
this case survived class sex and age and
we've formatted three of those columns
to a new setup so one of them is Factor
that's what we use for survive so it
knows it's a zero and one and then we
switched class and age to make sure that
it knows that those are numeric values
now that we have our data formatted we
need to go ahead and split the data into
a training and testing data set and by
now if you've done any of our other
machine learning tutorials you know this
is standard you need to have your data
that we train it with and then you got
to make sure it works on data that it
hasn't trained on so we'll go ahead and
do the splitting let's take a look and
see what that looks like
and when you're dealing with splitting
the data we're doing a little Randomness
so we'll just go ahead and set the seed
to one two three you can set that to
whatever number you want that's just
setting the random variable seed
we'll go ahead and hit enter on there
and to do this we're going to create
sample and we can go equals
sample dot split
so we're splitting up the data
this is actually creating a whole new
column
trues and falses that's all stored in
Sample and we want our data frame
and we use a dollar sign to denote that
we're going to be working with one of
the different columns
nice thing you can do in r
shows my survived so DF survived
and then our split
ratio split ratio I want to add a period
in there which it doesn't have our split
ratio is going to be equal to and we'll
do uh 0.70 so we're going to take 70
percent of the data of those that have
survived and we're going to just
randomly select which one of those we're
going to use for training and which one
we're going to use for testing it out
later
and we'll hit our enter and load that
sample in there
and then we'll go ahead and create our
train and our test data set so I'm going
to set train equal to and this is where
it kind of gets interesting because
we're going to do subset
and then we're going to do a subset of
our DF
where sample
and then we're going to use equals since
this is a logic gates wherever it sets
sample equal to true we're going to use
that line in DF
and this is of course R so it's all
capitalized for true
so here's our trained data frame we're
creating so when I execute this and it
shows up down below it goes up and says
hey this sample created a whole bunch of
trues and false and we're going to take
those trues and falses and wherever
we've created a true which is 70 of the
data randomly selected that's what we're
going to train the data with and then we
need our test set
and that's a subset just the same thing
we just did
we need our data frame and this is where
the sample equals
false and again when I hit Ctrl enter it
goes down this line of code and it runs
it down here in our terminal window
so now we've nicely split our data up we
have our training data set and our test
data set
and this is a course where we get to the
point of what we're actually trying to
do which is create our decision tree
we can do that by trading the decision
tree as a classifier
this always gets me you spend all this
work sorting through the data
reformatting it in this case mutating it
and filtering it and creating a train
set and a test set
so we're going to go ahead and create
our tree and we're going to assign to it
the r part that's the module we imported
and for the our part we need to go ahead
and
do What's called the survived and this
is kind of a little complicated to look
at so let's just take a quick look at
this I'm going to go backward on it the
first part is we're importing the data
so data equals train
and then we want to know is who survived
so the first part we put in here is the
column we're looking for is survived and
you'll see that we have added the
squiggly Mark in the period because
we're looking just for this prediction
we just want to know who survived on
these boats for programming our decision
tree and I'll go ahead and hit Ctrl
enter
and we've now created the tree that tree
with all those values is now in there
and if you remember from before we've
taken from when we did the closet full
of clutter we've done the same thing
where we have our entropy and that one
line computes the entropy and the
increase in information and it brings
the entropy down to zero so it's the
same thing but instead of applying it
here as we did visually to the closet
it's now applied it to the data on the
ship it's now looked at the survival of
zero or one based on female male what
age they are or the best split of the
age is and what class they were in you
can see we have first class if we go
down there I think there's
a third yeah third second so I guess
it's class one two and three but you can
see that's how it's split it up so let's
use these different variables to
minimize the entropy and maximize The
Information Gain and that's all done in
that one line of code
boy we worked on all that theory and uh
computer doesn't appear in one line of
code it's important to understand the
theory behind it so you know what's
happening because as they make changes
to these or if you had special settings
on it you have to know what they're
doing
but in this case you can see that we
once we get it formatted the computer
does all the heavy lifting for us
and it never ceases to amaze me just how
advanced machine learning has become
these days and how easy it is for people
to get into it and learn the basic
setups and be able to compute your
different machine learning models
once we've computed our decision tree
and we built it on there we want to go
ahead and start doing predictions with
it and what are we going to predict well
you remember that we created our data
with the train and test so we have our
training data which we program the tree
for now we want to see what it does with
the test data so let's see what that
looks like and we can wrap that into
tree Dot
survived dot predicted
we'll assign that to our prediction
this is nice because we have the command
predict from one of the modules the r
part module that we brought in
I can simply put in here that we're
going to use the tree
we have our test data
and type
this happens to be classification or
class
and this would also be if you were to
distribute this tree you could save the
tree and send it someplace else to be
used on new data this would be the
command line you would use to predict on
here predict you have your tree saved
you have whatever data you're putting
through and you let it know it's doing a
classification on the tree
and we'll go ahead and run that so now
that's loaded up
and now that we've gone through we've
trained our tree we've run a prediction
on our test data remember the tree had
never seen the test data till now so
we've already built the tree and we're
just testing it out
and to do that we're going to use a
confusion Matrix for evaluating the
model and let's see what that looks like
and that is simply confusion
Matrix so once we have the confusion
Matrix which came in from our carrot we
need to compare the two different pieces
of data and the first one is going to be
the value we generated up here we have
tree.survived.predictit
so I'm just going to copy that and paste
it down here
and then the second one is the tree
we're comparing that to
see survived
but it's not the tree it's easy to get
confused sometimes when you're moving
these things around
we're going to compare it to test the
test group of data specifically
the survived column
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like
and so let's go ahead and scroll up a
little bit here to where it first
executed the confusion Matrix
and the most important part of this is
that we have our prediction
and our reference and so 0 means they
didn't survive one means they survived
we had our prediction on here
versus the actual and that's what these
two columns mean
and so when you read this little chart
we have 0 0 so both the prediction and
the actual reference said we agreed on
218 values for people who did not
survive a little Grim there for data
remember talking this is morbid data
talking about death rates of people in
boats it says that they both agreed on
93 so 93 of them where we predicted the
value that they would survive and the
reference came up the same likewise the
predicted were predicted one
and the reference said no these people
didn't survive well our prediction got
25 wrong and where it says they didn't
survive and they actually did and got 57
wrong
and we can come on down with the um
confusion Matrix and we can look at the
accuracy comes up with the 0.7913 or 95
CI so yeah you're looking at pretty high
accuracy
information ratio p-value when you get
in statistics of p-value is one of the
things we look at remember that there
are certain values if it's over
0.95 is considered highly valuable
variable 0.5 means maybe anything less
than that means it's probably not
connected
you have to look up the p-value a little
bit more on that and then they just have
more information down here
which you can go through and
which you can go through but the
important part is that we have a very
high accuracy that's what we're looking
at this is a very accurate model and
again always remember the domain you're
working with certainly this is an
example and this is a good little piece
of data you can play with but if I was
say betting money and my accuracy came
up as 79 or over 95 percent CI I'd be
like yes let's bet on that that's a good
bet but if I was betting on a life or
death situation I might kind of rethink
that a little bit if that is if it's
going to affect my life that way you can
also look at this as if you're trying to
figure out where the boats go in this
particular example and where to put the
lifeboats that's actually pretty good be
able to say hey we can increase the
chances of people surviving this
accident by putting the lifeboats in the
appropriate places
and then this is always fun let's
visualize the decision tree one of the
cool things you can do inside of R real
easily and if you remember one of the
modules we brought in has a r part Dot
Plot we're going to take that and we're
going to dump that into the PRP for the
tree
and let's go ahead and hit enter
and this is fun let me move this over so
you can get a nice view you can see how
it actually split it up and let me just
rerun that again another expanded the
right you'll see right here where one of
the biggest splits was whether the
person was male or female I didn't know
that was probably one of the biggest
breaks as far as lowering the entropy
and increasing the Information Gain
and then once you know sex is male I
came down here and it said you're not
going to survive I guess the men were
throwing themselves overboard on the
boat I don't know maybe they're being
very gallant and letting the women and
children survive which is what I hope
that means so once you know that it's
not a male and it's a female passenger
if you're in class three or above you
had a high chance of surviving if you're
less in class three in class one or two
then it was based on age so you can see
where age was greater than 19. so
anybody over 19 had a high chance of
surviving and then if they were or less
than 19 I'm sorry if the age was a
little confusing on that one but if the
age was one side of 19 they probably
survived if not then they said hey if
your age is less than 60 you probably
survived and if not
people who are older probably didn't
make it out of the boat in time so
elderly have a much higher risk which
you would expect you'd expect that to be
the case that elderly would have a hard
time getting off into the lifeboats and
they would probably step aside for the
younger generation I know I would
because that might be more of a social
Norm statistic as opposed to survival
rate let's go and put this back on over
here
and see what else we can do with this
data
if you're working with the shareholders
it's good to have a lot of tools as far
as how to display you know they'll want
to see this number here where you say
hey this is what the confusion Matrix
looks like and we got a 0.79 accuracy
that would be like the number one thing
you'd talk to the shareholders about
other data scientists care about the
p-value and the information rate and
information like that but this is really
the core right here this is how much
data and this also shows them how much
data was looked at so you have a you can
actually just add these numbers together
and you can see how many different
people were in the this particular data
set I mean lines in the data set but we
go ahead and visualize the 2D decision
boundaries so let's take a look at that
that's kind of fun it's a little bit
more complicated so I'm not going to go
into it in too much detail today now the
guys in the back put this code together
for me which is great so I'm just going
to paste settings like I said we're not
going to go into it in too much detail I
want to just show you that there's some
other ways to display the data that is
not just this nice little tree over here
which gives us a little bit more maybe
view of what's going on as you dig
deeper into Data that becomes very
important it might not be something so
simple where you can look at in this
case one two three four notes so they
have four major nodes that they split
the data in
so we're looking at this we're going to
go ahead and create a set test equal to
test comma c241
we're just assigning color column to go
with the data okay that's what that is
we're going to take set and have it
equal to test
and we'll do X 1
and we're going to set that equal to
minimum set of one minus one Max set of
one plus one by equals .01
they had to play with these numbers a
little bit to get this to look right so
we're creating a sequence on here from
our the set we created so our test set
and then X2 is also creating a sequence
based on different values
and then we're going to put that all
into a grid so let's go ahead and run
that through all the way down to the
grid and they'll make a little more
sense when we add the column names to
the grid okay
so we'll set our test we'll create our
X1 sequence and our X2 sequence remember
a sequence is just like in this case
starting with 0.1 it's like
0.01.02.03.04
so we're going to create a grid with all
these values separated by 0.01 so that's
all we're doing right now
set that up there's our grid
and then we want to go ahead and create
some column names and for our grid set
we're going to have our C class and age
so we're just doing the class and the
age on here remember we did Sex also
before so it's just class and age on
this chart that we're pulling out
and we're going to create a y grid and
the y-grid is going to equal tree
survived predict it okay so here's our y
grid and our predicted values on there
now we're actually going to do something
we're going to plot and we're going to
plot the Y grid oops hold on let me see
what's in here
and let me go ahead and just run the
plot it's got to be the
there we go so let's take a look at this
and and see we make a little sense of
this code and what's going on here
because a couple things going on what
we've done is we've plotted a decision
tree classification data set we've done
our plot and we have our set so our
set's equal to our test data and then we
have our main we went ahead and give it
a name decision tree
and then we have our x-lab
and our X limit and we've set those up
as class with our y lab equals age and
our X limit equals range X1 comma y
limit equals range of X2
and when you look over here you can see
that we have age on the left and class
on the bottom
and So based on age and class
and so once we put in this nice graph
here we want to go ahead and add our
Contours and our points so let's go
ahead and run that and I'm going to run
all three of these so we can see all the
colors come in on the graph and this is
actually going to take a little bit
because remember you can make it go a
little faster by changing a couple of
the notes up here well we did 0.01 from
the Min to Max by changing that to 0.1
or other values you can actually it'll
run a little quicker and we're going to
create a nice little decision tree
classification test set just to see what
that looks like and how that data
displays
that was taking so long to run with 0.01
I went ahead and just did a 0.1 so
instead of filling the whole page with
different colors for a really pretty
view now I just have these different
colored lines coming across it gives us
another model that we can show for
whoever you're working with in this case
your shareholders of the company or the
individuals who you're posting to the
web for and you can see where we have
the green and the red and we've set
those up to identify from the decision
who's going to make it and who's not
based on age and class now my favorite
one on this and I'm going to go back and
just highlight this really quick was let
me just rerun that go back to PRP tree
where we display the tree and that's
where we split it in part because this
information gives us some keys that we
can then use in other models so it's
good to know that sometimes what you're
taking comes out and maybe you create a
bucket for people under 19 between 19
and 60 and over 60. and and different
things like that so you can actually put
people in buckets in a class age split
just a quick note on there again you
know lots of different things from which
you can display the data and you can see
how we use the decision tree to figure
out chances of somebody surviving based
on their class and their age let's go
ahead and take a look at the decision
trees so let's go ahead and talk about
another algorithm decision tree decision
tree is a tree shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action each branch
of the tree represents a possible
decision occurrence or reaction there's
a tree which helps us by assisting Us in
decision making let's look at the basic
terminologies to understand decision
trees we have our root node we have a
splitting we have decision node decision
node and then those split into terminal
node decision node terminal node
terminal node and each decision node
continues to split until it ends in a
terminal note note a is the parent node
of B and C also note we call the
terminal nodes Leaf nodes you can also
see that we have a branch or a sub tree
so when you have a split everything
under that split under one side is
called a sub tree you cannot build your
decision tree without knowing entropy
and Information Gain entropy entropy is
the measure of randomness of impurity in
the data set so we have here A bunch of
fruit and you can see we have it looks
like apples oranges and bananas it's
very chaotic so it's a very random data
set has a very high entropy and if we
take out one group let's say we take out
the apples it's a little less random now
we only have bananas and oranges so it's
a less random data set and we have lower
amount of entropy entropy is a major
Randomness for Purity in the data set so
when you have a homogeneous data set we
will have entropy equals zero and here
you can see it's all oranges and equal
divided data set will have an entropy
equal to one so here we have a half or
what is it looks like a couple bananas a
couple oranges and a couple apples so
everything is equal so we haven't P of 1
on there since there's two of everything
Information Gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split also known as entropy reduction
so we look over here we have an entropy
equals E1 and the information gain as we
split the bananas out the size becomes
smaller and you'll see that E1 is going
to be greater than E2 or we measure E2
of the apples and oranges in this case
if you love your fruit it's probably
going to get hungry right about now and
then the information gain from our level
2 equals E2 minus E1 where E2 is greater
than E3 as we come down here we'll see
that the E3 is now the third level we
split the oranges and apples out and
each time that entropy becomes less and
less and less until in this case we have
an entropy of zero since they're all
homogeneous in their order all oranges
all apples all bananas so let's take a
look at the use case decision tree and
actually put this into code and see what
that looks like as we go from Theory to
script and to predict the class of
flower based on the petal length and
width using R and you'll see here we
have these beautiful irises probably the
most popular data set for beginning data
analysis and statistics we have the
setosa the virginica and the versic
color let's install the packages that
will help us in the use case so because
we're doing decision tree we have our
part R part Dot Plot and then we have
the library R part and the library are
part Dot Plot let's go ahead and take a
look at that if you remember we have two
ways of installing it we can do the
install packages we did that earlier
here we go install packages using my up
Arrow to get to it or we can go up to
tools install packages and I can do R
part and are part Dot Plot and then go
ahead and hit the install that is it
will be updated this are currently
loaded oh it looks like some of them
already loaded that's fine we'll just go
ahead and update those and once we have
those updated let's take a look and see
what we have going on here oh it's still
loading let's go ahead and type in
library our part and Library R part Dot
Plot so we want to bring it into our
console with we're working in so up and
now we just download the packages and
now we want those libraries available to
what we're doing so the iris although
it's built into the r package download
on the basic download we actually have
to install the data or bring the data in
so we're going to do the data Iris and
then we're going to do the string Iris
and let's just flip back on over to our
our studio and set up our data Iris
then we're going to do string before we
do that let's do head head
Iris
there we go and you can see the head has
simple length sepal widths petal length
petal width species in this case the top
part's all setosa and each row gets a
number and then we did the string Iris
and that comes up with information and
if we flip back to our slide you can see
here the structure of the database under
string is it's a data frame as 150
objects five variables each so each one
has five variables all features are
numerical except species which is
categorical as it is our Target variable
which we want to predict so we want to
predict where there's going to be a
varicosa versus color setosa so you can
see here we want to predict all the
features are numerical except species
which is categorical it is our Target
variable which we want to predict and
you remember that's a setosa the Versa
color the virginica the three different
categories we saw earlier in the
beautiful pictures of the flower and so
we're going to go ahead and use the set
seed to decide the starting point used
in the generation of sequence of random
numbers remember we set the seed so that
if we ever want to reproduce what we're
doing it will reproduce the same thing
each time because using the same
randomizer seat bring slightly different
results but depending on what you need
it for and then we're going to Generate
random numbers using run if and the
question is why do we want to create
random numbers on here that's kind of an
unusual thing to do for inros Iris and
let's go back and just take a quick look
here actually we want to go back to our
R studio and you're going to notice when
I did the head of Iris what did I have I
had setosis cytosis
so the data is organized by species and
it's already grouped them together in
the data set well we want to randomize
that so that doesn't affect our output
and then we'll go ahead and take and
create our Iris Ran where we recreate
the data frame based on a random order
instead of setos all being grouped
together let's go ahead and put that
into our R studio and set dot seed and
we'll match their number
9850 this way we'll have identical
results to what they're doing on the
slides and we're going to set the
variable J G equal to run if and base
this on in row of Iris
and finally we're going to create Iris
underscore ran and we're going to assign
our variable we're creating Iris
underscore ran and we'll set that equal
to we can do that the original database
we're going to set that equal to Iris
and we need brackets because we're
assigning the valuables and we want to
change the order so there's an actual
command order we can do that's going to
be order G so this means all the rows in
the order that g is so we just
randomized all those rows and then we
want to keep all the columns so we'll
just put a comma and we'll leave it
blank for the columns so now Iris Ran
will have some randomized rows coming in
and if we do head let's just do this
real quick Iris Ran we can see there's
no longer cytosis cytosa we now have
virginica setosa versicolor setosa and
you can see the road numbers at the
beginning we have 103 20 63 17. so
they're randomized on there pretty well
now that we've done a little data
manipulation we can go ahead and build
our model using our part as follows and
one of the things I want you to notice
here is we're going to build our model
for our R part on the first hundred
because our data equals Iris Ran 1 to
100. there's 150 objects so we're
keeping a third of them off to the side
that way we have our training set and
our test set already pre-built because
we randomized the rows going in from the
beginning and then once we've done that
we want to go ahead and print our model
out and take a look at it let's go ahead
and put this into our our studio and
take a look and so we have our model
we're going to call it model that's our
variable name that we're giving it we're
going to assign that our part and in
Brackets we'll start with species and we
want to correlate species to all the
other columns so how do we do that and
the shorthand is just to put a period
there and then we're going to put a
comma and we want to set our data equal
to Iris Rand that's the data we put in
there and remember I said we're going to
do just the first 100 rows so we can
save the last 50 for testing so we can
do that simply by doing Row 1 to 100 so
in R you start with one for your rows
and because we want all the columns we
just put a comma and that denotes that
we're going to use all the columns in
here and in the um our part there's
different methodologies we're using the
method equals
class and you realize that we're doing a
classification between the three
different types of flowers and so this
is what we want to go ahead and set up
our model with and when we run that
we've now created a nice model for us we
can go and just type in model hit enter
and you'll see it'll print out a bunch
of information about our model so let us
know what's going on in there and let's
just break that down and see what that
looks like so we have our Target our
predictors that species and it's going
to relate to we used a period to denote
all the columns we're going to take the
first 100 rows to train the data and we
have the defining method to be used as
classification that's what the method
equals class is and we want to do next
is we're going to do a plot and take a
look and see what this actually looks
like a little visual here which is nice
and we'd simply do that with our plot
for the model and let's break this down
a little bit to see what that looks like
in the r setup and we do this our part
Dot Plot a little bit of a mouthful
there sometimes that's part of the art
part package or module so when you
imported this in it also included its
own plotting format and we're going to
send it our variable model and there are
actually a number of types of plots
listed for our part but we're just going
to do type equals four Fallen dot leaves
equals T and extra equals 104. let's go
ahead and hit enter on there and you'll
see right over here on the right hand
side it goes into our plots we just
enlarge the large that we have our Versa
color our setosa versicolor virginica
and let's go ahead and break that down
as you can see down here it represents
the tree as it splits it looks at it and
says hey if the pedal dot length is less
than 2.6 it's going to be a setosa so 34
of them fall into that category and if
the pedal length is greater than 2.6
then looks at that and says okay now I
have three different variables we're
going to split it again pedal width is
less than 1.7 is going to be a versa
color and if it's greater than 1.7 it's
a virginica and so you can see here it's
very simple tree it forms so I'm
levels you can see a branch off to the
right very nice depiction of what's
going on as far as the model now that's
created but once we create the model we
need to figure out is this model any
good so let me go back over here and
let's go back to our slides and the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to take our test data remember we
saved 50 rows for the end to go ahead
and run a predict on there so let's go
ahead and run that prediction so we'll
call it model underscore predict and
we're going to get a wrong button there
to predict and we're going to what are
we going to predict we're going to
predict our initial model and we need to
send the data so data equals and we
don't actually have to put the data part
in we just put in Iris underscore ran
and then we want to do just the last
50 rows and we denote that by 101 colon
150 and then comma and we'll leave that
part blank since we want all the columns
to show up and then finally this is a
classification so we need to let it know
that type equals class there we go and
let's just see what that looks like
model predict and so this is what the
data is put out as is it says whatever
this is 131 is a virginica number 10 is
a setosa line number 95 is a versa color
and so on all the way through what we
really want to know is how good our
model is so we're going to go ahead and
install a couple more packages we're
going to install the packages required
to use the confusion Matrix and to do
that we're going to install carrot and
e1071 and then of course we want to set
them to our project by using the library
command and so we can simply install
packages and we want carrot and and
we'll go ahead and just do that right
there there's carrot installed and we
went ahead did the install for packages
e1071 this
is
carrot
we need to load it into our workspace so
there's our library care carrot
OS and once that's loaded we'll go ahead
and also load the or set the set the
library to the e1071 so that we have
both those libraries available to us
here
e1071 and now these two libraries are
fully available to us and then we're
going to use these tools to create the
confusion Matrix
Matrix this is the Iris Ran and then
we'll go ahead and put the brackets here
and we're only going to do 101 to 150
and then we only want the first five
columns not the last five column the
first five columns columns so 5 in there
and we'll set that to our model predict
and then when we hit enter it's going to
head and just print out all the simple
so right here we're looking at our
confusion Matrix to see how everything
kind of balances out let's go over that
and see a little closer what that
actually means so the first part we see
is a reference and in here we have our
prediction because that's we call it the
column if you remember correctly and we
have it for setosa versicolor virginica
and then we have a ptosa versicolor
virginica going down each side and the
way you read this is if you look at this
we predicted
18 out of 16 cytosis
and then versacolor we predicted 13 of
the Versa color and then two of those we
predicted as virginica so we were wrong
on two of those and with the virginica
we predicted 17 correct and we had two
wrong that were versacolored so we look
at the overall statistics on here we
have an accuracy of 0.92 and a 95 CI
that's pretty good as we're going
through here those are good deals on
that and there's a lot more information
as you go down this the one thing I want
to remind you on this as we're looking
at these predictions and this is also
true for the linear regression model we
looked at earlier when we talk about the
accuracy that is the
this data and we say that as a
programmer to make that a very clear
distinction because if you're in data
analysis you should cringe if I say ah
this is a 95 accurate model without that
put
because bad data in bad data out we
won't go into detail right now on that
but that is a very important to note
that whenever you quote any of the
accuracies on here or you discuss any of
these values that come up today we're
going to cover the random forest in R if
you remember from part one we did the
decision tree and no one wants a poor
lone standing tree out in the field we
want a forest and so we're going to
cover random forests it's a little play
on words there I'm sure the people who
designed it also knew that too when they
were thinking about it so what's in it
for you what is a random Forest how does
a random Forest work we're going to
cover applications of a random Forest
some of the terms you need to know when
using a random forest and then we'll go
over the use case in R predicting the
quality of wine so let's start a little
bit with exploring what is a random
forest and welcome to Raphael's Vineyard
and I don't even know onset in Al says
France the largest wine production
region in the world so they have
centuries of wine production and data
they've collected on how to make the
best how to make their grapes and grow
them and how to properly get the right
grapes and ferment them like Raphael
wine makers around the world are facing
a grave problem so let's meet the man
himself and try helping him out what is
a random Forest we're going to come back
to the vineyard but we're going to look
at some other examples along the way too
open up the door and of course here
comes Rafael that probably I'd probably
look closer to Raphael than I do to the
young lad with the beard hey Raphael so
tell us how it's going not as good as
before not many people work in this
profession anymore so every stage of
production has gone slower if only we
could somehow speed up the process well
lucky for you I'm a machine learning
engineer how about we automate the
quality prediction process for wine let
me Begin by telling you what machine
learning and random Forest is machine
learning is a science of applying
algorithms allow a computer to predict
the outcome without being explicitly
programmed random force is an ensemble
machine learning algorithm so we're
bringing in different pieces and then
putting those pieces together it
operates by building multiple decision
trees remember I told you we don't want
just a lone tree out there in the we
want a forest they work for both
classification if you remember from part
one we had our vendor with his broccoli
and oranges I think he also had carrots
and it also the output given by the
majority of its decision trees is the
forest final output so if you have a
number of decision trees you have five
decision trees and four of them say it's
broccoli then it's probably broccoli and
you can also use it as a regression
model the output given by the majority
of decision trees is the forest final
output just like you do in
classification you can also come up with
actual values and numbers as a
regression model could you explain how a
random Force Works in layman terms it's
always a good thing to explore the
information on something a little bit
easier to understand and see sure let's
consider the case of Sam a high school
student this so reminds me of my own
high school student who's just started
his first year in college asking all his
friends so Sam is confused on which
course to take up so he's trying to
figure out what his next class is going
to be at school should he take music
lessons dance lessons math science maybe
social studies so he decides to ask a
couple of his friends for four
suggestions and Sam approaches Jane
first so he comes up to Jane and says
hey which of these classes should I take
and Jane asks Sam a few questions based
on which she can suggest theoretical do
you like Theory no he doesn't like the
theory part calculative do you like
calculative he goes yes I like doing
calculations and so Jane based on a
couple question goes she has a little
decision tree there going she goes
mathematics sounds good so James forms a
decision tree based on Sam's response
and gives her suggestion and of course
this is based on Jane's views and her
history and the data that she's
collected over her years in high school
next Sam approaches Bella Bella asks him
hey do you like the field of science and
Sam goes yes and then Bella goes do you
like I knew in Industry he like knew
things coming up in industry and Sam
goes yes and Bella goes you know you
should similar to Jane Bella also forms
a decision tree based on Sam's response
and gives her suggestion and says hey
how about artificial intelligence sounds
like oh artificial intelligence so set
up next asked Terry for his suggestion
and uh Sam goes do you like scoring
things
yes
and he goes do you like theoretical and
he goes no and he comes up and says
mathematics so you have two people
saying mathematics and one person
suggesting artificial intelligence since
two out of three friends suggested math
Sam decides to take mathematics and
there's a lot of subtleties in this
example it's actually a really good
example some of the things we run into
in data science is when we collect data
and we collect from different sources we
might have data from one source that
measures one thing or one set of
instruments and we might have data from
another source that measures something
else we saw that with each of his
friends are measuring different things
and asking different questions that's a
little bit beyond the scope of this
particular tutorial so let's go back to
our Wine Cellar so you see more the
number of decision trees more accurate
will be the prediction random forests
have a number of applications in Market
already if you've been watching any of
our other tutorials you'll see that
these are very common we have in banking
it can be used to predict fraudulent
customers is used to analyze symptoms of
patients and detecting the disease in
e-commerce the recommendations are
predicted based on customers activity
stock market trends could be analyzed to
predict profit or loss most recently I
was watching a review on weather here in
the United States and the data they pull
in for that and one of the top weather
places actually uses five different
models random forest was one of them I
believe they used five different models
to predict the weather and depending on
what the models come up with and what's
going on some of the models do better
than others I thought that was really
interesting it's important to note so
when you see us repeat the same things
over and over and you're looking at the
different machine learning tools you
realize that we use multiple tools to
solve the same problem and we can find
the best one that fits for that
particular situation so let's see how
that fits back in our wine production to
help speed up the process of wine
production we will automate the
prediction of wine quality suppose our
random Forest bills three decision trees
we have the first decision tree which is
going to divide everything by chlorides
less than 0.08 and it's either yes or no
and then it's going to look at alcohol
greater than six yes or no quality
equals high quality not so good and if
the chlorides were greater than 0.08
quality equals low so there's our first
treat and then our second tree is going
to split it on sulfates less than 0.6
and pH pH less than 3.5 and again we
have it coming down here that if the pH
is low and the sulfites are low the
quality equals time if the pH is a
little higher but the sulfides are low
it's not so good and if the sulfides are
greater than 0.6 we have a quality equal
below and then we'll do a third decision
tree we'll split it based on ph and we
can see below how that tree looks like
with our sugar less than 2.5 if not it's
a quad equals low and it's real low
quality and if it is less than 2.5 then
the pH decide whether it's going to be a
quality high or not so good and if we
track one of our wines down the list
we'll look at it we'll say oh two out of
three decision trees indicate the
quality of our wine going to be 5 the
force predicts the same so this sounds
promising so let's go ahead and dive in
and see what that actually looks like so
this is the data set that holds all the
attribute values required to predict the
Wines quality and I'll pull this up in a
spreadsheet in just a moment but you can
see here we have fixed acidity volatile
acidity citric acid all the way to
Quality and then quality is like a four
five six or seven I believe and this
will be done in R so let's go ahead and
get started on our coding we'll be using
rstudio before we dive into our studio I
always like to open up the data in the
spreadsheet and look at the actual data
called it wine quality Dash Red Dot XLS
so it's a spreadsheet a Microsoft
spreadsheet
and when we open it up we'll see that it
matches what we had before as far as the
slide was showing us with the we have 12
different columns the first 11 are our
features our fixed acidity volatile acid
citric acid things you always want to
look at when you're looking at your data
and we've done this before in the part
one but just a reminder we want to note
that we have decimal places here float
values in a lot of these things
especially the first number of columns
free sulfur dioxide looks to be an
integer but it varies a lot so we have
you know I see some values all the way
up to 51 7 4
so we'd probably keep this as a linear
model kind of thing same thing with the
sulfur dioxides densities again decimal
places sulfides alcohol
quality I want you to note in the
quality that we only have a few
qualities here this isn't like a spread
between 0 and 100 it looks to be three
four five six and seven
and so when we start looking at the
processes we can have the option of
either doing this as a
a series of integers or float values
going from
three to seven or we can convert that to
a categorical three four five six and
seven being the categories but we'll
look at that in the coding here in just
a minute and finally you'd want to go
ahead and scroll down through the data
and just look for missing data or
anything weird obviously working with
big data you wouldn't be able to do that
if this was spread across numerous
computers and you had millions of rows
we have what 1687 rows here so it's a
nice size spreadsheet still considered a
small data set let's go ahead and switch
over and let's take a look at this in
the R so here we are in our R studio and
if you remember it comes up
automatically in three panels I have my
font on fairly large to help out
the upper left panel is a file that's
open you can have multiple files and
tabs open as you can see on mine right
now I'll probably close most of those in
just a minute
and this is where you can put in your
commands then you can execute these
commands by either clicking on the Run
box or control enter is the hotkeys for
that and all that does is then puts that
down in the console and executes that
line of command you could just paste
these directly in the console I've
certainly been known to do that if I'm
loading up some data and I just want to
take a quick look at it in R because I'm
doing the coding in something else or if
I just want to do a quick explore before
I dive in and figure out what needs to
be done that's one of the tricks you can
do and then on the right hand side we
have our environment history connections
we mainly are going to just be sitting
on plots and I'm just going to minimize
this for right now out of the way when
we dive in if you haven't yet you do
need to go ahead and install the package
random Forest I'm not actually going to
do that because I've already run that we
don't need to rerun that but I am going
to go ahead and import it into our
project with the library and then random
forest and we'll do the control enter
you can always hit the Run button up
there too
and then now the library has been
uploaded in there and you can see down
below it takes this and just copies it
and pastes it down below and runs it in
our console and then just a quick
troubleshooting thing my Java happens to
be the developer's job the latest
release of the developers Java from last
week is clashing with my R and rerouting
my Java files so your chances are you
don't need to look this up or find out
where your Java is but there's a JRE
folder if you do have an error that
comes up next in the next Library you
look that up it's usually under program
files Java and you'll see jdk depending
on what version you have on there and
then find that JRE folder and I'm just
going to set the environment on there
you have to do that every time you run
the script so with r there is a place in
R where you can set it permanently but
generally it's set to whatever your
system variables are set to so you don't
want to mess with that so you just want
to put this in your code if you're
having problems and you can always take
it out then we need to go ahead and
bring in another Library
and we're going to be importing a the
spreadsheet so it's an X the xlsx since
it's a Microsoft spreadsheet then I'll
go ahead and run that
let's go ahead and create a variable
path we're going to assign to variable
path the location of our folder so this
is very lengthy one you'll have to copy
and paste it off your computer my name
is Richard and you can see under it's
under C column users Richards documents
docs business simply learn marketing
random forest and then the actual file
which is wine quality Dash Red Dot XLS
so I put in the whole path in here you
could also set the computer path to
whatever folder you have it in and then
just use just the name of the file but I
went ahead and did this because it a lot
of times it's good to meet wherever your
paths are going where you're pulling
your data from and again it went the
control enter so I could you'll see that
that pushed the line down below and ran
that line so our path is now set
and then let's create a variable called
Data
and we'll assign that to a read
and we're going to be reading let's see
where is it there it is and spreadsheet
and before I put in let me path
but we also need one more thing on the
spreadsheet because it is an Excel
spreadsheet we need to know which page
we're on so let's go look that up
and in the spreadsheets it might be a
little hard to see because it's a very
tiny font down there but you'll see the
page tabs on the bottom this actually
has two different pages and we want page
one for this project so let's flip back
over and put that in our code and the
term they use is sheet index I always
have to look that stuff up
and it was sheet index of one we'll go
ahead and execute this
so at this point we've now loaded the
data into the variable data and it's
reading those and I think there was like
you know a couple thousand rows of data
in there so it takes it just a moment to
pull it in
once I have my data in there I always
like to do something like this data
and in I always forget an R it's a head
data
and we can run that and you'll see it
prints out that what we looked at in the
spreadsheet so we have our fixed acidity
volatile acidity citric acid residual
sugar chlorides free sulfur all the
different things we're actually looking
for Quality so we want to keep that in
mind that quality is the final setting
is it a three four five six what is the
quality on there
and the first thing we need to do is
we're actually going to take the data
quality
and let me let me quality there it is
in R the dollar sign means that you're
looking at one of the columns in here or
features as it is so we see data dollar
sign quality in r that means that's what
we're going to be editing and what we
want to do is we want to change the
quality just a little bit
and so we're going to set it equal to
now we're not assigning a variable we're
altering it so data dollar sign quality
equals and we would do as is one of the
functions in R and we're going to do as
a factor
and then data
quality because that's what we're
actually editing on there and this stuff
just for a second and look at this
Factor takes this
and looks at the data as a
categorically so instead of it being on
a continual scale of you know zero to a
hundred or something like that it
actually looks at it as category of five
category of six category of a category
of cat category of dog there are yes or
no categories versus a continual now
there's a lot of different things in
here that we could do the same thing
with
but all of these really are linear
numbers 7.4.70
[Music]
sulfur dioxide 3467 so we really don't
we need to mess with any of the other
variables in there but we do want to go
ahead and set this up and we'll come up
here and we'll do our control enter and
it'll run it down below and you'll see
data quality equals as Factor data
quality so we've now turned that into a
factor or into a categorical data
and so let me just bring this down a
little bit the guys in the back do the
rest of this next piece of code there
are so many different ways and if you
have been looking at any of our
tutorials this should look kind of
familiar this is one way to do it and
you'll see we have our training data and
our testing data and so we've done here
is we've got it we have a data set size
equals
and we're just going to do by the row
and so we want 0.8 or 80 percent of the
data is going to be our training set to
train our forest and if you train a
forest or any machine learning model of
course want to test it so we're going to
save 20 of the data for testing and when
you look at this we have the index
which we set at 80 percent comma and
then a negative index so that's the
remaining setup so it goes from that
index on this is our notation for
sorting out that data and then we create
the index and we use the term sample
and this is just going to go in there
and set our different samples for in row
size data set size and everything so we
have an index now so the data is indexed
and we're just going to pull off the
first set of index and the end of the
index for our data and we can run all of
this in one shot we'll go into code
and we'll run selected lines and so now
we have our data in here we have our
training set and our testing set that's
what we wanted to get to
so once we've formatted all the data
then we get to the next real easy step
which is a single line to bring in our
random Forest
so let's go ahead and we'll use the
variable RF standing for random forest
and we're going to assign
if you remember correctly we brought in
our library random
if you wonder why I go up here all the
time is because I'll forget which
letters are capitalized in some of these
because I switch between packages so
much but it's random with a capital f
for 4S random Forest so the RF is going
to equal random Forest
and of course the we start by telling it
which column we're trying to predict
and of course we can always go down here
and double check we're running this on
the quality there we go quality and
we're using just that column all the way
to the end
and then we've added our team in the
back has gone in and played with this a
little bit and we'll go a little bit
over what they did but I'm going to put
in the values that they have set for the
different options in the random Forest
before I do that it would help if I tell
it what data to use data is going to
equal our training set
and then we have the variables that
they've put together and let's just talk
a little bit about what these different
variables mean
so uh M try and entry these are some of
the variables you play with with the
random forests the M try not so much
when they first put it out I think mtry
was very common four is a good value I
can't remember what the default is but
it's probably three four or five or
something like that depending I think it
depends on how many features you have
going in there so you could even just
leave this as a default without too much
troubles
the entry this is where it gets
important and I'm going to make this
2001
one of the suggestions is to always make
this odd like a tie breaker just in case
the default is like 500 or 501.
I didn't finally we have importance
equals true I can't remember what it
defaults to but generally you want to
set the importance equals to true it
actually looks at the correlation
between the different features to make
sure that there is some kind of
correlation as it's doing its
calculations so our one line of code is
going to assign a random forest and go
ahead and train a random for us all in
one execution so this whole thing has
been centered around getting to RF set
to the random forest and let's go ahead
and execute this variable or this line
of code and you'll see it takes a little
bit down here to execute as it goes
through and sets it up
and you'll see it probably takes a
minute or so to execute the code
depending on the size of the data and
how good your machine is
and then with all of our data we can
start looking at the answers and we'll
just do RF we'll execute that
and you'll see that the random forest
does a nice job you can see right here
has our data equals training it
basically goes over everything we talked
about
and you come down here and it has a
confusion Matrix which is nice we always
like our confusion Matrix when we're
talking to our shareholders and
explaining what the data comes out with
and how it trains
and we can go ahead and plot our RF
let's see what that looks like
and
as the number of force grows you
remember we set it to 2001 Forest you
can also see how the error comes in how
the different error on the different
variables
this is kind of a nice graph that gives
you an idea it might help you adjust
whether you really want to do 2000
different for us you might actually
truncate this off at around maybe 800
because you notice the lines kind of
continue on again this is just still on
the plot
and of course the next step is we need
to go ahead and predict remember we
split our data into two groups so let's
go ahead and get a result we'll call it
result and we'll assign this one
there we go
we'll set this to a data frame
there we go there's our data frame
and then oh let's call this we have our
test our test
quality because that's what we're we're
setting up on our test group with the
quality on there
then we want to have a predict a nice
little keyword there to go and run our
random for us
and then we tell it that we're going to
predict using our RF our random Forest
our testing group
1 to 11 is what we're using type equals
response
so let's go ahead and execute it that's
a mouthful on there
somewhere I left out a comma in there so
it gave me an error but you can see
right here we've said in there and now
we have a result and just real quick we
could do the head of the result
result comma 5 and just take a look at
the first five lines and you'll see we
have the actual value and what we
predicted over here
and we could also just do all of the
result and just see what that looks like
oops
and print that out
and so it has all the different data
we're going through on there
and finally let's just go ahead and plot
put plot up here plot and let's plot the
result
and just see what that looks like
maybe not the best one to show to the
shareholders but it does give you an
idea on the left on the y-axis you'll
see that it predicted eight
and this tells you that it a lot of the
eight and the eight scale was pretty
probably gave us about 50 percent came
up there at eight
really maybe 50 it didn't guess right
but it did come up there and say that it
was at least a four five or six even
where it was considered an eight and so
on you can see these different blocks
coming in so that if you line up the
three with the three four with the four
and you kind of cross index them a heat
map would probably do better but for
this example we'll just do a quick plot
of the data as far as how it works and
you can again see the results that we
predicted over here and you can look
those over
of course back in The Wine Cellar we're
talking to our Vineyard owner and if you
remember from before we looked at this
chart right here the error rate is 29.05
percent therefore our accuracy is 70.95
if you're doing a Vineyard that's
probably pretty good accuracy and always
check your domain when you're sharing
this stuff because if you're doing
something that's life or death maybe 70
accuracy might not be so good but if
you're looking at where you're going to
distribute the bottles to for the wine
and who's going to drink it you know 70
accuracy is pretty good for that that's
probably a lot better than having no
accuracy whatsoever and not even knowing
what Wine's going out to who so we have
automated the process of predicting the
quality of wine I myself prefer to
predict it by sampling it that's great
thank you I like to visit this guy and
Sample his wine and find out just how
good his different Vineyards are so now
let's understand what an svm is and if
you want to understand support Vector
machine you really need a good example
and I know that Cricut is a wonderful
game I don't know a lot about it but I
know it's very popular around the world
and we're going to use Cricut as an
example of svm so we'll classify qriket
players into batsman or Bowlers using
the runs to Wicket ratio so a player
with more runs would be considered a
batsman and a player with more wickets
would be considered a bowler and if we
could take a data set say of people
cricket players with runs and wickets in
columns next to their names we could
create a plot a two-dimensional plot in
this example clear separation between
qriket players considered Bowlers and
those cricket players considered batsman
and you don't always have a data set
this clean where there is a clear
segregation of data Bowlers versus
batsman but for the sake of
understanding svm this example does well
so before we do any separation in before
we apply any high level mathematics
let's just take a look at an unknown
value a new data coming into our data
set and that datum we don't know what
class it belongs to that datum is a
molar or a batsman we know that much but
we don't know should we consider that
qriket player a batsman or a bowler and
so we want to draw a decision boundary
some type of line separating the two
classes so that we can use that decision
boundary to classify the new data point
of course we could draw lines there's a
yellow line a green line a blue line
there's actually not just three lines
but an infinite number of lines that we
could draw between those two classes so
which one do we pick and this is kind of
reminiscent of simple linear regression
where we find the line of best fit we
want the line of best separation we want
a line that clearly separates those two
groups as much as possible once we have
the correct line we would be able to
classify the new data point but in this
example you can see if we pick yellow
the new data point would be a bowler but
if we picked green or blue the new data
point would be a batsman so we need the
one that best separates the data what
line best separates the data we'll find
the best line by Computing the maximum
margin from equidistant support vectors
now support vectors in this context
simply means the two points one from
each class that are closest together but
that maximize the distance between them
or the margin so the word Vector here
you may think well he really means
points data points well in
two-dimensional space yes and maybe even
in three-dimensional space but once you
get into higher dimensional spaces when
you get more and more features in your
data set you have to consider these as
vectors you can no longer really
describe them as points so we call them
vectors and the reason their support
vectors is because the two vectors that
are closest together that maximize the
distance between the two groups support
the algorithm so that's why we call them
support vectors so if you look at our
example there are a couple of points at
the top that are pretty close to one
another and a couple of points at the
bottom of that graph that are pretty
close to each other and I'm not really
sure looking at the graph which two are
closest but clearly those points are the
ones we need to consider the rest of the
other points are too far away from the
rest of the other points in other words
the bowler points are far to the right
and the batsman data points are far to
the left so we'll look at these four
points to begin with mathematically we
would calculate the distance among all
of these points and we would minimize
that distance once we pick the support
vectors we'll draw raw dividing line and
then measure the distance from each
support Vector to the line the best line
will always have the greatest margin or
distance between the support vectors if
we consider the yellow line as a
decision boundary the player with the
new data point would be considered a
bowler the margins don't appear to be
maximum though so maybe we can come up
with a better line so let's take two
other support vectors and we'll draw the
decision boundary between those and then
we will calculate the margin and notice
now that the unknown data point the new
value would be considered a batsman we
would continue doing this and obviously
a computer does it much quicker than a
human being over and over and over again
until we found the correct decision
boundary with the greatest margin and in
this case if you look at the green
decision boundary the green line appears
to have the maximum margin compared to
the other two and so let's consider this
the boundary of greatest margin and now
classify higher unknown data value and
now clearly it belongs in the batsman's
class the green line divides the data
perfectly because it has the greatest
margin or the maximum margin between the
support vectors and now we can have
confidence in our classification that
the new data point is indeed a batsman
technically this dividing line is called
a hyperplane and the reason it's called
a hyperplane will become a little bit
more evident in a few minutes generally
in two-dimensional space we consider
those lines but in three-dimensional
space and higher dimensional spaces
they're considered planes or hyperplanes
so we always tend to refer to them as
hyperplanes and the hyperplane that has
the maximum distance from the support
vectors is the one we want so sometimes
called the positive hyperplane D plus is
the shortest distance to the closest
positive point and D minus sometimes
called a negative hyperplane as the
closest shortest distance to the closest
this negative point and the sum of D
positive and D negative is called the
distance margin so if you calculate
those two distances and add them up
that's the distance margin and we always
want to maximize that if we don't
maximize it we can have a
misclassification and you can see the
yellow margin is much smaller than the
green margin so this problem set is two
dimensional because the classification
is only between two classes and so we
would call this a linear svm now we're
going to take a look at kernel svm and
if you notice in this picture this is a
great depiction of a plane not a line
This is three-dimensional space so
that's the plane that separates those
two classes so what if our
two-dimensional data looks like this
what if there's no clear linear
separation between the two classes and
machine learning parlance we would say
that these are not linearly separable
how could we get support Vector machine
to work on data that looks like this
since we can't separate it into two
classes using a line what we're going to
do and clearly there's no line I mean
convince yourself there's no line that
goes and separates those two classes so
what we would do is we would apply some
type of transformation to a higher
Dimension we would apply a function
called a kernel function to the data set
such that the data set would be
transformed into a higher Dimension a
dimension high enough where we could
clearly separate the two groups the two
classes in this case with a plane much
the same way you saw the picture a few
slides ago where the plane was
separating the two classes here we
clearly could draw some planes between
the green dots and the red dots and of
course we could draw an infinite number
of planes separating those two classes
but we would draw the one that would
maximize the margin so if we let R be
the number of dimensions then the kernel
function would convert a given
two-dimensional space to a
three-dimensional space and as I said
once the data is separated in three
dimensions we can apply svm and separate
the two groups using a two-dimensional
plane and this is analogous in the
higher dimensions and that last picture
on the right hand side would be some
type of depiction of a higher Dimension
hyperplane and there are more than one
type of Kernel function there's gaussian
RBF kernel sigmoid kernel polynomial
kernel depending on the dimension and
how you want to transform the data there
are more than one choice for kernel
functions so now let's go through a use
case let's take a look at horses and
mules and see if we can use svm to
classify some new data so the problem
statement is classifying horses and
mules and we're going to use height and
weight as the two features and obviously
horses and mules typically in general
tend to weigh differently and tend to
stand taller so we'll take a data set
we'll import the data set we'll make
sure we have our libraries the
e1071 library has support Vector machine
algorithms built in we'll compute the
support vectors using the library once
the data is used to train the algorithm
we'll plot the hyperplane get a visual
sense of how the data is separated and
if it's two-dimensional or
three-dimensional that's great remember
if it's higher dimensional it's tough to
plot those and then we'll use the new
model the trained model to classify new
values in general we would have a
training set a test set and then ingest
the new data but for our example we're
just going to use the whole data set to
train the algorithm and then see how it
performs and once we see how it performs
we'll see did we get a horse did we
predict a horse when we had a horse did
we predict a mule when we had a mule so
here's the r code of course if you want
to run this our code you'll have to
install R and then our studio then
you'll have to ingest the data and then
you'll have to create an indicator
variable to help us with our plots we'll
install our libraries install the
package if you don't already have it
installed I do and then call the library
up into the r session that you're
working we'll create the data frame from
the data that was ingested we will then
view the data frame and of course we
have to explore the data frame hoping
that we don't have missing values or we
don't have outliers if we do have
missing values or outliers we'll have to
either compute those values or delete
those values but in this case let's hope
we don't have any and now for a quick
demo on support Vector machines so we
have a working directory where my data
is stored and I'm going to set the
working directory to that data source
and read the data file into r i now I'm
going to create a vector that really is
just an indicator variable it's the
negative ones and the ones that indicate
whether it's a mule or a horse negative
one for mule positive 1 for a horse so
I'll create that vector and svm there's
a great package
e1071 Great Library that has the support
Vector machine functions that we're
going to use and now I'm going to create
the data frame I'm going to take my data
and I'm going to add to it the is horse
vector
and now let's just take a peek and as
you can see there's the height weight
and whether or not the animal was a mule
or a horse so remember machine learning
we take a data source with known
outcomes and we apply our algorithm to
that data source in this case a data
frame of heights weights and the
indicator variable and then we use the
machine learning algorithm to learn from
that data with those known results so
now let's plot the data the height
versus weight and as you can see the
horses tend to be a lot taller and weigh
a lot more than the mules so now let's
run our algorithm our svm model against
the data and the key here is that it's a
linear model and we've run it and great
now we have a model let's look at the
summary of the model and as you can see
there's the formula that it ran and some
of the information about the vectors in
the classes and there are two support
vectors so now let's find those two
support vectors on our our graph and
this might be a little hard to see the
orange outline around this point and
this point indicate that those are the
two vectors that will support this model
and thus we call them the support
vectors now let's get the parameters of
the hyperplane from the model and let's
plot a line that will be our hyperplane
there's our hyperplane line and
therefore to the left and below are
mules and to the right and above our
horses above that line let's take a few
new observations and I've encoded these
so that it would be illustrative we'll
take these new observations and we'll
plot them and I'm going to generate a
new plot red being the horses black dots
being the mules I'll create an X and Y
axis I'm going to plot Three Dots and
you can see one of them the Green Dot
the first one kind of Falls near the
mules the blue one kind of Falls near
the horses and visually we might
conclude hey one's a mule one's a horse
but what about the orange dot well for
the orange dot we really need our
hyperplane we really need something to
clearly indicate which side it's on and
of course by looking at this data
visualization you can tell that the
orange dot is probably a mule and let's
verify those results by sticking those
observations into our model and predict
some outcomes and down below you can see
that for the three data points one two
and three the first one the green one
was negative one that's a mule the
second one was a positive one that's
blue that's the blue point which was a
horse and the third one which we weren't
sure about but clearly the svm model
correctly predicted that that third
point would be a negative one would be a
mule and we can visually see that by the
hyperplane on the graph so that's a
quick example of svm in general support
Vector machines are binary classifiers
we don't use them for higher level
classification if you had three or more
classes you might want to use something
like random Forest what applications you
can use it for face detection text
categorization image classification and
bioinformatics really anywhere that you
have the need to classify things into
two groups so let's Dive In into what is
clustering what is clustering so we'll
have a group of people here hanging out
at a table or local coffee shop I'm
guessing coffee shops since they all
have the same mugs and one of them is
trying to figure out what they're going
to do I have 20 places to cover in four
days I guess he's going traveling that
sounds fun one of those Breeze through
Costa Rica or visiting the U.S or going
to to Europe to go visit all the
highlights so he's got 20 places he
wants to go and he wants to hit him in
four days very ambitious and how will I
manage to cover all of them that's the
question that he's coming up how am I
going to get to all these different
places in the short time I have maybe
he's a sales team so he has 20 places
he's got to do demos for you can make
use of clustering by grouping the places
into four clusters each of these
clusters will have places which are
close by so we're going to Cluster them
together by what is closest to the other
one then each day you can visit one
cluster and cover all the places in the
cluster great that's a great idea you
know if you're going to hit four
different places is maybe you're going
to Cluster whatever streets are closest
together so you don't have to travel
spend all your time traveling the method
of dividing the objects into clusters
which are similar between them and are
dissimilar to the objects belonging to
another cluster so this is a formal
definition of clustering and we have
here what we call hierarchical
clustering and partial clustering and
we're going to go more into detail on
hierarchical clustering and you'll see
the difference between the two where
partial clustering doesn't have the
descending graph it just has groups of
things and under hierarchical clustering
we're going to go over agglomerative and
divisive and you can think of
agglomerative of bringing things
together and divisive as dividing them
apart and then partial clustering the
two most common ones are K means that's
probably the most common used for
partial clustering and there's also
fuzzy c means and there's other ways of
clustering and other algorithms out
there but these are the two big ones
k-means really being the most common one
used but we're not going to dig too deep
in to partial clustering because we're
studying hierarchical clustering today
so what is clustering well the
applications of clustering are pretty
numerous we have things like customer
segmentation what people kind of Belong
Together how do we group them together
we have social network analysis so
social networks we might look at
sentiments what group of people like
something what group of people don't
like something and then we can use that
sentiments to suggest new cells for them
you know this whole group is into
Harley-Davidson motorcycles so we cater
them to sell them Harley-Davidson
motorcycle parts and we find out that
people in that group also like leather
jackets they also like motorcycle boots
and they like bandanas my brother's into
Harley-Davidson so that's why I picked
that kind of funny example but you can
kind of see we look for similarities
between these people and then we group
them together accordingly and that's a
good sentimental clustering is very
common in so many things today we want
to know the sentiments on stocks who is
interested in stocks who's not
sentimental analysis we talked about
customer segmentation and cells well we
want to know what kind of sentimental
view people have on different
restaurants if we're going to open up a
new restaurant or a new putting stores
in and of course city planning a lot of
this I just kind of aimed at the city
planning side sitting planning is Big
with clustering we want to Cluster
things together so that they work we
don't want to put a industrial Zone in
the middle of somebody's neighborhood
where they're not going to enjoy it or
have a commercial zone right in the
middle of the industrial Zone where no
one's going to want to go next to a
factory to go eat a high-end meal or
dinner so it's very big in City Planning
but it's also very big in just
pre-processing data into other models so
when we're exploring data being able to
Cluster things together reveal things in
the data we never thought about and then
once we have it clustered we can put
that into another model to help us
figure out what it is we want for our
solution so let's go a little deeper
into hierarchical clustering let's
consider we have a set of cars and we
have a group similar we want to group
similar ones together so below we have
you'll see four different cars down
there and we get two clusters of car
types sedan and SUV so if you're just
looking at it you can probably think oh
yeah we'll put the sedans together and
the SUVs together and then at last we
can group everything into one cluster so
we just have just cars so you can see as
we have this we make a nice little tree
this is very common we see anybody talks
about hierarchical clustering this is
usually what you see and what comes out
of it we terminate when we are left with
only one cluster so we have as you can
see we bring them all together we have
one cluster we can't bring it together
anymore because they're all together
hierarchical clustering is separating
data into different groups based on some
measure of similarity so we have to find
a way to measure what makes them alike
and what makes them different
agglomerative clustering is known as a
bottom-up approach remember I said think
of that as bringing things together so
you see I think the Latin term aglo is
together because you have your
conglomerate rocks where all the
different pieces of rocks are in there
so we want to bring everything together
that's a bottom up and then divisive is
we're going to go from the top down so
we take one huge cluster and we start
dividing it up into two clusters into
three four five and so on digging even
deeper into how hierarchical clustering
Works let's consider we have a few
points on a plane so this plane is 2D so
we have an X Y coordinates kind of makes
it easy we're going to start with
measure the distance so we want to
figure a way to compute the distance
between each point each data point is a
cluster of its own remember if we're
going from the bottom up a glomerative
then we have each point being its own
cluster we try to find the least
distance between two data points to form
a cluster and then once we find those
with the least distance between them we
start grouping them together so we start
forming clusters of multiple points this
is represented in a tree-like structure
called dendogram so this is another
keyword dendro RAM and you can see it is
it's just a branch we've looked at
before and we do the second group the
same so it gets its own dendogram and
the third gets its own dendogram and
then we might group two groups together
so now those two groups are all under
one dendrogram because they're closer
together than the P1 and P2 and then we
terminate when we are left with one
cluster so we finally bring it all
together you can see on the right how
we've come up all the way up to the top
whoops and we have the gray hierarchical
box coming in there and connecting them
so we have just one cluster and that's a
good place to terminate because there is
no way we can bring them together any
further so how do we measure the
distance between the data points I mean
this is really where it starts getting
interesting up until now you can kind of
eyeball and say hey these look together
but when you have thousands of data
points how are we going to measure those
distances and there is a lot of ways to
get the distance measure so let's go and
take a look at that distance measures
will determine the similarity between
two elements and it will influence the
shape of the Clusters and we have
euclidean distance measure we have
squared euclidean distance measure which
is almost the same thing but with less
computations and we have the Manhattan
distance measure which will give you
slightly different results and we have
the cosine distance measure which again
is very similar to the euclidean playing
with triangles and sometimes it can
compute faster depending on what kind of
data you're looking at so let's start
with the clitian distance measure the
most common is we want to know the
distance between the two points so if we
have Point p and point Q the euclidean
distance is the ordinary straight line
it is the distance between the two
points in euclidean space and you should
recognize D equals in this case we're
going to sum all the the points so if
there was more than one point we could
figure out the distance to the not more
than one points this is the sum of more
than two Dimensions so we can have the
distance between each of the different
dimensions squared and that will give us
and then take the square root of that
and that gives us the actual distance
between them and they should look
familiar from euclidean geometry maybe
you haven't played too much with
multiple Dimensions so the summation
symbol might not look familiar to you
but it's pretty straightforward as you
add the distance between each of the two
different points squared so if your y
difference was 2 minus 1 squared would
be 2 and then you take the difference
between the X again squared and if there
was a z coordinates it would be you know
Z1 minus Z2 squared and then take the
square root of that and sum it all or
sum it all together and then take the
square root of it so to make it compute
faster since the difference in distances
whether one is farther apart or closer
together than the other we can do What's
called the squared euclidean distance
measurement this is identical to the
euclidean measurement but we don't take
the square root at the end there's no
reason to it certainly gives us the
exact distance but as far as doing
calculations as to which one's bigger or
smaller than the other one it won't make
a difference so we'll just go with the
so we just get rid of that that final
square root computes faster and it gives
us the pretty much the euclidean squared
distance on there now the Manhattan
distance measurement is a simple sum of
horizontal and vertical components or
the distance between two points measured
along axes at right angles now this is
different because you're not looking at
the direct line between them and in
certain cases the individual distances
measured will give you a better result
now generally that's not true most times
you go with euclidean squared method
because that's very fast and easy to see
but the Manhattan distance is you
measure just the Y value and you take
the absolute value of it and you measure
just the X difference you take the
absolute value of it and just the Z and
if you had more you know different
dimensions in their a b c d e f however
many dimensions you would just take the
absolute value of the difference of
those dimensions and then we have the
cosine distance similarity measures that
angle between the two vectors and as you
can see as the two vectors get further
and further apart the cosine distance
gets larger so it's another way to
measure the distance very similar to the
euclidean so you're still looking at the
same kind of measurement so should have
a similar result as the first two but
keep in mind the Manhattan will have a
very different result and you can end up
with a bias with the Manhattan if your
data is very skewed if one set of values
is very large and another set of values
is very small but that's a little bit
beyond the scope of this it's just
important to know that about the
Manhattan distance so let's dig into the
agglomerative clustering and a glometric
clustering begins with each element as a
separate cluster and then we merge them
into a larger cluster how do we
represent a cluster of more than one
point so we're going to kind of mix the
distance together with the actual
agglomerative and see what that looks
like and we're actually going to have
three key questions that are going to be
answered here so how do we represent a
cluster of more than one point so we
want to look at the math what it looks
like mathematically and geometrically
how do we determine The Nearness of
clusters when to stop combining clusters
always important to have your computer
script or your whatever you're working
on have a termination point so it's not
going on eternally we've all done that
if you do any kind of computer
programming or writing a script let's
assume that we have six data points in a
euclidean space so again we're dealing
with X Y and Z in this case just X and Y
so how do we represent a cluster of more
than one point let's take a look at that
and first we're going to make use of
centroids very common terminology in a
lot of machine learning languages when
we're grouping things together so we're
going to make use of centroids which is
the average of its points
and you can see here we're going to take
the 1 2 and the 2 1 and we're going to
group them together because they're
close I mean if we were looking at all
the points we'd look for those that are
closest and start with those and we're
going to take those two we're going to
compute a point in the middle and we'll
give that point 1 5 1.5 1.5 and that's
going to be the centroid of those two
points and next we start measuring like
another group of points we got 4 1 5 0.
when they're pretty close together so
we'll go ahead and set up a centroid of
those two points in this case it would
be the 4.5 and 0.5 would be the
measurements on those two points and
once we have the centroid of the two
groups we find out that the next closest
point to a centroid is over on the left
and so we're going to take this and say
oh 0 0 is closest to the 1.5 1.5
centroid so let's go ahead and group
that together and we compute a new
centroid based on those three points so
now we have a centroid of 1.1 or 1 comma
1. and then we also do the this again
with the last point the five three and
it computes into the first group and you
can see our dendogram on the right is
growing so we have each of these points
are become connected and we start
grouping them together and finally we
get a centroid of that group two and
then finally the last thing we want to
do is combine the two groups by their
centroids and you can see here we end up
with one large group and you'll have its
own centroid although usually they don't
compute the last centroid we just put
them all together so when do we stop
combining clusters well hopefully it's
pretty obvious to you in this case when
they all got to be one but there are
actually many approaches to it so first
pick a number of clusters K up front and
this is done in the fact that we don't
want to look at 200 in clusters we only
want to look at the top five clusters or
something like that so we decide the
number of clusters required in the
beginning and we terminate when we reach
the value K so if you looked back on our
clustering let me just go back a couple
screens you'll see how we clustered
these all together and we might want
just the two clusters and so we look at
just the top two or maybe we only want
three clusters and so we would compute
which one of these has a wider spread to
it or something like that there's other
computations to know how to connect them
and we'll look at that in just a minute
but to note that when we pick the K
value we want to limit the information
that's coming in so that can be very
important especially if you're feeding
it into another algorithm that requires
three values or you set it to four
values and you need to know that value
coming in so we might take the
clustering and say okay only three
clusters that's all we want for K so the
possible challenges this only makes
sense when we know the data well so when
you're clustering with K clusters you
might already know that domain and know
that that makes sense but if you're
exploring brand new data you might have
no idea how many clusters you really
need to explore that data with let's
consider the value of K to be 2. so in
this case in our previous example we
stop and we are left with two clusters
and you can see here that this is where
they came together the best well still
keeping separate the data the second
approach is stop when the next merge
would create a cluster with low cohesion
so we keep clustering till the next
merge of clusters creates a bad cluster
low cohesion setup on there that means
the point is so close to being between
two clusters it doesn't make sense to
bring them together but how is cohesion
defined oh let's dig a little deeper
into cohesion the diameter of a cluster
so we're looking at the actual diameter
of our cluster and the diameter is the
maximum distance between any pair of
points in the cluster we terminate when
the diameter of a new cluster exceeds
the threshold so as that diameter gets
bigger and bigger we don't want the two
circles or clusters to overlap and we
have radius of a cluster radius is a
maximum distance of a point from
centroid we terminate when the radius of
a new cluster exceeds the threshold
again we're not we don't want things to
overlap so when it crosses that
threshold and is overlapping with other
data we stop so let's look at divisive
clustering remember we we went from the
bottom up now we want to go from the top
down divisive clustering approach begins
with a whole set and proceeds to divide
it into smaller clusters so we start
with a single cluster composed of all
the data points we split it into
different clusters this can be done
using monothetic divisive methods what
is monothetic divisive method and we'll
go backwards and let's consider the
example we took in the agglomerative
clustering to understand this so we
consider a space with six points in it
just like we did before same points we
had before and we name each point in the
cluster so we have in this case we just
gave it a letter value a b c d e f since
we follow top down approach in divisive
clustering obtain all possible splits
into two columns so we want to know
where you could split it here and we
could do like a a b split and a cdef
split we could do BCE ADF and you can
see this starts generating a huge amount
of data a b c t EF and so for each split
we can compute cluster sum of squares
and we can see here the we actually have
the formula out for us B J 12 equals N1
of absolute value of x minus absolute
value of x squared so again we're
Computing all the different distances in
there squared back to your kind of
euclidean distances on that and so we
can actually compute B A J between
clusters one and two and we have the
mean of the cluster and the grand mean
depending on the number of members in
the cluster and we select the cluster
with the largest sum of squares let's
assume that the sum of squared distance
is largest for the third split we had up
above and that's where we split the a b
c out and if we split the ABC out we're
left with the def on the other side we
again find the sum of squared distances
and split it into clusters so we go from
ABC we might find that the a is splits
into BC and and D into EF and again you
start to see that hierarchical dendogram
coming down as we start splitting
everything apart and finally we might
have a splits in b and c and then each
one gets their own d e f and it
continues to divide until we get little
nodes at the end and every data has its
own point or until we get to K if we
have set a k value so we've kind of
learned a little bit about the
background and some of the math in
hierarchical clustering let's go ahead
and dive into a demo and our demo today
is going to be for the problem statement
we're going to look at U.S oil so a U.S
oil organization needs to know its cells
in various States in U.S and cluster of
the states based on the cells so what
are the steps involved into setting this
problem up so the steps we're going to
look at and this is really useful for
just about any processing of data
although I believe we're going to be
doing this in R today we're going to
import the data set so we'll explore our
data a little bit there create a scatter
plot so always it's good to have a
visual if you can once you have a visual
you can know if you're really far off in
the model you choose to Cluster the data
in or how many splits you need and then
we're going to normalize the data so
we're going to fix the data up so it
processes correctly we'll talk more
detail about normalization when we get
there and then calculate the euclidean
distance and finally we'll create our
dendogram so it looks nice and pretty
and we have something we can show to our
shareholders so that they have something
to go on and know why they gave us all
that money and salary for the year so we
go ahead and open up R and we're
actually using our studio which is the
really has some nice features in it it
automatically sets up the three Windows
where we have our script file on the
upper left
and then we can execute that script and
it'll come down and put it into the
console bottom left and execute it and
then we have our plots off to the right
and I've got it zoomed in hopefully not
too large a font but large enough that
you can see it
and let's just go ahead and take a look
at some of the script going in here
clustering analysis and we're going to
work we'll call it my data and we're
going to assign it in R this is a symbol
for assigning and we're going to go read
CSV
read CSV file
and we'll put that in Brackets and let's
before we go any further let's just look
at the data outside of R it's always
nice to do if you can
and the file is going to be called
utilities.csv this would also be the
time to get the full path so you have
the right path to your file and remember
that you can always Post in the comments
down below
and when you post down there just let us
know you want to connect up with simply
learn so that they can get you this file
so you can get the same file we're
working on and you can repeat it and see
how this works this is utilities.csv
It's a comma separated variable file so
it's pretty straightforward and you can
see here they have the city fixed charge
and a number of different features to
the data and so we have our RoR cost low
demand cells
nuclear fuel cost on here and then going
down the other side we have U.S cities
Arizona Boston they have Central U.S I
guess they're grouping a number of areas
together the Commonwealth area you can
see down here in Nevada New England
Northern U.S Oklahoma the Pacific region
and so on so we have a nice little chart
of different data they brought in
and so I'm going to take that complete
path that ends in the utilities.csv
and we're going to import that file let
me just enlarge this all the way upside
an extra set of brackets here somehow or
maybe I missed a set of brackets
this can happen if you're not careful
you can get brackets on one side and not
the other or in this case I got double
brackets on each side there we go and
then the magic hotkeys in this case are
your control enter which will let me go
ahead and run the script
and so I've now loaded the data and as
you can see I went ahead and shrunk the
plot since we're going to be looking at
the window down below
and we can simply convert the data to a
string
now all of us do this automatically the
first time we say hey just printed all
out as a string and then we get this
huge mess of stuff
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
so when you can see here they have you
can probably kind of pull it together as
looking at it but let's go ahead and
just do the head
and we'll do the head of my data
there we go and control enter on that
and the head shows the first five rows
you'll see this in a lot of different
scripts in R it's you type in head and
then in Brackets you put your data and
it comes through and lists the first
five rows as you can see below
and it shows Arizona Boston Central and
it has the same columns we just looked
at so we have the fixed charge the RoR
the cost the load the D demand I'm not
an expert in oil so I'm not even sure
what D demand is cells I'm guessing
nuclear how much of it's supplied by
nuclear and the actual fuel cost
and then the different states that it's
in or different areas
and one of the wonders of R is all these
cool easy to use tools that are so quick
so we'll do pairs
and pairs creates a nice graph so let me
go ahead and run this
uh whoops the reason it gave me an error
is because I forgot to resize it so let
me bring my plot way out so we can see
it and let's run that again
and you'll see here that we have a nice
graph of the different data and how it
plots together how the different points
kind of come together
this is neat because if you look at this
I would look at this and say hey this is
a great candidate for some kind of
clustering and the reason is is when I
look at any two pairs let's go down to
say cells and fuel costs towards the
bottom right
and when you look at them where they
cross over you sort of see things how
they group together but it's a little
confusing you can't really pinpoint how
they group together you could probably
look at these two and say yeah there's
pretty good commonalities there and if
you look at any of the other pairs
you'll start seeing some patterns there
also and so we really want to know what
are the patterns on all of them put
together not just any two of them the
whole setup
let me go ahead and Shrink my this down
for just a second just a notch here
and let's create a scatter plot oops
and this is simply just use the term
plot in Brackets and then which values
do we want to plot and if we remember
when we looked at the data earlier let
me just go back this way
in this case let's go ahead and compare
two just two values to see how they look
and we'll do fuel costs and cells
and it's in my data so we gotta let her
know which two columns we're looking at
next to each other and it will open up
our plot thing and then go ahead and
execute that
and we can see on those close-up what
we're just looking at in the pairs
and if I was eyeballing this I would say
oh look there's a kind of a cluster up
here of five items and this one is hard
to tell which cluster would be with but
maybe it's six you go in the top one and
you have a middle cluster and a bottom
cluster maybe two different clusters so
you can sort of group them together fuel
cost and the sales and see how they
connect with each other
and again that's only two different
values we're looking at so in the long
run we want to look at all of them
and then the people in the back
they sent me this grip so we can go
ahead and add labels so with my data
text fuel cost cells the labels equal
City
position four these are numbers you can
kind of play with till they look nice
and oops again I forgot to resize my
plot it doesn't like having it too small
and we'll run that
I mistyped something in here
nope I did a lowercase D and they did a
capital D there we go so now we can go
in here and do this with my data and you
can see a little hard to see on my
screen with all the the different things
in there okay plus the actual cities so
we can now see where all the cities are
in connection with in this case fuel
cost and sales so you have a nice label
to go with the graph
and then we can also go ahead and plot
in this case let's do oh the RoR oops
and we'll do that
also with the cells and do my data
remember to leave it lowercase this time
so we plot those two
we'll come over here and it's going to
I'm surprised give me an error
and then we'll also add in the with
statement so we put some nice labels in
there
and it's going to be the same as before
except instead of doing the fuel cost
cells we want the r cells and we'll
execute that
oops and of course it gives me an error
because I shrunk it down so let's redo
those two again
there we go and we can see now we have
the RoR with cells and we'd probably get
a slightly different clustering here if
I was looking at these cities they're
probably different than what we had
before
but you could probably look at this and
say yeah these kind of go together and
those kind of go together but again
we're going to be looking at all of them
instead of just one or two
and so at this point we want to dive
into the next step we're going to start
looking at a little bit of coding or
scripting here
this is very important because we're
going to be looking at normalization
we put that in there normalization and
if you've done any of the other machine
learning skills and setup dishes start
to look very normal in your
pre-processing of data whether you're in
r or python or any of these scripts we
really want to make sure you normalize
your data so it's not biased
remember we're dealing with distances
and if I have let's say the RoR is even
look at this graph here on the right
you can see where my RoR varies between
8 and 14. that's a very small variable
and our cells varies between four
thousand and sixteen thousand so you can
imagine the distance between four
thousand and eight thousand which is the
distance of four thousand versus eight
to ten versus two the cells is going to
dominate so if we do any kind of special
work on this it's going to look at cells
and it's going to Cluster them just by
the cells alone and then RoR might have
a little tiny effect of two versus four
thousand we want to level the playing
field
turns out there's actually a number of
ways in script to normalize
so I'm just going to put in the code
that they put together in the back for
me and let's talk about it a little bit
so we have Z we're going to assign it to
my data
and let's go ahead and
we're going to do a little reshaping
across all rows
or I mean across all columns so each of
the rows is going to have a little
reshaping there
and then we're going to get M which
stands for means
and we're going to apply it to my data
so again we want to go ahead and create
a the most common variable in there
and then s is going to be the SD stands
for standard deviation
so instead of just doing a lot of times
what they do with normalization of data
is we just reshape the data everything
between 0 and 1. so that if the lower
end is eight that now becomes zero and
the upper end is 14 that now becomes 1.
that doesn't help if it is not a linear
set of data so with this we're going to
look for the means and the standard
deviation for reshaping the data
and that way the most common values now
become the kind of like the center point
and then the standard deviation is how
big the spread so we want the standard
deviation to be equal amongst all of
them and then finally we go ahead and
take Z and with the Z we're going to
reassign it and we're going to scale the
original my data which we shaped based
on M and based on the standard deviation
and the two in here that just means
we're looking at everything in kind of a
x y kind of plot
and we can quickly run these control
enter control enter control enter
control enter so now we have Z which is
a scaled version of my data
and now we can go ahead and calculate
the euclidean distance
oops calcu
there we go
and in R this is so easy once you've
gotten to here we've done all that
pre-data processing
we'll call it distance
and we'll assign this to
dist so dist
is the computation for getting the
euclidean distance and we can just put Z
in there because we've already
reformatted and scaled Z to fit what we
want let me go ahead and just hit enter
on that
and I'm going to widen my left hand side
again
I'm always curious what does this data
look like so let's just type in distance
which will print the variable down below
oops
you have to hit Ctrl enter
and this prints out a huge amount of
information
as you can see just kind of streams down
there
and let's go ahead and large this
and I don't know about you but when I
look at something like this it doesn't
mean a whole lot to me other than I see
two three four five six
and then you kind of have the top part 6
17 18
so I imagine this is like a huge chart
is what we're looking at
and we can go ahead and use print oh
distance
digits
equal three and let's run that
oops I keep forgetting that it has to go
through the graph on the right and we
see a different slightly different
output in here let me just open this up
so we can see we're looking at and by
cutting down the distance you can start
to see the patterns here if it's looking
at the different distances
so if I go to the top we have the
distance between one and two one and
three one and four one and five one and
six and then two and three and so on
obviously the distance between itself is
zero and it doesn't repeat the data so
we don't care to see two versus one
again because we already know the
distance between one and two
and so we have a nice view all the
distances in the chart and that's what
we're looking at right here and it's a
little easier to read that's why we did
the print statement up here to do digits
equals three make it a little bit
smaller we could even just do digits
well let's just do two see what that
looks like we might lose some data on
this one if it's uh if something's way
off
but we have a nice setup and we can see
the different distances and that's what
we were computed here between each of
the points
and then the whole reason we're doing
this is to get ourselves a nice
identogram going a nice clustering
dendogram we'll do a couple of these
looking at different things
we'll take a variable hc.l and we're
going to assign it
H cluster
and then distance
that easy we've already computed the
distances so the H clustering does all
the work for us
and let me hit enter on there so now we
have our HCL which is assigned the H
clustering computation based on
distances and apart and then I'm going
to expand my graph because we would like
to go ahead and see what this looks like
and we can simply plot that
and hit the control enter so it runs
and look at that we have a really nice
clustering dendrogram except when I look
at it the first thing I notice is it
really shows like numbers down below
now if you were a shareholder in some
data scientist came up to you and said
look at this this is what it means you'd
be looking at that going what the heck
does 3 9 14 19 1 18 mean so let's give
it some words there
so let's do the same plot with our HCL
HC there we go
and let's add in labels and this is just
one of the commands and plots
so we have labels equals my data
and then under my data we want to know
the city
and we'll have it hang minus one that's
just the instructions to make it pretty
so we'll run that
oops I accidentally ran just hang my one
let me try that again there we go okay
so now you can see what it's done and
the hang my one turns it sideways that
way we can see Central which is Central
us and Kentucky
and we start to actually get some
information off our clustering setup and
the information you start looking at is
that when we put all the information
together you probably want to look at
Central American Kentucky together
Oklahoma and Texas has a lot of
commonality as does Arizona and Southern
U.S and you can even group all five of
those Florida Oklahoma Texas Arizona and
Southern U.S these regions for some
reason share a lot of similarities and
so we want to start asking what those
similarities are
but this gives us a place to look it
says hey these things really go together
you should be grouping these together as
far as your cells and what's what you're
doing
and then one of the things you might
want to do is there's also we can do the
dendogram average
this changes how we do the clustering
so it looks very similar like we had
before and those are HCL we're going to
assign it we're going to do an H cluster
we're still doing it on distance oops
distance
and this time we're going to set the
method to average so we can change the
methodology in which it computes the
values
and before if you remember correctly we
did median median is a little bit
different than means we did the most
common one and then we want the average
of the median
and let's go ahead and run that
and then we can plot
and here's our HCL
oops there we go here's our HCL and I
can run that plot and you can see this
changed a little bit so our way it
computes and groups things looks a
little different than it did before and
let's go and put the cities back in
there and do the hang
control copy let me just really quickly
copy that down here
because we want the same labels
and again you can see Nevada Idaho pujet
I remember we were looking at Southern
U.S and Arizona Texas and Oklahoma
Florida so the grouping really hasn't
changed too much so we still have a very
similar grouping
it's almost kind of flipped it as far as
the distance based on average has
something you could actually take to the
shareholders and say hey look these
things are connected and at which point
you want to explore a little deeper as
to why they're connected because they're
going to ask you okay how are they
connected and why do we care
that's a little bit beyond the actual
scope of what we're working on today
but we are going to cover membership
what's called a clustering membership on
there
and let's create a member we'll just
call it Member One oops there remember
dot one and we're going to assign to
this
we're going to do cut tree
and
cut tree
it limits it so what that means is I
take my HC Dot
l in here
oops there we go dot l and so I'm taking
the cluster I just built and we want to
take that cluster and we want to limit
it to just a depth of three so we go
ahead and do that and run that one oops
let me go run
there we go so now I've created my
Member One
and then whoops let me just move this
out of the way
we're going to do an Aggregate and we're
going to use Z remember Z from above and
we're going to turn Member One into a
list and then we're going to aggregate
that together based on the mean let me
go ahead and enter run that
Oops I did remember L it's actually
number one
there we go
and if we take a look at this
we now have our group one fixed charge
and then all your different
columns listed there and most of them
should come up kind of looking between
zero and one but you'll see a lot of
variation because we're varying it based
on the means so it's a means the
standard deviation not just forcing it
in between 0 and 1.
which is a much better way usually to
normalize your data than just doing the
zero one setup
and finally we can actually look at the
actual values
and the same chart we just did
oops
I made a mistake on there with my data
there we go okay
and again we now have our actual data
instead of looking at just the if you
looked up here it's all between 0 and 1
and when we look down here
we now have some actual connections and
how far distance this different data is
again because more of a domain issue and
understanding the oil company what these
different values means and you can look
at these as being the distances between
different items
so a little bit different View and you
have to really dig deep into this data
we really want you to take away from
this is the dendigram and the charts
that we did earlier
and that is the cluster output and our
nice dendogram so this would be stage
one in data analysis of the cells again
you'd have to have a lot more domain
experience to find out what all the
individual numbers we looked at mean and
what the distance is and what's
difference between Central America and
Kentucky and why they're similar and why
it groups all of Central Kentucky
Florida Oklahoma Texas Arizona and
Southern us together into one larger
group so I'd be Way Beyond the scope of
this but you can see how we start to
explore data and we start to see things
in here where things are grouped
together and ways we might not have seen
before and this is a good start for
understanding and giving advice for
cells and marketing maybe Logistics City
development there's all kinds of things
that kind of come together in the
hierarchical clustering as you begin to
explore data and we just want to point
out that we get three clusters of
regions with the highest cells region
with average cells region with the
lowest cells again those are some of the
things that they clustered it around and
you could actually see where things are
going on or lacking you know in this
case if you're the lowest cells no one
wants to be in the region of the lowest
sales welcome to this session where we
will learn on time series analysis using
our programming language so this is
basically a mini project where we will
look at time series data and how we can
analyze it visualize it to basically
find some important information or
gather insights from the data now when
you talk about time series analysis time
series is basically any data set where
your values are measured at different
points in time so when you talk about
time series data data is usually
uniformly spaced at a specific frequency
for example hourly weather measurements
you have daily counts of website visits
monthly sales total and so on so when
you talk about time series that can also
be irregularly spaced and sporadic for
example timestamp data and computer
systems event log or history of 911
emergency calls now when we work with
time series data for example here I am
taking a energy data set we can see how
techniques such as time based indexing
resampling rolling windows can help us
explore variations in electricity demand
and renewable energy Supply over time
now here we will look at some aspects of
this data set which I am considering so
there is this is open Power Systems data
set and here is the data set I have we
can look at the data set now this is in
a simple format it has time it basically
has values for consumption and then you
have data for wind and solar and wind
plus solar so in certain cases you have
only the date and the consumption but
then if we scroll down we will also find
data for wind solar wind plus solar and
so on so this is a Time series data set
which we would want to work on sometimes
you may also have the data collected
which just does not have the time but it
may also have time stamp that is it
would have say hour minutes and seconds
and that can also be worked upon so
let's consider this data set and let's
work on this project where we will
Analyze This Time series data set now
here we can work on this time series
data we can basically create some data
structures out of it such as data frames
we can do some time based indexing we
can visualize the data we can look at
the seasonality in the data look at some
frequencies and also do some Trend
detection now when you talk about this
data set it has electricity production
and consumption which is reported as
daily totals in gigawatt hours and here
are The Columns of the data which I was
just showing you so you have data you
have consumption you have wind you have
solar and wind plus solar so this is the
data we have and we will basically
explore say electricity consumption and
production in Germany which has varied
over time so some of the questions which
we can answer here is when is
electricity consumption typically
highest and lowest how do wind and solar
power production vary with seasons of
the year what are the long term Trends
in electricity consumption solar power
and wind power how blue wind and solar
power production compare with
electricity consumption and how has this
ratio changed over time we can also do
wrangling or cleaning of this data or
pre-processing of data and create a data
frame and then we can visualize this now
let's see how do we do that so I will
open up my R studio and let's look at
the data set so here is the data set now
I'm picking it up from my machine you
can also pick it up from GitHub so all
the data sets or similar data sets can
be find in my GitHub repository and here
I can look in the data sets you will
find a lot of different data sets here
there are some time series data sets
such as power I can search for power or
you have basically coal
or you have this
opsd Germany daily data set and there
are many other data sets which you can
work on now to
get the documentation on this project
you can also look in my GitHub
repository and you can search for
repositories and then basically you can
look in data science and R and here
there is a project folder where I have
given the documentation sample data set
and also your time series analysis
related document this is also the code
which you can directly Import in your R
studio and you can practice or work on
this project so let's see how does that
work so first thing is we will create a
data frame
from this data set now here if you see I
am using header as true so that it
understands the heading of each column I
am also giving row dot names and I'm
specifying date so there is this date
column in the data set as I showed you
earlier let's look at it again so you
update consumption wind solar wind plus
solar so you can suggest that date
should become the index column which can
be useful so you can do this now let's
just create this let's look at what does
this data frame contain and here if you
see it shows me some data which has been
now as a part of this data frame
structure it starts with consumption
wind solar wind plus solar and if you
see this one is becoming my index column
so I can always do a head and look at
part of the data frame using head or
tail so look at the first records so
let's see this now that shows me the
head data I can also do a tail and look
at the
ending values so if you closely see here
we have wind solar wind dot solar and
that basically has n a values so there
are missing values but let's look at the
tail and that tells me that there is
some data available for wind and solar
and wind solar now we can always look in
a tabular format using View
and we can look at the data so this
shows me that there are values in these
columns we see any values but if I
really scroll down
I can see some values which would be
available for wind and solar and wind
solar so I can just use view now I can
look at the dimensions of this
particular object
and that tells me there are 400
4384 rows and four columns you can
always look at the structure that is
check the data type of each column which
can be very useful so if I see here I
don't see the date column because date
column was considered as an index which
can be useful but I also look at my
other columns they are of the num types
so that's the data type for each
attribute or each column here now we
would be interested in looking at this
date column so let's look at the data
type of this date column now if I try to
do this this will show me that this is
null because date as a column does not
exist because we created it as an index
so if I look at Road names
and then I search for my data show me
the index column or row dot names it
tells me these are the values that's the
date column which we are seeing here now
we can access a specific row by just
doing a my data and give the index value
or row name value so let's look at that
and that shows me based on this index
you are looking at the value you can
obviously search for a different date
something like this you can also pass in
a vector and you can give range of
values so that is 0 1 2006 to 4 of
January and we can look at this one so
it shows me
these are the values so here actually
I'm not giving a range but I'm just
selecting multiple values from row.names
now we already know that in R you have a
summary function so you can always do a
summary and that gives you for each
column it gives you minimum first
quartile median mean third quartile and
maximum values so we are looking at
consumption we are looking at wind solar
and wind dot solar now this is good but
then if I would want to really visualize
the data access the data do some
analysis then it would be good to take
all the columns and then we can later
decide to change the data type of say
date column if we want to use it so
earlier I was using date as row dot
names or the name of the rows or index
what you call in any other programming
language so here I will just use my data
set and I'll say header as true I'm
calling it my data 2. let's look at the
data and this one shows me
five columns wherein My First Column is
the date consumption wind solar and so
on now looking at the structure so let's
look at the data type
so it tells me that if now I'm
interested in looking at the date column
from my data to data frame it tells me
it is a factor with 4 384 levels and
these are the values so it is not in a
date time format it's a factor now what
we can do is we can convert this into a
date format how do we do that so let's
have a variable X and I'm going to use
as dot date function and I'm going to
pass in my date column so that's
assigned to X now let's look at the head
of X and it shows me the values we will
also see what kind of class it is and we
will look at the structure of X so class
already says it is date type and look at
the structure so it shows me the format
now we have converted this column or
column related value into X now how do I
basically extract values out of it or
make it a part of data frame so first I
will use so all once it has been
converted in date format I will go for
as dot numeric and here I will create a
variable called year and I will just do
a format on X which is basically of date
type and then I'm saying percentage y so
that will get me the ear component out
of this let's look at the values that
shows me year component
now similarly we can get the month out
of this and then basically look at the
month values we can get the day out of
it and we can get the day component now
if I look at my data 2 which we had
created earlier this basically had date
consumption wind solar wind solar so
what I can do is I can add these
extracted columns such as year month day
to my data frame using a c byte that is
column bind and I will assign it to my
data 2 again so let's do this and now if
you look at head it shows me date so
that should be date format consumption
now this one might not be date format
but we'll see you have consumption wind
solar and we have extracted the year
month and day which can help us for
group by we can do some aggregations we
can do a plotting and we can do various
things by these additional columns now
let's look at first three rows here so
I'll say one is to 3 for my data 2 and
that shows me some data here you can
always do a head and look at the sample
of data so that basically shows me month
day your columns and then you have your
date now what we can do is we would want
to visualize this data we would want to
basically understand the consumption now
as I said if we want to visualize the
data say for example I want this which
is consumption of data over years and
this one is in terms of gigawatts per
hour as we were mentioning here gigawatt
hours so if I would want to create this
visual to basically understand the
pattern of the data how do we do it so
we can you create a line plot of
full-time series of Germany's
electricity consumption using the plot
method now how do we do that so here
one of the option is I can straight away
use the plot method I can then say what
would be in my x-axis what would be on
my y-axis what would be the type of
graph I would want to plot what is my
name on x-axis y-axis and this is the
simplest way so I am saying my data 2
I'm extracting the year column and here
I am taking the consumption so let's
create a plot and here if you see we are
looking at a plot we do see some tick
times and we see that the data has been
divided with every two years so from
2006 onwards to 2016 but then really
this data does not give me uh you know a
very useful way of looking at the rate
or understanding it might be what I can
do is I can use the same way but I can
give apart from x axis and y axis I can
say that
limits that is X limit is 2006 to 2018
and Y limit is from 800 to 1700 so we
can do this and let's look at this again
this is a plot but it really does not
help me in visualizing and understanding
the data so what are the better options
I can go for multiple plots in a window
as of now we are just sticking to one
plot in window so if you would want to
have multiple plots you can always
change the value here and make it two or
three that will say how many rows and
how many columns so as of now we will
just keep it as it is par
MF row now if I would want to plot I can
straight away give the column name so I
am interested in getting the consumption
now I can just do a plot I'll say my
data 2 and I will choose the second
column which is consumption which we saw
here
from our data so consumption was the
second column so I can just do a plot in
a straight away way without mentioning
your x-axis y-axis limits and so on and
if you look at this this one is giving
me a pattern now here I am looking at
x-axis y-axis which is not really named
we do not have a name to this graph and
we are looking at the data it does show
me some kind of pattern but might be we
can make it more meaningful so I can do
it this way where I say my data second
column let's give access as ER x axis
y-axis is consumption now that has
changed the x-axis and y axis now I can
also give some more details I can say
type should be line I have the line
width I'm saying color is blue and let's
do this so this looks more meaningful
maybe shows a wavering pattern of
consumption over years I can also give a
limit of x that is 0 to 2018 and that
basically shows me the range now we can
change that and we can be more specific
and saying X limit should be 2006 to
2018 and let's look at this now this one
once you have given a proper limit it
shows the line graph and it shows what
was the consumption in 2006 and over a
period till 2018. I can then
use any of these options are fine but it
depends on what and whom you are
presenting the data or what kind of
analysis you are doing so I can do a
plot I can choose column second X lab
which is x-axis y-axis type is line
width giving X limit y limit and then
I'm giving a title to this which is
consumption graph
and then basically you are looking at
the line graph now those are the options
which you can do either you could be
very specific or you could just give
your column which you want to plot or
obviously make it more meaningful by
giving all the details now what we can
do is if we would want to look at this
data and understand it better rather
than just looking at a simple line I can
take the log values so here I am saying
log of my data to Second column so I'm
taking log values of consumption and I'm
taking the difference of logs so I can
say difference and then you can
basically increase or decrease this by
multiplying it by some number so rest
Remains the Same I am changing the color
and let's look at this plot and you see
this basically is giving me a better
pattern which makes meaning here we see
the log values so this is you are using
a simple plot function
in R you can also use ggplot now for
that we can install the ggplot package
it's already there in my machine so I'll
say no I will access this by using the
library vgg plot to
and now I can use ggplot to plot so
the way you specify here you can say my
data too that's the data frame I am
saying type as o and when I'm saying
line I am basically going to use x-axis
which is here Y is consumption and let's
look at this plot so again we are back
to the one which we were doing earlier
really does not make any sense gives us
some data but then really does not give
me enough information I can
in my Aesthetics I can say x as year Ys
consumption I can do a grouping and then
I can give line and plot so again we
have some information but really does
not help me right now let's look at
other example so I am just doing the
same thing here and I'm looking at line
type being test I'm using the GG plots
other methods such as geomline and
geompoint to give me more information
and if I look at the
plot it does give me data it tells me
what are the different values it gives
me some kind of pattern but I would
still prefer the way we were doing with
plot
now we can change the color and
obviously add details to it so what we
see is when you use the plot method
which I did earlier it was choosing
pretty good tick locations that is every
two years and labels the years for the
x-axis which was helpful right but with
these data points which we were seeing
here
or say for example this one
or say this one
or say this one we are looking at some
data but then that really is quite
crowded and it is hard to read you can
look at the values but then it really
does not give you enough information so
we can go for plot method but then we
will see how we can consider different
data now if I would want to plot the
solar and pinned time series so let's
see how do we do that
so wind column is what I'm interested in
so first thing is it was always good to
find out the minimum and the maximum
values in every column so I'm saying
minimum I'm saying let's put in here my
data to
and then let's look at the values so we
are looking at the columns we know
consumption is the second column when
does the third column and you have solar
as the fourth and this one is the fifth
so let's say let's find out the minimum
of each of these columns which we would
want to plot so let's say minimum of
data third column and here I'm also
saying remove the N A values because we
do not want to consider the N A values
so let's like look at the minimum that
shows me
5.7757 what is the maximum value it is
826 so that also helps me in giving a
limit if I want to plot wind on y-axis I
can give a y limit from 5 to 850
consumption wise let's find out the
minimum from second column and maximum
and similarly for solar find the minimum
and maximum and wind plus solar minimum
and maximum so this will be helpful when
you would want to plot multiple graphs
or give some limits so that's fine now
for multiple plots as I said instead of
having one plot let's plot consumption
and wind and solar and try to see a
pattern so I can say par function and I
will say three rows and one column so
now when I start plotting you will see
you will have multiple plots in one
single window so let's see how we do it
so here
let's look at plot one so this one is
consumption as we did earlier and let's
look at the data so that gives me some
data you can always do a zoom and you
can look at the data you can basically
expand this graph or you can reduce this
graph to see what kind of pattern we
have in consumption similarly we can
basically choose date being x-axis my
consumption being y-axis right so this
is being more specific because here we
have a range but it really does not give
me enough information so I will
basically give x-axis y-axis I will give
the name that is daily totals and then I
will basically give consumption color
and Y limit based on my minimum and
maximum limits so let's do this and now
we can look at the data here so let's
see this data makes a little more
meaning because we are looking at the
dates
and let me do a zoom so it shows me all
the dates it shows me the data points it
shows me how the data pattern is
changing for consumption now this is for
consumption so what we can do is we can
also extract specific data so if you see
here I have done some testing where I am
saying okay I would want to get a date
specifically
I would want to extract some value so we
are looking at the date column but if
you remember we did not change the data
type we just change the data type of
date column we extracted year month out
of it it would be good if we can convert
a column into date time format and put
that in our data frame now let's look at
the plot 2 this is mainly for your
column which should be consumption and
wind and solar so here I see it is solar
data and I can plot this one to see how
it looks like
and that tells me from 2006 onwards we
have some pattern I can be more specific
where I say I would be giving date and
then the column for solar x axis Y axis
what is the type what is the Y limit and
what is the color it is always good to
specify your X and Y axis give a name
rather than let it automatically pick up
now this makes more meaning because it
shows me some dates similarly we can do
for wind so either you do it just by
giving the column
or you give your X and Y axis so let's
look at this one
and this shows me the data so we can
choose plot 3 this one we can choose
plot 2 we can choose plot one and we can
put all that data in one graph so that's
when you are putting in multi plots in
one particular graph you can always do a
zoom you can always look at the data
right and this is usually useful to look
at the pattern what kind of pattern we
see what data we have and so on now
moving forward so we have seen how you
are creating these plots all in one
window let me reset this back to one
plot per window and let's basically plot
time series in a single year so what we
have seen is that when you look at the
plot method it was quite crowded then we
looked at solar and wind and if you
compare that you will see your
consumption pattern your solar pattern
your wind pattern and basically we can
see from this particular data data some
kind of pattern so electricity
consumption is highest in the winter
where we will see what is the
consumption
is it highest in Winter or is it in
summer we can see that by breaking a
year further into months we can see that
but we see a pattern which goes for
every year or every two years being
highest at a particular point of time
and then it drops down so electricity
consumption is highest in Winter and
that might be due to electrical Heating
and increased lighting usage and lowest
in summer now when you look at
electricity consumption appears to split
into two clusters we can always look at
the consumption one with oscillation
centered roundly around 1400 gigawatts
so you can always look at 1400 gigawatts
and you see all the values here which
are in that particular consumption
another with fewer and more scattered
data points entry is roughed around 1150
so if you really expand this you can see
you will have lot of data points at this
point
now we might guess that these clusters
correspond with weekdays and weekends
which we can see if you break that data
into yearly monthly weekly and so on now
if you look at solar production that is
highest in summer when sunlight is most
abundant and lowest in winter so
obviously when you are making or
gathering some insights when you're
looking at the data you are also using
your domain knowledge your business
knowledge you are you know knowledge of
business to understand how this goes if
you look at wind power production that's
again highest in Winters and drops down
in summer so due to stronger winds and
more frequent storms and lowest in
summer so there is some kind of
increasing Trend in wind power
production over years which we can see
here
over the years
and all the time series data what we are
looking at is referring or showing us
some kind of seasonality that is we are
looking at seasonality in which a
pattern is repeating again and again at
regular times
at regular intervals so if you look at
consumption solar and wind time series
that oscillates between high and low
values on a yearly time scale which we
can break down and see I'll show you
that it corresponds with the seasonal
changes in weather over the year so
seasonality does not have to correspond
with meteorological reasons for example
if you look at retail stale sales data
uh that will show you yearly seasonality
with increased sales in particular
months so seasonality when we say can
occur on other time scales so the plots
what we are seeing here they are fine
but if you look at those plots they
might show some kind of weekly
seasonality also so in your consumption
corresponding to weekdays and weekends
so let's plot for one single year now
how do I do that so first is I will look
at my data too
that shows me the structure it shows me
date which is Factor other columns which
are all numerics now like we did earlier
I'll repeat this step where I'm going to
convert the date column into date type
look at head of it look at class of it
look at the structure of it right and
then what I want to do is I want to add
this
as to my data frame so I will create a
variable called mod data and this one
will have as data and I'm formatting the
value of x which is date time into month
day and year so let's do that and now
you look at the mod data which I created
like modified data so this is the format
I have it is in date type if you
carefully see here and then I can look
at the head of it so it saves me mod
data now we are what we did here is when
I said my data 3
so my data 3 we did a c bind and I did a
mod data which is going to add this
column to my other Columns of my data
too so my new data frame is my data 3.
let's look at the structure of it and
you see there is this date column I can
delete it I can remove it I can let it
be right so that depends on our choice
might be we want to once our analysis
done we want to remove the mod data
right so we can keep both of them now
let's basically extract data for a
particular year now how do you do that
so this is some wrangling so I will say
my data 4 let's call it my data 4 and I
will use subset function so subset will
work on my data 3 that's the data and
what I'll do is I will do a subset how
do how is the subset found so I'll say
take the mod data column the value
should be greater than or equal to 2017
and should be less than
2017 December 31st so I'm getting data
for one year and I'm storing it as my
data 4.
let's get the head of it and you see we
are specifically looking at 2017 related
data now let's do a plotting of this
where I will only create a plot for one
year so I'm saying my data 4 that's my
new
data what we got
so here I am going to take the first
column
which is mod data
I am going to take the third column
which is consumption so I'm looking at
the date format for one year consumption
values for it and then rest of the
things as we have done earlier let's
look at the plot and this makes more
meaning right so when you look at this
plot it tells me Jan to Jan it shows me
some kind of pattern where I have
divided the year into months
right and it is broken down into say two
months so Jan and March and May and July
and so on but we still see a pattern and
that gives me good understanding of
pattern where I've broken it down into
months so this is where you have taken
time series in a single year to
investigate further and this is what we
see right now we can clearly see there
are some weekly oscillations what one
more interesting feature is that at this
level of granularity that is when you're
looking at yearly data there is a
drastic decrease in electricity
consumption in early January and late
December during the holidays or probably
we can assume that this is holidays now
I can zoom in further and look at just
Jan and Feb data
let's see how we do that and let's see
how we work by zooming in the data
further so to zoom in the data further
let's see how we do it now here we have
this my data 4 which is basically having
a subset right so let's work on this one
so I will say my data 4 which earlier I
was taking data 3 I was doing a subset
and I was giving the date but this time
I will make it more narrower so I'll say
my data 4 I will say subset from my data
3
and I will choose mod data column which
we have modified with the date format I
will choose the starting date as
1701 that is Jan and then let's go till
Feb and let's create this
now let's look at the head of this so it
shows me we have the data which is Jan
and then you you can basically look at
more on this now again as I said earlier
let's find out the minimum of this from
the First Column so that is basically
your mod data so let's look into this
one and that basically
will give me minimum and maximum let's
look at the value so this one tells me
Jan 17 January 1 and maximum is
your
Feb 28th second month 2017 so we are
actually looking at two months data here
let's look at the Y minimum so this is I
will look at column three now what is
column three consumption so let's look
at the minimum value for consumption
maximum value of consumption let's look
at the values which can be given as our
limits now this is the minimum and
maximum now let's do a plotting for this
data which has been narrowed down for
consumption based on my data so I'm
saying My First Column which is mod data
and then third column which is
consumption I am giving some naming
convention for sorry namings for your
x-axis y-axis
what is my consumption
or what is my title here what is the
color and then you see I'm using X limit
to give the minimum and maximum limit
and Y limit so let's look at this data
and if you look at this data it is
specifically for two months and again I
can look at the pattern here what I can
also do is I can add some grid here
so I can basically look at this data and
make more meaning out of it so it is
bi-weekly data you can see now I can add
a line here using AB line and then I can
basically choose what lines I would want
to add horizontally so that basically
allows me to dissect the data and look
at data in a more meaningful way I can
also add vertical lines so vertical
lines as I'm saying sequence will be
minimum maximum and I'm saying an
interval of seven so let's do this and
this basically has added some lines
every week and you can see at the end of
week it is dropping and then it is
starting again it Peaks somewhere in the
mid of the week and again it drops down
so this is you're looking at your
consumption data right now what we can
also do is we can create some box plots
so when we looked at zooming in data for
Jan and Feb you can add some data point
points like this so consumption is
highest on the weekdays as I showed you
here and lowest on the weekends so this
is what we are seeing when we are
breaking the data or zooming it further
for a couple of months so we have
vertical grid lines and we have nicely
formatted tick labels that is Jan first
and 15th Feb first and so on so we can
easily tell which days are weekdays and
weekends with use of these grid lines
and basically breaking it down so there
are many other ways to actually
visualize your time series data
depending on what patterns you're trying
to explore you can use Scatter Plots you
can use heat maps you can use use
histograms and so on now moving further
we would want to explore the seasonality
right so when you further explore the
seasonality of our data we can use box
plots basically to group the data by
different time periods and display the
distribution for each group now how do
we do that
let's come here and let's see how box
plot works so I can just do a simple box
plot and I can choose my consumption
column and that gives me just the
consumption data but this really does
not give me any meaning I can look at
solar data I can look at the wind data
and we can also see some outliers here
so we can create box plots but if we
would want to do a box plot what is box
plot it is basically a visual display of
your Phi number summary that is you want
to look at your mean median you want to
look at your 25th percentile 50
percentile or 75th percentile so we can
use a quantile function use the
consumption column and then you
basically give a vector which shows you
Phi number summary so that's your
quantile and then let's do a box plot so
if you are looking at quantile it tells
me what is the minimum what is 25th
percentile 50 75th and 100 that's from
my consumption column so let's create a
box plot for consumption let's give it a
name as consumption let's give y-axis as
consumption and a limit for y-axis now
that's my consumption graph so I can
look at yearly data now that will make
more meaning rather than just looking at
the complete consumption data so how do
we do it yearly so we will say
consumption and then I will say the year
column so it is consumption but grouped
based on year
so here I can give x axis y axis and I
can give y limit so let's create this
and this makes more meaning we can give
some coloring scheme here but now I'm
looking at 2006 2007 8 9 and so on and
we can look at the data what is the
range right it gives me 5 percentile or
sorry five number summary of the data
per year and it basically allows me to
look at the seasonality of this
similarly we can create box plot by just
giving consumption yearly grouped and
here I am giving the title as
consumption Y axis x axis and y limit
wherein I can also use less so this is
one more feature which you can do and
that basically will give me the tick
points if you compare this one to the
previous graph so when I created this
previous graph I had two 2006 2008 and I
had from 600 to 1800 and if I go for the
next one I am basically seeing more
useful information now let's look at
monthly data so I would want to group it
based on months
and let's create that so this gives me
the monthly data where I'm looking at
months
and I could select a particular year or
I can just do a grouping based on months
so I can have multiple plots to see a
difference here so let's do this now
let's create a box plot for consumption
which is monthly data and let's give it
a color let's look at the wind data
which is again grouped monthly and let's
look at the solar data which is grouped
monthly now if I zoom in it basically
gives me the seasonality of the data for
your wind for your consumption for your
solar so what we are doing is we are
creating these box plots which are
giving us values now what I can also do
is I could look at the day wise also but
before we look into this how do I infer
some information from these box plots
which are being created so this is what
we have done where we are looking at the
data for month and these box plots give
me year seasonality which we were seeing
in our gear plots but give some
additional insights so if I look at the
data here it tells me the electricity
consumption is generally higher in
winter
now this is based on months so we can
see consumption is higher in Winters and
lower in summer so we can obviously look
at our plot we can see where it is lower
where it is higher and then we can look
at the median and lower two quartiles
are lower in December and January
compared to November and February so
that is you look at the quartiles and
you will see that
the median and lower two quartiles are
lower in December and January
kill Chan and December so you can look
it from my plot now this is giving you
some idea on seasonality
now that might be due to business being
closed over holidays now this one we
were also seeing when we looked at time
series for 2017 only and box plot
basically confirms that there is this
consistent pattern throughout the years
now when you look at your solar and wind
power production both will give you a
year seasonality what we are seeing here
and
if basically I look at the data so it
depends on what parameters you are
choosing but if you look at solar it
will reflect the effect of occasional
extreme wind speeds associated with
storms and other transient and since we
are grouping it based on months we can
see this pattern is quite evident every
year
now what we can do is we can group the
data day wise so here let me again reset
this to one plot per graph now I'll say
box plot I'll say consumption which is
group based on day now we know that
there is a day column and let's give a y
limit and let's look at the data so this
is where I am grouping the data day wise
so you look at 31 days and you look at
the box plot so this is where you are
plotting it on a daily basis
so you can look at the data you can
break it down to a particular week so
here I have given day and I have chosen
all the 31 days but I can break it down
to a week and I can look at the data so
if we look at the data per week or per
day we can basically infer that
electricity consumption where I'm doing
a consumption group by day is higher on
weekdays than on weekends
so time series with strong seasonality
can often be represented with models
that can decompose signal into
seasonality and long Trend now this is
an easy way now how do we look at the
frequency of the data that could be
interesting to see so let me look at
say the yearly data
which we were seeing here
now let's go further and here we have
looked at data so what we will do is we
look at the frequency now when you look
at the frequency when you talk about
frequency in your data so we have the
modified date column which gives me a
frequency and if we really look into the
data that will tell me that the data is
on a daily basis so for that let's look
at my data 3 again which gives me data
and you can just see all the data's data
or dates are in sequence so your 22 20
24 25 26 and so on I can look at I can
access a d player package
that is basically allowing me to work in
a better way now I can look at the
summary of this and for all my columns I
am seeing what is the minimum Phi number
summary date and consumption so date
does not show me anything because this
is not in a date format it is just a
factor but other things have the fine
number summary so we are looking at wind
plus solar we are looking at year and
month and day and all these columns now
what we will do is we will want to find
out the sum of each
column how many entries does it have and
we will say the value should any value
should not be considered so let's look
at this one so it tells me for my
particular columns so let me run this
again
and that shows me for each column how
many values you have and these counts do
not include the N A values now similarly
I can find out specifically for
consumption I can find out is there any
n a value so I'm saying is Dot N A and
let's find out if there is any n a value
or missing value in consumption it says
0 okay that's good if you look in wind
it tells me there are
1463 entries which are n a
similarly solar similarly wind dot solar
or wind plus solar so it gives me a
count of n a values that is missing
values and also values which are not
missing so to understand frequency what
we can do is we can find out the minimum
on the date that is the First Column and
I am saying RM
n a DOT RM is true that is get rid of n
a values and find out the minimum and
let's look at the minimum value this is
the minimum from my modified date now if
I would want to get the frequency I can
basically use sequence function so I can
say from X minimum that is the minimum
value I want to look at the frequency
that is day wise and let's just look at
five entries and see if there is a day
by day frequency
so let's look at the value of this and
obviously it tells me there is day wise
frequency so that allows me to look at
the frequency look at the type of it it
is an integer class is a date so
similarly we can say from X minimum we
can basically look at the frequency
month wise and I can again look at five
records so that shows me monthly data
right so I can extract the data for
frequency similarly yearly data and
that's also very useful now we can
select data which has any values for
wind so how do I do it I would want to
find out the wind column and I want to
find out where the values are in a so I
will create a variable and here I will
say my data 3 and then I give a
conditional where I say is n a
in the column so let's do this now once
I've done this
once I've done this I have said that my
selected wind data from my data 3 where
we said any values and I will give the
names to this so name should be in my
data 3 I'm interested in mod data
consumption wind and solar so these are
the four columns I'm interested in let's
look at first 10 records here or first
10 rows so that tells me these are the
values where wind has n a or missing
values
I can always do a view and that gives me
the complete data so it basically shows
me
1463 entries
and here it shows me all n a values so
you can look at all the way to the end
and it shows me wind has any solar does
have some value here
in the last row but then also if you see
the numbers have
a difference so you have one four six
one and then you have two one seven four
so there is a difference so there is
some data in between where wind has some
values so we have found out any values
now what we will do is we will select
data which does not have any values so I
will call it cell selected wind 2 I'll
again use my data 3 I will say which but
now I am saying not any
from this column and I will select the
data for the columns so I am interested
in looking at 10 records and this shows
me not any value so no more missing
values so if I really look at this data
as I saw earlier which has n a and if I
look at these values which are not any
for the wind column so looking at these
two result we will know that in year
2011 wind column
has some missing values
so let's focus on year 2011. so how do I
do that let's call it a different
variable I'll say my data 3 I will say
here when I say which where we were
saying n a here I will say the year
should have a value of 2011 and I want
all these columns
let's look at the data here and this is
showing me 2011 but
V
are not seeing all the values so there
are some values but then there are some
missing values also for 2011 based on
whatever analysis we have done so let's
look at the class of this it is
basically a data frame do a view and
this one will help me in finding out
where are the N A values so if you just
scroll down
looking at all the data let's search if
wind column has a n a or a missing value
and I will see
if there is any missing value in which
column or which row it is for the wind
column so we have all the values which
are existing
I could select and search for one
specific value and I'll show you how we
can do that so here let's scroll all the
way down so it's like you're exploring
your data and seeing is
wind column having n a or missing value
for a particular row and let's scroll
here and here you see there is a missing
value for one particular row so 13th
December 2011 has wind value 15 December
has wind value but
your 14th December does not have right
similarly we can search so there was
only one entry which was missing now
that could be for some reason might be
it was not calculated might be it was
not tabulated so we have a missing value
in that so it tells it my plotting that
can affect my analysis so let's look at
the number of rows in this which will
tell me how many rows we have for 2011
so it tells me 365 so that is basically
the number of days in a year now we will
find out if there were any values so we
earlier checked total number of any
values per column
that is in your row number 265 to 269
we can see here 265 to 269
so this is where we were seeing are
there any n a values right so let's go
back here
and
we want to find out the number of any
values for a particular year how do I do
it so I can just do a sum I will say is
n a now I am interested in my data 3
wind column and I am saying my ear has
to be 2011 but I am finding out the N A
values
so let's do this and it tells me one and
that's right that's what we saw when we
did a view let's see how many non-na
values you have and that is 364 so that
basically
satisfies my logic so 364 plus 1 missing
so there are 365 let's look at the
structure of this it tells me you have
modified date and date format you have
consumption wind and solar now let's
create a variable
selected wind 4 I will save in 3 that is
which was having all my n a and non-na
values for 2011 I will say let's find
out the n a value
because I am interested in finding out
that particular row so I'm saying find
out where the values n a and I want all
the columns
let's look at this one and this is my
specific
row which has a n a value
now we know that data follows a device
frequency which we have clearly seen now
let's select data which has n a and
non-na values so let's say let's call it
test one I will use win3 which has n a
non-na values but now I will say I want
the modified date which should be
greater than 12 12 2001. now remember we
had when we were doing a view we saw
that one particular day or what we see
here 14th of December there is no date
so I will select a subset of data which
includes this n a and non n a that is
might be I can take 13th of December and
15th of December so let's start from 12
12
so the date should be greater than 12 12
that means 13th and it should be less
than 16 so that is 15th and the columns
right so now we have some data let's
look at this so I have a I've selected a
subset of data I could have done this
using subset also so I have any and non
any values now why are we doing this so
sometimes you might have some data for a
particular column and you may want to
find out if there are any missing values
might be you want to fill them up or
replace them with something so that is
usually useful when you are doing a
trend detection so say for example you
have data for every month and might be
in one one of the months you have missed
or might be you have data for every year
collected monthly and then in one of the
years for a couple of months you don't
have the data like I can say 2016 I have
data for all 12 months 2017 all 12
months 2018 might be a don't have data
for March and June 2019 I don't have
data for same months so I can forward
fill or backward fill them using the
previous year's same month data so we
can do that so here I have test data
where I've extracted a subset of data I
can look at the class of this it is a
data frame structure of this it has the
columns now let's use the library
and function and use the Tidy r package
and what we will do is we will fill it
up so I will use test one I will fill
the wind column which has a missing
value now once you do this if you notice
it has done a forward fill so it has
taken the previous value and it has just
filled up that so you can fill up the
data using different directions such as
up and down left and right and so on so
we can take care of missing values in
our frequency data which allows us to
basically
analyze the data in a better way now
here we will want to also look at some
more data so this is to deal with
frequencies of fill column
wherein you can take care of missing
values forward fill so filling values
can be done in different directions as I
said and you may want to First convert
your time series to specified frequency
if your data does not have a frequency
but we had now if you do not have a
frequency might be you can convert it
into a frequency such as weekly daily
monthly as I showed you and then
basically you can do a forward fill
for the values so for example if I have
my data I can break it down into weekly
and then look at the values and if there
are any values missing for weekly data I
can use a forward fill so that can take
care of my frequency data then let's
look at the trends of the data which is
the last part of this project so
basically let's look at the trend So
when you say Trend what does that mean
so in Time series data
you always have some kind of trend so
that will exhibit some slow gradual
variability in addition to higher
frequency variability such as
seasonality and noise now to visualize
these Trends what we do is we use what
we call as rolling means so we know how
our data is spread over year or month or
day but how about looking at a rolling
average and see what is the difference
so a rolling mean will tend to smooth a
Time series by averaging out the
variations and frequencies
so this can be higher than the window
size so there is something called those
windowing where you can choose a set of
time frame you can also average out any
seasonality on a time scale equal to
window size so this will allow you to
look at lower frequency variation in the
data
so when we are looking at electricity
consumption time series we already saw
there is a weekly pattern there is a
yearly seasonality which we saw using
box plots so we can also look at the
rolling means of the time scales how do
we do that so for this you can use some
package like zoo and then you can
basically use a rolling mean using the
zoo package and you can say what is the
frequency with which you want to
calculate the rolling mean now how do we
do this let's look at this data so here
I am going to my look at my data 3 which
we have been using so far now let's call
it a three day test you can give it any
name I'm going to use my data 3 I'm
using the python function
now I will use D plier and I will
arrange the data in descending in here
now you can always break it down step by
step and you can see the result of this
so I'm going to arrange this data in
descending order of year
so obviously my last one 2017 or 2018
will be on the top you want to group the
data by year so it depends on how many
years we have we'll see so you can group
the data by year now this data is then
used to basically mutate so mutate
function is going to allow me to use
this rolling mean so I'll call it as
says 0 3 day so I'm going to calculate a
rolling mean every three days for my
consumption column and
basically let's ungroup this so let's
see how this works
sorry yeah let's look at this and here
when I'm doing a three day test
let's look at the result of this and
then I'll explain this so if you see
here we have the test three day column
now this has the rolling average now
what does that mean so first value here
what we see is one three six seven is
the average consumption in 2017 from the
first date with the data point on either
side of it that is you can look at this
date so one one three zero then you look
at
you are looking at the value one three
six seven here so you look at one one
three zero one four four one one five
three zero if I take a mean of these so
for example if I would just do this part
and that
is giving me mean okay because I have a
comment so let's basically add anything
as comment and then let's do this so it
saves me one three six seven that's what
we are seeing here right so you've got
getting a rolling average every three
days similarly if you want every five
days it takes the five values and it
gets the mid value right so you can
always find out the mean rolling mean
for a particular frequency now let's do
that for seven days that is weekly data
and yearly data that is 365 days so how
do I do it same logic my data test
now I am using my data 3 I'm arranging
it in a descending order I am grouping
by year so when you do a group by year
so earlier when we did a grouping by and
when we looked at the data it was
telling me how many rows we had right so
let's do a grouping by year and let's
say test 0 7 so that's a rolling average
every seven days and I'm also saying
take care of the N A values similarly
I'm getting rolling average every 365
days might be you can do quarterly might
be you can do half yearly and let's do
this so let's create this my data test
and let's look at the result of this so
I will use my data test I will say
arrange based on modified date now we
know there is a column called modified
date I want to just look at 2017 data so
I'm doing a filter
right and then I will choose what are
the columns I'm interested in so I will
look at the 7 and 365 day and let's look
at say first seven records so let's do
this
and that basically gives me the
consumption value modified date year and
my rolling seven day average or the web
seven day mean which is for first seven
days and then 365 you will not see the
data here but if I do a view on this I
can basically see the values so you can
always select a particular column to see
the values
these are the values for every seven day
rolling average this is for 365 days
every 365 days so you see all the values
are missing but every 365 entry you will
have basically some data
now
let's do a plotting of this and
basically visualize this data which we
are seeing rolling average so let me
first do a plotting one plot per graph
and let's do a plotting I will take
consumption data
x-axis y-axis
color and give a title to this so let's
create this and that's my consumption
data which is spread over a period of
time and that's fair enough but now
let's add some more plot to this so I
will add the seven day rolling average
to this so for second plot to be added
in the same one in R you can use points
so I will say points I will choose seven
data column type is line width X limit y
limit and color so let's do this and
that's my pattern seven day rolling
average which basically gives me some
kind of trend
similarly I can add one more here and
this time I will choose the 365 day
and look at the pattern lines so now you
see some Dots here well you could do it
in a different way so I can just add
Legend to this and I can say Legend will
be a very next axis and y-axis so I am
saying it will be 2500 and Y is 1800 so
my Legend will come in somewhere here I
am saying my Legend will have
consumption test and this one I can give
some names I can give what is the color
I can say what kind of
Legend it explains what is
for each color and then basically a
vector so let's add a legend to this and
I've added a legend now you can do a
zoom and look at the data
and
here I see that my x-axis is fine but
y-axis is going a little about of my
plotting area so I can actually change
that so here I have 1800 how about
making it 1600 and let's look at this
one so we can basically uh go for this
one and start again here plot end points
and line and then add a legend right and
you can basically place your Legend
anywhere in the plot so this basically
is giving me the trend what I'm looking
at my rolling average so similarly you
can look at the trend for wind and solar
data so what we are seeing here is when
you look at Trend this is one more way
of looking at it you can always create
plots in different ways so seven day
rolling mean has smoothed out all week
leases personality which we were seeing
Here in My Graph where you look at every
seven day preserving the yearly
seasonality so seven day will tell that
electricity consumption is typically
higher in Winter and lower in summer so
better is you break it down yearly so
here if you look at every ear you can
see when it's winter when it's summer
what is the seasonality what your Trend
what you are seeing here and if there is
a decrease or increase for few weeks
every winter so similarly if you look at
365 now as you said as I said rolling
average basically
uh reduces the variation so if I look at
360 by Rolling mean we can see long-term
Trend in electricity consumption is
pretty flat now that's what we are
seeing it's kind of pretty flat there is
not much variation over years if you
really join these dots
so
we can basically see some highs and lows
and that gives me a trend now this is
how you can do a trend detection and
similarly we can do plotting for wind
and solar so this is a small project
which I demonstrated using R now all
this code
which you have here in the form of a
project.r file you can find here in my
GitHub page this is a document which
explains some things feel free to
download this and you can add details to
it this is the sample data set which you
can also find in my repository in the
data sets folder so continue learning
and continue practicing R so who is a
data science engineer are you a data
science engineer or are you going to be
looking for a different field what
exactly is a data science engineer well
a data science engineer is someone who
has programming experience and Python
and our expert level knowledge ability
to write proficient codes and the we
have Python and R I'm going to say
python or R once you've become really
proficient at one language transferring
those skills into another one is usually
fairly easy now R is a little different
because it is an analytics platform so
going from python to R if you already
know that the data analytics in Python
moving to R is pretty easy now R doesn't
have all the other code that you can
access with python there's so many
things you can do with python that that
are not data analytics so that's
important to keep in mind that you
should probably be pretty well-rounded
in Python and really have a solid
foundation in r or have a solid
foundation R and be well-rounded in
another programming language where you
really get the programming side of it
strong SQL and Big Data experience so
you have to have a strong coding skill
with Hands-On Big Data experience and of
course we're showing SQL here most
commonly used whether you're using a
Microsoft SQL server or MySQL server you
can also start thinking Hadoop and Spark
in Big Data access Hadoop file system is
not a huge jump if you've already
learned your SQL and you've already
learned your basics in coding Hadoop
sits on top of all that and does a
wonderful job creating huge clusters of
data but you really need to know your
SQL because that is so common in most of
the large companies now accessing their
data and an ability to visualize models
and troubleshoot code of the models this
is a kind of an interesting one because
these models are can get very
complicated so you got to be able to
break them down into something that you
can put the pieces together and digest
each of the pieces so being able to
visualize these models is very important
and then being able to drill down and
troubleshoot the different models or the
pieces in those models they need to be a
versatile Problem Solver equipped with
strong analytical and quantitative
skills a self-starter with a strong
sense of personal responsibility and
Technical orientation this is an
interesting one because when you talk
about data science engineer it's such a
new field that most companies don't have
it well defined they don't know what
they're looking for you might not even
know what you're looking for you might
have an idea and you're looking for
patterns but where do those patterns
lead you so you really need that
self-starter side to jump in there and
figure out where to go and be able to
communicate that back to the team and
there there we go we have a strong
product intuition data analysis skills
and business presentation skills this is
what I was talking about is you're going
to bring that back to the team so if you
don't have a strong product and tuition
if you don't know what's going on with
the company what they need and where
you're going with your analysis it's
going to be a dead end and you got to be
able to present that to the shareholders
to your co-workers which leads us to
Great teammate with excellent
interpersonal skills and this is kind of
a strange one because you spend so much
time behind your desk so you have to be
able to kind of float between you're
studying all the data and being able to
explain this to people in simple terms
that they can understand no one wants
somebody to come up and say yeah the
Peace Corps and the F score is this that
and the other thing and you might have
two people in the room understand you
you have to be able to sit down and
explain what that means and why so let's
take a look at the data science skill
set when we talk about data science
engineer skill set we're talking about
database knowledge statistics
programming tools data wrangling
probably the least favorite and most
used machine learning data visualization
and then to touch on big data and so
we'll start with database knowledge the
most common databases of course your SQL
structured query language think rows and
columns it's an essential language for
extracting a large amount of data from
data sets so knowledge of the SQL is
mandatory for data science engineers and
you can see there's tools required
there's the Oracle database I mentioned
MySQL server Microsoft SQL Server
teradata there are so many different
forms of SQL and it'll just keep coming
back and coming back so if you don't
have a solid basic understanding of SQL
go get it very important because it will
come up you know it's if you don't know
it it's going to bite you in statistics
of course we are you know that's what
this is all about is figuring out and
predicting things so you need to know
your statistics statistics is a subset
of mathematics that deals with
collecting analyzing interpreting data
therefore data scientists needs to know
statistics so you need to understand
your probabilities and what what that
means and what the p-score means in the
F score and means and mode and median
all that information standard deviation
all of those you need to be aware of and
then we get into the programming tools
and I mentioned this earlier a little
bit but you need to master any one of
these specific programming languages
programming tools such as R python SAS
are essential to perform analytics in
data and again you know you can move in
there and you can be an expert in just R
you can be an expert in just SAS in a
little bit you can be an expert in
Python because most of these when we're
talking about data science and data
wrangling you really kind of get down to
the point where you really need to have
a full programming language at least the
basics and if you're going to be working
in data science python right now is the
main one but you know there's also Java
C plus plus so you need to know a solid
language at least the basics of it so
you can understand how to do basic
iterations and things like that I always
find that interesting that my sister who
runs a university data analytics Center
that's the first question she asks for
people candidate to come and work for is
how do you iterate through data you'd be
amazed at how many people don't
understand that very basic concept in
programming so when we look at r r is a
free software environment for
statistical Computing and graphs
supports most machine learning
algorithms for data analytics like
regression Association clustering and
Etc python python is an open source
general purpose programming language and
there's our general purpose I was just
talking about you need to know a little
bit about python libraries like numpy
and scipy are used in data science scipy
yeah numpy and site Pi are very Central
to Python and I'd throw pandas in there
also that module those are very Central
to working with python and data
analytics and then SAS SAS can mine
Ultra manage and retrieve data from a
variety of sources it can perform
statistical analysis on the data so
where R is the open source platform SAS
is more like the paid for platform and
so it has some things more automated
because people are paying for it
developing it but it's also if you
really start using it as a company
you're gonna have to pay for it where RS
resource is uh free software Python's
also open source and free to use so
we're going to talk a little bit about
data wrangling and I mentioned earlier
that is uh both the probably people's
least favorite aspects of data science
and also probably one of the places you
spend the most time so when we talk
about data wrangling it is a process of
transforming raw data into an
appropriate format to make it useful for
analytics and it involves cleaning raw
data structuring raw data and enriching
raw data and this gets interesting
because you'll get stuck on something
like in Python you might get stuck on
something that is a date time based on
an integer 64 numpy set you might not
know what all those terms mean because
you work in r or something like that but
you get the point that it's all one
particular format and then you have to
figure out how to switch it so that the
computer can see it correctly in
whatever format you're using or whatever
analytics platform you're using
knowledge of machine learning techniques
such as supervised machine learning
decision trees linear regression k n Etc
is useful for few job roles so this is
kind of interesting because sometimes
that's the center of the job role of a
data scientist and sometimes you just
have to be able to apply the programming
skills to it so you can get the answer
and let somebody else fine-tune your
machine learning techniques so it really
depends on what it is you're working
with and you can see here we have our
nearest neighbor setup where it groups
things together that look alike linear
regression you're drawing a line through
the data or curve so you can predict
what the next value is going to be and
then our nice decision tree which starts
splitting things up and says you know
it's sunny out yes let's go swimming no
it's raining we're not going to go
swimming yes Jan semi might go swim it's
raining uh we'll stay indoors yes we'll
walk the dog no so you have a decision
tree that helps figure out how you get
to the end result so decision trees can
be pretty powerful and data
visualization data visualization is the
study and creation of visual
representation of data data
visualization uses algorithms
statistical graphs plots information
graphics and other tools to communicate
information clearly and effectively this
one you really have to master as a data
science this one you really have to
master as a data scientist and there
certainly are so many different tools to
use to visualize it but when you're
communicating a picture is worth a
thousand words when you can put a
picture up and and people can look at
and go oh I see what's going on that's
worth a lot more than saying yeah yeah
this is good people hear that and they
just kind of go okay it's good but why
and you might say you know okay these
numbers make it look good no people want
something they can see and there
certainly is Tableau is probably one of
the most popular ones out there calic
view power bi Google data studio in pi
python there's the pi kit and Seaborn
there's all kinds of different options
for visualization you need to master
probably at least one or two of them so
you understand how they work and how
they're different and then Big Data big
data is a massive amount of data which
cannot be stored and processed using
traditional methods big data has various
benefits like access to social data can
enable organizations to tune their
business strategies Big Data can improve
customer experience uh and so we're
usually when you say big data we're
almost always talking about Hadoop and
Apache spark it used to be Hadoop as
your file system so that's how you store
all your data going across the nodes and
there certainly are other ways to store
it when we talk about Hadoop we're
usually talking about at least 10
terabytes of data when you're dealing
with a Hadoop file structure and then
you can use spark where Hadoop processes
on and off the hard drive so it's
continually reading and writing to the
hard drive spark is running in your RAM
and so when you're doing a very
intensive data process you'll run a
spark setup which will spread those
processes over multiple computers and of
course now the two combine and Spark
sits on top of Hadoop and you get your
big data there's also a talent Tableau
has its own server set up there's Splunk
Cassandra you'll hear the Cassandra
database pentahoe I'm not even sure how
to pronounce that one it's not one I've
worked with certainly there's a lot of
options for Big Data the two big players
are of course Hadoop and Spark and even
your SQL servers and MySQL servers will
spread across five different servers and
you can be talking about Big Data across
five servers with those pulling them
into say Apache spark to do your
high-end processing and then there's
non-technical skills probably the most
important one in data science in any of
our data analytics is intellectual
curiosity updating knowledge by reading
contents and relevant books on Trends in
data science this is such there's so
much going on in this field and it's
exploding now that it's hard to keep
track of it all so you really need to
have that Curiosity in the data science
probably even more so than a lot of
other fields but I would say in just
today's world you need intellectual
curiosity because things are changing so
rapidly in today's world the way that's
going with our technology understanding
how the problem solved can impact the
business business Acumen this is the one
where a lot of people kind of skip over
you have to have a little business sense
if you don't know how it's going to
impact the business you're going to be
in trouble why do they want to even pay
you to be there unless they know what's
going on and they're getting something
in return so this is your bottom line
for your paycheck is what's going on
with the business how is this going to
impact the business what are you doing
for them in communication skills
companies look for someone who can
clearly and fluently translate technical
findings to a non-technical team and
I've talked about this a bunch and I I
can't even iterate this enough if you
are struggling with your communication
skills work on building them they don't
have to be you know this isn't rocket
science where you have to know all these
complicated terms what you need to do is
take the complicated terms you know from
data science and reduce that down to
something that anybody can understand so
when you come up and you have you know
knnn no one knows that k n is you know
unless they're in data science nearest
neighbor looking for things that match
together you got to explain that to
people who do not have the technical
skill in the data science Arena and a
data science engineer needs to work with
everyone in the organization including
customers so it's teamwork and that's
always one that throws people for a loop
But ultimately you are analyzing your
customers information and so sometimes
getting in there and rolling up your
sleeves if you're let's say you're doing
data analysis for a sales team and
you're backing a sales team you might
have to get in there and go start making
some cells and making some phone calls
and see what it's like what is that team
doing when they call 15 people in cold
calls and then they do a follow-up two
weeks later or three weeks later which
one works better two or three does it
work better to call and send a fax call
and send an email you know when should
you show up in person if it's that kind
of business so working with everybody
including the customer is very important
with the data with this kind of setup
and non-technical skills for a data
scientist so let's take a look at some
of the roles a data science plays in the
job market let's drill in there just a
little bit here so when you have a data
scientist they're going to perform
predictive analysis and identify Trend
and patterns that can help in better
decision making companies hiring data
scientists include Apple Adobe Google
Microsoft I would say that's even
expanding down to smaller companies you
know where you're talking about only 100
employees or something like that they're
starting to look at data scientists
because they need them to come in and be
a part of that team and the rule is
understanding challenges of a system and
offer best Solutions this should always
be the goal of a day data scientist is
to be looking at the whole system and
then trying to find those patterns that
are going to best enhance the company or
the business or the whatever group maybe
you're working with the sales team or
the marketing team and you can see
languages pretty important to have a
these are a number of different
languages and again it depends on your
own specialty there's all kinds of
different variations but we have R SAS
python Matlab SQL Hive Pig spark you
should have at least a knowledge of all
of these maybe a python programmer never
used our download it go through the
basics so at least you know what's going
on in R versus python because R is
pretty powerful for doing a very quick
display and then of course a lot of
things you can do in Python you have to
be able to do queries on database from
time to time create and modify
algorithms which can be used to reduce
information from large databases I mean
usually this is one of those things you
do at the beginning you set it up and
then you kind of Let It Go Until It
Breaks and you have to go back and fix
it because your query isn't working that
certainly is a very very common thing to
to have happen especially if you're
pulling data off the web and the
internet and then we have some more
companies that are hiring data analysis
like IBM DHL HP and so we're talking
about data analysts the role is
responsible for a variety of tasks such
as visualization optimization and
processing large amount of data and so
we're talking about a data analyst we're
also we're still talking a lot of the
same stuff which you'll see we now
thrown in JavaScript and HTML in here
because that's pretty common with the
data analyst versus a data scientist and
you can see that SQL is still pretty
solid and also CC plus plus is pretty
big so some companies also use Java so
I'd put Java in the languages also on
that for a data analyst and then you
have a data architect ensuring that data
Engineers have best tools and systems to
work with and so companies hiring a data
architect are like Visa Logitech
Coca-Cola they create blueprints for
data management with the best security
measures I cannot highlight that a data
architecture really spends a lot of time
with security measures that's big how
many hacks have we seen in the last year
on large companies have lost data for
millions of their customers and how
badly that affects them and we're
looking at languages as you see that SQL
is pretty solid across all of these
under a data architect XML that's one
that a lot of the data science jobs
don't really you don't see as much but
you're going to see more XML with a data
architect because there's a lot of XML
files that are that have your security
measures embedded in them and of course
your hive Pig those are Hadoop systems
we're doing some basic queries so
instead of doing the high-end queries
you know how these simplified query
systems built into Hadoop and Spark so
if you're using big data you're going to
want to know your spark also and then we
have our data engineer the data engineer
updates the existing systems with better
version of the current Technologies to
improve the efficiency of the databases
think admin here a lot of work tracking
down what version you're in of the
different programs which version of
python are you using what version of R
are you using what version of C plus
plus so companies hiring data Engineers
or like Amazon Spotify Facebook and they
develop construct test and maintain
architectures such as databases and
long-scale processing systems and here
we have our languages our SQL our Matlab
SAS SPSS python Java Ruby C plus Pearl
Hive Pig you pretty much as a data
engineer at this level when you talk
about the admin and updating all these
databases need to know all the different
stuff that's being used in the company
and you're testing out these structures
to make sure they work and so you really
are talking admin level kind of setups
if you like spinning up an admin onto a
Google cloud service or Amazon cloud
service now you start to get an idea
what we're talking about because then
you can test it out up there and then
you can bring it back and update it to
the company statistician creates new
methodologies for engineers to apply and
so when we look at this this is where
we're digging into the math path of
Which models to use what setup is going
to work what kind of activation do we
have on our neural network these little
tweaks are going to make a big
difference and we look for methodologies
at a large level what kind of data are
we going to be looking at how we're
going to pull it together companies
hiring a data engineer or we're talking
about statisticians we're talking about
LinkedIn PepsiCo Johnson and Johnson and
of course these companies probably hire
a little bit of everything but they have
a lot of statisticians working for them
and so we look at the role extract and
offer valuable reports from the data
clusters through statistical theories
and data organization and the languages
across the board we're still seeing SQL
our Matlab SAS SPSS data that's a new
one that we haven't seen in some of the
other roles python Pearl an older
version and that shouldn't be a surprise
because a lot of these companies
probably built a lot of the original
packages on Pearl if you go look at
Johnson and Johnson and of course your
big data Hive Pig and Spark and then our
database administrator I mentioned the
other one is an admin there are more or
an admin level for the software itself
so administrator is another level some
of the tasks involved are monitoring
operating and maintaining databases
installation configuration defining
schemas training users Etc and this is
interesting training users because when
you build a database and you define all
the different tables that are embedded
in that database and how they're all
connected the end user's got to have
that information otherwise you're in
trouble when we have companies hiring
data Engineers of course Tableau Twitter
Reddit the role ensures that all the
databases are available to all relevant
users again a little security in there
what role do they have is allowed in and
not and is performing correctly and is
being kept safe and you better be ready
to spend some time in security because
again that's a very big thing nowadays
with the number of people who hack into
these databases in the languages are
going to be covered you have your
c-sharp your Java SQL Ruby on Rails XML
again there's that XML because a lot of
your securities and embedded in XML
files python all the main players
depending on what the company's using
data and analytics manager so when you
see manager that means that somebody's
going to sit on top and organize the
people underneath so they're going to
improve the business process as an
intermediary between business and I.T oh
you better have some really good
communication skills for this one some
of the companies hiring a data Engineers
or Coursera Motorola slack of course
these companies are hiring data
scientists in almost all of these fields
so the role oversees the data science
operations and assigns the duties to the
team according to skills and expertise
so that's a big one you better be able
to communicate what's going on help your
team members come out and be able to
communicate with other people so
sometimes your job is just being able to
get people to talk to each other the big
thing on that is is the whole
communication line going from one end to
the other because you can't communicate
all the information that everybody's
working on you have to pretty much to
come in there and help people
communicate what there's going on and
also know what they're up to without
being micromanagement because that will
crash a company if you micromanage
everybody but if you just let them do
whatever they want and they never talk
to each other that will also destroy the
company you got to find that nice middle
ground and you really have to have an
overview of everything as a data and
analytics manager one of the things I
mean you know it's good to have at least
one or two solid bases of programming
under your belt for a data analytics
manager but you do need to have a very
general understanding of all the
different tools being used so that you
know what's going on with your different
team members of course sqlr SAS Java
python Matlab all of those are big
business analytics so this is when
you're talking about your bi or your
business intelligence and your business
analytics very important to know this is
kind of a subdivision of a lot of the
other stuff we've talked about a lot of
the other rules we've looked at so you
possess specialized knowledge of their
business domain and apply that knowledge
and Analysis specifically to the
operation of the business so you might
be a specialist in banking you might be
a genetics engineer so you know about
genetics you might just be General
business helping the marketing so a lot
of companies hiring data engineer Oracle
Uber Dell and the role act as a link
between the data engineers and the
management Executives so it's very
similar to when you go back up here we
look at data analytics manager a
business and analytics is going to also
kind of fill that role in between but
they're more specialized in business and
you better know SQL because we're
talking about business specifically most
of the large companies are storing their
data that's up and running right now
that people are accessing to purchase
something on the Home Depot website or
the Uber they're logging in you better
know your SQL it's very Central to
business analytics so let's go ahead and
take a look at the data science engineer
salary Trends and you'll see that our
source is Glassdoor as we're pulling a
lot of our data from average base pays
around 117
000 in the US the average salary and
when we look at India we're talking
about 950
000 a year and those are based on some
of them you need to go ahead and dig
deeper to find out what education level
versus entry level but those are pretty
solid base once you're in the industry
and once you've created your career in
there we look at the job titles the most
common job title is data scientist
business intelligence manager is the
second greatest one that's kind of good
to note that's why they put that up
there as being its own little
subcategory of data science managers a
business intelligence manager because
it's such a high level of jobs and then
we looked at some of the other ones data
architect business intelligence
architect again your bi your business
intelligence gets its own ranking
because it's such a high level you know
it's a business people want their
businesses to make money so that's who's
hiring of course data engineer business
intelligence developer business
intelligence consult business
intelligence analyst business analyst
and data analyst so you can look at the
data analysis being the general one that
doesn't go specific to business so if
you're looking just for your career as
far as getting a job probably should
have some kind of business understanding
in the background and again you know
your companies want to make money so
they're going to hire someone who knows
business if banking business if you
specialize in banking or retail if you
specialize in retail and marketing and
you can see here on the data science
salary Trends and the growth in data
science job listings it's continually
going up it's um since 2014 to 2012
we've gone from 400 to 600 that's a
pretty big increase so you know huge
growth in this market it's one of the
biggest growing markets right now for
jobs and careers so let's go ahead and
take a look at building a resume always
exciting putting ourselves out selling
ourselves and if you looked at some of
our other videos dealing with some
resumes you'll see a trend here the top
part is so different than what resumes
were in the 90s in the 2000 to 2010
they've evolved they've really evolved
it used to be 2000 2010 maybe LinkedIn
maybe one other reference now you're
going to see that we want those
references this is a sales tactic which
now has come into resumes used to be
that if you're a real estate agent every
real estate agent I knew I used to deal
with real estate software for the real
estate industry back in the 90s every
real estate agent won their picture on
their business card they wanted them
their picture if they could put on their
contracts they want people to see the
face so that's really a big change is to
make sure that it stands out you stand
out here's a picture of somebody so
you're more than just a couple letters
and a name and of course you need your
contact information should always be at
the top you have your summary what are
you focusing on be a little careful with
your summary because if you have
everything in your summer memory and
then they scroll down to experience and
education and skills they're going to
stop the second you repeat yourself in
your resume that usually means to the
reader hey this person doesn't have
anything more to offer me I'm done so be
a little careful how you word your
summary most companies appreciate when
you come in here and you've adjusted
this summary to be both about you and
how you're going to serve that company
so it's worth researching that company
to find out how those connect and put
that in the summary take some time to do
that that's actually a pretty big deal
and the references are huge also
especially in data science when you're
talking about any of the programming or
data science data analytics having a
place to go where they can look it up
and scroll down and see different things
you're doing whether it's LinkedIn in
this case which is a business profile
most commonly used in GitHub where you
have stuff published Facebook I'm always
hesitant because that tends to push more
towards social media type jobs and other
jobs but certainly there's people who
have Facebook who do marketing and stuff
like that but these links having these
basic links here is important people are
starting to look for that for some other
setup maybe you have a personal website
this is a good place to put that so that
they now have a multitude of links that
go back to you and highlight who you are
and then the next part or next four
parts so for the next four parts we have
a combination of experience education
skills certifications and you can see
they're organized if you have you know a
lot of people like to see what kind of
degree you have they want to know where
it came from and if you just got out of
college you're going to put education at
the top and then maybe you'll put skills
after that and then your experience at
the bottom if you've been in the field
for years you know my degree just to
give you my age goes back to the night
early 90s so I usually put education at
the very bottom and then because a lot
of the stuff I'm trying to sell myself
on right now is my skill I actually put
that at the top and I'll put my
education my certifications at the
bottom my skills and then my experience
is since it's a huge part of my resume
goes next you can organize these in
whatever order you want that's going to
work best for you and sell you so
remember you're selling yourself this is
your image probably don't wear an old
tie-dye T-shirt with holes in it you
know something nice because it is
professional and of course your summary
your and then what do you have to offer
the company and again when I put out
resumes and I haven't done a resume in a
while you go in there and you can take
this and reorganize this so if the
company's looking for something specific
you might put the experiences specific
to that company you might even take
experience if you have like a long job
history like I do I've gone into a lot
of different things you might leave out
those companies or those experiences
that had nothing to do with data science
because it just becomes overwhelming
resume should only take about 30 seconds
to glance over maybe a minute tops
because because after that point you've
lost the person's interest and if they
want to dig deeper they now have links
they have your website they have
LinkedIn and they can now take this and
they come back to it and they go okay
let's look at this person a little
closer so quick overview this is your
sales sheet selling you to the company
so always tie it to the company so that
you have that what am I going to give
this company what are they going to get
from me we've covered a lot on data
science engineer in general and we've
gone over a basic resume remember keep
it simple short and direct that is so
important with that resume so one of the
first questions that you may face is
what are the different types of machine
learning now what is the best way to
respond to this there are three types of
machine learning if you need any
material you will always be told there
are three types of machine but what is
important is you would probably be
better of emphasizing that there are
actually two main types of emotional
learning which is supervised and
unsupervised and then there is a third
type which is reinforcement learn so
supervised learning is where you have
some historical data and then you feed
that data to your model to learn now you
need to be aware of a keyword that they
will be looking for which is labeled
data right so if you just say pass data
or historical data the impact may not be
so much you need to emphasize on labeled
data so what is labeled data basically
let's say if you are trying to do train
your model for classification you need
to be aware of for your existing data
which class each of the observations
belonged right so that is what is
labeling so it is nothing but a fancy
name you must be already aware but just
make it a point to throw in that keyword
labeled so that will have that
okay so that is what is supervised
learning when you have existing labeled
data which you then use to train your
model that is known as supervised
learning and unsupervised learning is
when you don't have this labeled data so
you have data it is not labeled so the
system has to figure out a way to do
some analysis on this okay so that is
unsupervised learning and you can then
add a few things like what are the ways
of performing a supervised learning and
unsupervised learning and what are some
of the techniques so supervised learning
we we perform or we do regression and
classification and unsupervised learning
uh we do clustering and clustering can
be of different types similarly
regression can be of different types but
you don't have to probably elaborate so
much if they are asking for just the
different types you can just mention
these and just at a very high level but
if they want you to elaborate give
examples then of because I think there
is a different question for that we will
see that later then the third so we have
supervised and we have unsupervised and
then reinforcement you need to provide a
little bit of information around as well
because it is sometimes a little
difficult to come up with a good
definition for reinforcement
so you may have to little bit elaborate
on how reinforcement learning works
right so reinforcement learning works in
in such a way that it basically has two
parts to it one is the agent and the
environment and the agent basically is
working inside of this environment and
it is given a Target that it has to tip
and every time it is moving in the
direction of the target so the agent
basically has to take some action and
every time it takes an action which is
moving uh the agent towards the Target
right towards a goal a Target is nothing
but a goal then it is rewarded and every
time it is going in a direction where it
is away from the goal then it is
punished so that is the way you can a
little bit explain and this is used
primarily or very very impactful or
teaching the system to learn games and
so on examples of this are basically
used in alphago you can throw that as an
sample where alphaco used reinforcement
learning to actually learn to play the
game of Go and finally it defeated the
go world champion all right this much of
information that would be good enough
then there could be a question on
overfitting uh so the question could be
what is overfitting and how can you
avoid it so what is overfitting so let's
first try to understand the concept
because sometimes overfitting may be a
little difficult to understand
overfitting is a situation where the
model has kind of memorized the data so
this is an equivalent of memorizing the
data so we can draw an analogy so that
it becomes
explain this now let's say you're
teaching a child about recognizing some
fruits or something like that and you're
teaching this child about recognizing
let's say three fruits apples oranges
and pineapples okay so this is a small
child and for the first time you're
teaching the child to recognize fruits
then so what will happen so this is very
much like that is your training data set
so what you will do is you will take a
basket of fruits which consists of
apples oranges and pineapples okay and
you take this basket to this child and
there may be let's say hundreds of these
fruits so you take this basket to this
child and keep showing each of this
fruit and then first time obviously the
child will not know what it is so you
show an apple and you say hey this is
Apple then you show maybe an orange and
say this is orange and so on and so
forth and then again you keep repeating
that right so till that basket is over
this is basically how training work in
machine learning also that's how
training works so till the basket is
completed maybe 100 fruits you keep
showing this child in the process what
has happened the child has pretty much
memorized these so even before you
finish that basket right by the time you
are halfway through the child has
learned about recognizing the Apple
orange and pineapple now what will
happen after halfway through initially
you remember it made mistakes in
recognizing but halfway through now it
has learned so every time you show a
fruit it will exactly 100 accurately it
will identify it will say the child will
say this is an apple this is an orange
and if you show a pineapple it will say
this is a pineapple
Apple so that means it has kind of
memorized this data now let's say you
bring another basket of fruits and it
will have a mix of maybe apples which
were already there in the previous set
but it will also have in addition to
Apple it will probably have a banana or
maybe another fruit like a jackfruit
right so this is an equivalent of your
test data set which the child has not
seen before some parts of it it probably
has seen like the apples it has seen but
this banana and Jackfruit it has not
seen so then what will happen in the
first round which is an equivalent of
your training data set towards the end
it has 100 it was telling you what the
fruits are right Apple was accurately
recognized orange or I was accurately
recognized and pineapples were
accurately recognized right so that is
like 100 accuracy but now when you get
another a fresh set which we're not a
part of the original one what will
happen all the apples maybe it will be
able to recognize correctly but all the
others like the Jackfruit or the banana
will not be recognized by the child
right so this is an analogy this is an
equivalent of overfitting so what has
happened during the training process it
is able to recognize or reach 100
accuracy maybe very high accuracy okay
and we call that as very low loss right
so that is the technical term so the
loss is pretty much zero and accuracy is
pretty much hundred percent whereas when
you use testing there will be a huge
error which means the loss will be
pretty high and therefore the accuracy
will be also low okay this is known as
overfitting this is basically a process
where training is done training
processes it goes very well almost
reaching 100 accuracy but while testing
it really drops down now how can you
avoid it so that is the extension of
this question there are multiple ways of
avoiding overfitting there are
techniques like what you call
regularization that is the most common
technique that is used for avoiding
overfitting and within regularization
there can be a few you other subtypes
like drop out in case of neural networks
and a few other examples but I think if
you give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be
easy so so there will be some questions
where the interviewer will try to test
your fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like quick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and tests
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set in machine learning model and
how is the split done so the question
can be
so in
learning when we are trying to train the
model so we have a 3 's process we train
the model and then we test the model and
then once we are satisfied with the test
only then we deploy the model so what
happens in the train and test is that
you remember the labeled data so let's
say you have thousand records with
labeling information now one way of
doing it is you use all the Thousand
records for training and then maybe
right which means that you have exposed
all this thousand records during the
training process and then you take a
small set of the same data and then you
say okay I will test it with this okay
and then you probably what will happen
you may get some good results all right
but there is a flaw there what is the
flaw this is very similar to human
beings it is like you are showing this
model the entire data as a part of
training okay so obviously it has become
familiar with the entire data so when
you're taking a part of that again and
you are saying that I want to test it it
obviously you will get good results so
that is not a very accurate way of
testing so that is the reason what we do
is we have the label data of this
thousand records or whatever we set
aside before starting the training
process we set aside a portion of that
data and we call that test set and the
remaining we call as training set and we
use only this for training our model now
the training process remember is not
just about using one round of this data
set so let's say now your training set
has 800 records it is not just one time
you pass this 800 records what you
normally do is you actually as a part of
the training you may pass this data
through the model multiple times so this
thousand records may go through the
model maybe 10 15 20 times still the
training is perfect till the accuracy is
high till the errors are minimized okay
now so which is fine which means that
your that is what is known as the model
has seen your data and gets familiar
with your data and now when you bring
your test data what will happen is this
is like some
because that is where the real test is
now you train the model and now you are
testing the model with some data which
is kind of new that is like a situation
like a realistic situation because when
the model is deployed that is what will
happen it will receive some new data not
the data that it has already seen right
so this is a realistic test so you put
some new data so this data which you
have set aside is for the model it is
new and if it is able to accurately
predict the values that means your
training has worked okay the model got
trained properly but let's say while
you're testing this with this test data
you are getting lot of errors that means
you need to probably either change your
model or retrain with more data and
things like that now coming back to the
question of how do you split this what
should be the ratio there is no fixed uh
number again this is like individual
preferences some people split it into 50
50 test and 50 training Some people
prefer to have a larger amount for
training and a smaller amount for test
so they can go by either 60 40 or 70 30
or some people even go with some odd
numbers like 65 35 or
63.33 and 33 which is like one third and
two-thirds so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something that you has
to be this you can go by your individual
preferences all right then you may have
questions around data handling data
manipulation or
or data management or Preparation so
these are all some questions around that
area there is again no one answer one
single good answer to this it really
varies from situation to situation and
depending on what exactly is the problem
what kind of data it is how critical it
is what kind of data is missing and what
is the type of corruption so there are a
whole lot of things which is a very
generic question and therefore you need
to be little careful about responding to
this as well so probably have to
illustrate this again if you have
experience in doing this kind of work in
handling data you can illustrate with
examples saying that I was on one
project where I received this kind of
data these were the columns where data
was not filled or these were this many
rows where the data was missing that
would be in fact a perfect way to
respond to this question but if you
don't have that obviously you have to
provide some good answer I think it
really depends on what exactly the
situation is and there are multiple ways
of handling the
data or corrupt data data now let's take
a few examples now let's say you have
data where some values in some of the
columns are missing and you have pretty
much half of your data having these
missing values in terms of number of
rows okay that could be one situation
another situation could be that you have
records or data missing but when you do
some initial calculation how many
records are corrupt or how many rows or
observations as we call it has this
missing data let's assume it is very
minimal like a 10 percent okay now
between these two cases how do we so
let's assume that this is not a mission
critical situation and in order to fix
this 10 percent of the data the effort
that is required is much higher and
obviously effort means also I'm in money
right so it is not so Mission critical
and it is okay to let's say get rid of
these records so obviously one of the
easiest ways of handling the data part
or missing data is remove those records
or remove those observations from your
analysis so that is the easiest way to
do but then the downside is as I said in
as in the first case if let's say 50 of
your data is like that because some
column or the other is missing so it is
not like every in every place in every
Row the same column is missing but you
have in maybe 10 percent of the records
column one is missing and another 10
percent column two is missing another 10
percent column three is missing and so
on and so forth so it adds up to maybe
half of your data set so you cannot
completely remove half of your data set
then the whole purpose is lost okay so
then how do you handle then you need to
come up with ways of filling up this
data with some meaningful value right
that is one way of handling so when we
say meaningful value what is that
meaningful right let's say for a
particular column you might want to take
a mean value for that column and fill
wherever the data is missing fill up
with that mean value so that when you're
doing the calculations your analysis is
not completely way off so you have
values which are not missing first of
all so your system will work number two
these values are not so completely out
of whack that your whole analysis goes
from a task right there may be
situations where if the missing values
instead of putting mean may be a good
idea to uh fill it up with the minimum
value or with a zero so or with a
maximum value again as I said there are
so many possibilities so there is no
like one correct answer for this you
need to basically talk around this and
illustrate with your experience as I
said that would be the best otherwise
this is how you need to handle this
okay so then the next question can be
how can you choose a classifier based on
a training set data size so again this
is one of those questions where you
probably do not have like a
one-size-fits-all answer first of all
you may not let's say decide your
classifier based on the training set
size maybe not the best way to decide
the type of the classifier and even if
you have to there are probably some
thumb rules which we can use but then
again every time so in my opinion the
best way to respond to this question is
you need to try out few classifiers
irrespective of the size of the data and
you need to then decide on your
particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so you will never be
able to just buy if somebody defines a
problem to you and somebody even if they
show the data to you or tell you what is
the data or even the size of the data I
don't think there is a way to really say
that yes this is the classifier that
will work here no that's not the right
way so you need to still you know test
it out get the data try out a couple of
classifiers and then only you will be in
a position to decide which classifier to
use you try out multiple classifiers see
which one gives the best accuracy and
only then you can decide then you can
have a question around confusion Matrix
so the question can be explained
confusion Matrix
Matrix so confusion Matrix I think the
best way to explain it is by taking an
example and drawing like a small diagram
otherwise it can really become tricky so
my suggestion is to take a piece of pen
and paper and explain it by drawing a
small Matrix and confusion Matrix is
about to find out this is used
especially in classification learning
process and when you get the results
when the our model predicts the results
you compare it with the actual value and
try to find out what is the accuracy
okay so in this case let's say this is
an example of a confusion Matrix and it
is a binary Matrix so you have the
actual values which is the labeled data
right and which is so you have how many
yes and how many know so you have that
information and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many you
know right so the total actual values
the total yes is L plus 130 and they are
shown here and the actual value knows
are 9 plus 3 12 okay so that is what
this information here is so this is
about the actual and this is about the
predicted similarly the predicted values
there are yes are 12 plus 3 15 yeses and
no are 1 plus 9 10 nodes okay so this is
the way to look at this confusion Matrix
okay and uh out of this what is the
meaning converting so there are two or
three things that needs to be explained
out right the first thing is for a model
to be accurate the values across the
diagonal should be high like in this
case right that is one number two the
total sum of these values is equal to
the total observations in the test data
set so in this case for example you have
12 plus 3 15 plus 10 25 so that means we
have 25 observations in our test data
set okay so these are the two things you
need to First explain that the total sum
in this Matrix the numbers is equal to
the size of the test data set and the
diagonal values indicate the accuracy so
by just by looking at it you can
probably have a idea about is this an
accurate model is the model being
accurate if they're all spread out
equally in all these four boxes that
means probably the accuracy is not very
good okay now how do you calculate the
accuracy itself right how do you
calculate the accuracy itself so it is a
very simple mathematical calculation you
take some of the diagonals right so in
this case it is 9 plus 12 21 and divide
it by the total so in this case what
will it be let me take a pen so your
your diagonal values is equal if I say t
is equal to 12 plus 9 so that is 21
right and the total data set is equal to
right we just calculated it is 25 so
what is your accuracy it is 21 by your
accuracy is equal to 21 by 25 and this
turns out to be about 85 percent right
so this is 85 percent so that is our
accuracy okay so this is the way you
need to explain draw diagram Give an
example and maybe it may be a good idea
to be prepared with an example so that
it becomes easy for you you don't have
to calculate those numbers on the fly
right so a couple of hints are that you
take some numbers which are with which
add up to 100 that is always a good idea
so you don't have to really do this
complex calculations so the total value
will be 100 and then diagonal values you
divide once you find the diagonal values
that is equal to your percentage okay
all right so the next question can be a
related question about false positive
and false negative so what is false
positive and what is false negative now
once again the best way to explain this
is using a piece of paper and then
otherwise it will be pretty difficult to
so we use the same example of the
confusion Matrix
and we can explain that so A confusion
Matrix looks somewhat like this and when
we just take
somewhere like this and we continue with
the previous example where this is the
actual value this is the predicted value
and in the actual value we have 12 plus
113 yeses and 3 plus 9 12 nodes and the
predicted values there are 12 plus three
15 years and 1 plus 9 10 loss okay now
this particular case which is the false
positive what is a false positive first
of all the second word which is positive
okay is referring to the predicted value
so that means the system has predicted
it as a positive but the real value so
this is what the false comes from but
the real value is not positive okay that
is the way you should understand this
term false positive or even false
negative so false positive so positive
is what your system has predicted so
where is that system predicted this is
the one positive is what yes so you
basically consider this row okay now if
you consider this row so this is this is
all positive values this entire row is
positive values okay now the false
positive is the one which where the
value actual value is negative predicted
value is positive but the actual value
is negative so this is a false positive
right and here is a true positive so the
predicted value is positive and the
actual value is also positive okay I
hope this is making sense now let's take
a look at what is false negative false
negative so negative is the second term
that means that is the predicted value
that we need to look for so which are
the predicted negative values this row
corresponds to predicted negative values
all right so this row corresponds to
predicted negative values and what they
are asking for false so this is the row
for predicted negative values and the
actual value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is the way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify the predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive we need to
take for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative right 9 is true
negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then uh you might
have a question like what are the steps
involved in the machine learning process
or what are the three steps in the
process of developing a machine learning
model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way a you can probably answer in
your own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model
first of all you try to understand the
problem
try to figure out whether it is a
classification problem or a regression
problem based on that you select a few
algorithms and then you start the
process of training these models okay so
you can either do that or you can after
due diligence you can probably decide
that there is one particular algorithm
that which is more suitable usually it
happens through trial and error process
but at some point you will decide that
okay this is the model we are going to
use okay so in that case we have the
model algorithm and the model decided
and then you need to do the process of
training the model and testing the model
and this is where if it is supervised
learning you split your data the label
data into training data set and test
data set and you use the training data
set to train your model and then you use
the test data set to check the accuracy
whether it is working fine or not so you
test the model before you actually put
it into production right so once you
test the model you're satisfied it's
working fine then you go to the next
level which is putting it for production
and then in production obviously new
data will come and
the inference happens so the model is
readily available and only thing that
happens is new data comes and the model
predicts the values
now so this can be an iterative process
so it is not a straightforward process
where you do the training through the
testing and then you move it to
production now so during the training
and test process there may be a
situation where because of either
overfitting or things like that the test
doesn't go through which means that you
need to put that back into the training
process so that can be an iterative
process not only that even if the
training and test goes through properly
and you deploy the model in production
there can be a situation that the data
that actually comes the real data that
comes with that this model is failing so
in which case you may have to once again
go back to the drawing board or
initially it will be working fine but
over a period of time maybe due to the
change in the nature of the data once
again the accuracy will deteriorate so
that is again a recursive process so
once in a while you need to keep
checking whether the model is working
fine or not and if required you need to
tweak it and modify it and so on and so
so net net this is a continuous process
of clicking the model and testing it and
making sure it is up to date then you
might have question around deep learning
so because deep learning is now
associated with AI artificial
intelligence and so on so it can be as
simple as what is a deep learning so I
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and then obviously the
question would be then what is the
difference right so deep learning you
need to mention there are two key parts
that interviewer will be looking for
when you are defining deep learning so
first is of course deep learning is a
subset of machine learning so machine
learning is still the bigger let's say
scope and deep learning is one one part
of it so then what exactly is the
difference deep learning is primarily
when we are implementing these our
algorithms or when we are using neural
networks for doing our training and
classification and regression and all
that right so when we use neural network
then it is considered as deep learning
and the term deep comes from the fact
that you can have several layers of
neural networks and these are called
Deep neural networks and therefore the
term deep you know deep learning the
other difference between machine
learning and deep learning which the
interviewer may be wanting to hear is
that in case of machine learning the
feature engineering is done manually
what do we mean by feature engineering
basically when we are trying to train
our model we have our training data
right so we have our training label data
and this data has several let's say if
it is a regular table it has several
columns now each of these columns
actually has information about a feature
right so if we are trying to predict the
height weight and so on and so forth so
these are all features of human beings
let's say we have census data and we
have all this so those are the features
now there may be probably 50 or 100 in
some cases there may be 100 such
features now all of them do not
contribute to our model right so we as a
data scientist we have to decide whether
we should take all of them all the
features or we should throw away some of
them because again if we take all of
them number one of course your accuracy
will probably get affected but also
there is a computational part so if you
have so many teachers and then you have
so much data it becomes very tricky so
in case of machine learning we manually
take care of identifying the features
that do not contribute to the learning
process and thereby we eliminate those
features and so on right so this is
known as feature engineering and in
machine learning we do that manually
whereas in deep learning where we use
neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably will add value to your response
all right so the next question is what
is the difference between or what are
the differences between machine learning
and deep learning so here this is a
quick comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and in
machine learning learning enables
missions to take decisions on their own
based on past data so here we are
talking primarily of supervised learning
and it needs only a small amount of data
for training and then works well on low
end system so you don't need a large
machine and most features need to be
identified in advance and manually coded
so basically the feature engineering
part is done manually and the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural network so
here in deep learning we use neural line
so that is the key differentiator
between machine learning and deep
learning and usually deep learning
involves a large amount of data and
therefore the training also requires
usually the training process requires
high-end machines because it needs a lot
of computing power and the Machine
learning features are the or the feature
engineering is done automatically so the
neural networks takes care of doing the
feature engineering as well and in case
of deep learning therefore it is said
that the problem is handled end-to-end
so this is a quick comparison between
machine learning and deep learning in
case you have that kind of a question
then you might get a question around the
uses of machine learning or real life
applications of machine learning in
modern business the question may be
worded in different ways but the meaning
is how exactly is machine learning used
or actually supervised machine learning
it could be a very specific question
around supervised decision learning so
this is like give examples of supervised
machine learning use of supervised
machine learning in modern business so
that could be the next question so there
are quite a few examples or quite a few
use cases if you will for supervised
definition learning the very common one
is email spam detection so you want to
train your application or your system to
detect between spam and non-span so this
is a very common business application of
a supervised machine learning so how
does this work the way it works is that
you obviously have historical data of
your emails and they are categorized as
spam and not
spam that is what is the labeled
information and then you feed this
information or the all these emails as
an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is Spam and which is not
so that is the training process and this
is supervised machine learning because
you have labeled data you already have
emails which are tagged as spam or not
spam and then you use that to train your
model right so this is one example now
there are a few industry specific
applications for supervised machine
learning one of the very common ones is
in healthcare diagnostic in healthcare
Diagnostics you have these images and
you want to train models to detect
whether from a particular image whether
it can find out if the person is sick or
not whether a person has cancer or not
right so this is a very good example of
supervised machine learning here the way
it works is that existing images it
could be x-ray images it will be MRI or
any of these images are available and
they are saying that okay this x-ray
image is deflective of the person has an
illness or it could be cancer whichever
illness right so it is stacked as
defective or clear or good image and
Effectiveness something like that so we
come up with a binary or it could be
multi-class as well saying that this is
defective to 10 percent this is 25 and
so on but let's keep it simple you can
give an example of just a binary
classification that would be good enough
so you can say that in healthcare
Diagnostics using which we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when New
Image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer or not
right so I think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
uh
rise then so there can be a question
around semi-supervised machine learning
so what is semi-supervised machine
learning now semi-supervised learning as
the names such as it falls between
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning but for all practical purposes
it is considered as a art of supervised
learning and the reason this has come
into existence is that in supervised
learning you need labeled data so all
your data for training your model has to
be labor now this is a big problem in
many Industries or in many under many
situations getting the label data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of diagnostic images we just
let's say take X-ray images now there
are actually millions of x-ray images
available all over the world but the
problem is they are not labeled so their
images are there but whether it is
effective or whether it is good and
information is not available along with
it right in a form that it can be used
by a machine which means that somebody
has to take a look at these images and
usually it should be like a doctor and
then say that okay yes this image is
clean and this image is cancerous and so
on and so forth now that is a huge
effort by itself so this is where
semi-supervised learning comes into play
so what happens is there is a large
amount of data maybe a part of it is
labeled then we try some techniques to
label the remaining part of the data so
that we get completely labeled data and
then we train our model so I know this
is a little long winding explanation but
unfortunately there is no quick and easy
the definition for semi-supervised
machine learning this is the only way
probably to explain this concept
we may have another question as what are
unsupervised machine learning techniques
or what are some of the techniques used
for performing unsupervised machine
learning so it can be worded in
different ways so how do we answer this
question so unsupervised learning you
can say that there are two types
clustering and Association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together this is first
then Association you can I think the
best way to explain Association is with
an example in case of Association you
try to find out how the items are linked
to each other
for example if somebody bought a maybe a
laptop or the person has also purchased
a mouse so this is more in an e-commerce
scenario for example so you can give
this as an example so people who are
buying and laptops are also buying a
mouse so that means there is an
association between laptops and
people who are buying bread are also
buying butter so that is the association
that can be created so this is
unsupervised learning one of the
techniques
links all right then we have very
fundamental question what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so machine
learning these are the two main types of
machine learning supervised and
unsurvested and in case of supervised
and again here probably the key word
that the person may be wanting to hear
is labeled data now very often people
say we have historical data and if we
run it it is supervised and if we don't
have historical data yes but you may
have historical data but if it is not
labeled then you cannot use it for was
learning so it is it's very key to
understand that we put in that keyword
labeled so when we have labeled data for
training our model then we can use
supervised learning and if we do not
have labeled data then we use
unsupervised learning and there are
different algorithms available to
perform both of these
so there can be another question a
little bit more theoretical and
conceptual in nature this is about
inductive machine learning and
active machine learning the question can
be what is the difference between
inductive machine learning and deductive
machine learning or somewhat in that
manner so that the exact phrase or exact
question
three they can ask for examples and
things like that but that could be the
question so let's first understand what
is inductive and deductive training
inductive training is induced by
somebody and you can illustrate that
with a small example I think that always
helps so whenever you're doing some
explanation try as much as possible as I
said to give examples from your work
experience or give some analogies and
that will also help a lot in explaining
as well and for the interviewer also to
understand so here we'll take an example
or rather we will use an analogy so
inductive training is when we induce
some knowledge or the learning process
into a person without the person
actually experiencing it what can be an
example so we can probably tell the
person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
a fire can cause damage
right so this is inductive learning
compared to that what is deductive
learning so here you draw a conclusion
or the person draws conclusion out of
experience so we will stick to the
analogy so compared to the showing a
video Let's assume a person is allowed
to play with fire right and then he
figures out that if he puts his finger
it's burning or if draw something into
the fire it burns so he is learning
through experience so this is known as
deductive learning okay so you can have
applications or models that can be
trained using inductive learning or
deductive learning all right I think uh
probably that explains
question is are knnn and K means
clustering similar to one another or are
they same right because the letter K is
kind of common between them okay so let
us take a little while to understand
what these two are one is KNN another is
K means a KNN stands for K nearest
neighbors and K means of course is the
clustering mechanism now these two are
completely different except for the
letter K being common between them KN is
completely different K means clustering
is complete
KNN is a classification process and
therefore it comes under supervised
learning whereas k-means clustering is
actually unsupervised okay when you have
K and N and you want to implement k n n
which is basically K nearest neighbors
the value of K is a number so you can
say k is equal to 3 you want to
implement k n n with K is equal to 3 so
which means that it performs the
classification in such a way that how
does it perform the classification so it
will take three nearest objects and
that's why it's called nearest neighbor
so basically based on the distance it
will try to find out its nearest objects
that are let's say three of the nearest
objects and then it will check whether
the class they belong to which class
right so if all three belong to one
particular class obviously this new
object is also classified as that
particular
but it is possible that they may be from
two or three different classes okay so
let's say they are from two classes and
then they are from two classes now
usually you take a odd number you assign
odd number two so if there are three of
them and two of them belong to one class
and then one belongs to another class so
this new object is assigned to the class
to which the two of them belong now the
value of K is sometimes tricky whether
should you use three should you use five
should you use seven it can be tricky
because the ultimate classification can
also vary so it's possible that if
you're taking ks3 the object is probably
in one particular class but if you take
K is equal to 5 maybe the object will
belong to a different class because when
you're taking three of them probably two
of them belong to a class one and one
belong to class two whereas when you
take five of them it is possible that
only two of them belong to class one and
the three of them belong to to class 2
so which means that this object will
belong to class 2 right so you see that
so it is the class allocation can vary
depending on the value of K now K means
on the other hand is a clustering
process and it is unsupervised where
what it does is the system will
basically identify how the objects are
how close the objects are with respect
to some of their features okay and but
the similarity of course is the the
letter K and in case of K means also we
specify its value and it could be three
or five or seven there is no technical
limit as such but it can be any number
of clusters that you can create okay so
based on the value that you provide the
system will create that many clusters of
similar objects so there is a similarity
to that extent that K is a number in
both the cases but actually these two
are completely different processes
we have what is known as naive based
classifier and people often get confused
thinking that naive base is the name of
the person who found this classifier or
who developed this classifier which is
not 100 True base is the name of the
person bais is the name of the person
but naive is not the name of the person
right so naive is basically an English
word and that has been added here
because of the nature of this particular
classifier an ibase classifier is a
probability based classifier and it
makes some assumptions that presence of
one feature of a class is not related to
the presence of any other feature of
maybe other classes right so which is
not a very strong or not a very what do
you say accurate assumption because
these features can be related and so on
but even if we go with this assumption
this whole algorithm works very well
even with this assumption that is the
good side of it but the term comes from
that
the answers the explanation that you can
then there can be question around
reinforcement learning it it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using
using or it can be any game so the best
way to explain this is again to talk a
little bit about what reinforcement
learning is about and then elaborate on
that to explain the process so first of
all reinforcement learning has an
environment and an agent and the agent
is basically performing some actions in
order to achieve a certain goal and this
goals can be anything either it is
related to game then the goal could be
that you have to score very high score
value High number or it could be that
your number of lives should be as high
as possible don't lose life so this
could be some of them a more advanced
examples could be for driving the
automotive industry self-driving cars
they actually also make use of
reinforcement learning to teach the car
how to navigate through the roads and so
on and so on and so forth that is also
another example example now how does it
work so if the system is basically there
is an agent and environment and every
time the agent takes a step or performs
a task which is taking it towards the
goal the final goal let's say to
maximize the score or to minimize
on or minimize
minimize the whole it is rewarded and
every time it takes a step which goes
against that core right contrary or the
reverse Direction it is penalized okay
so it is like a character elastic
ity how do you use this to create a game
of chess so to create a system to play a
game objects now the way this works is
and this could probably go back to this
alphago example where alphaco defeated a
human child so the way it works is in
reinforcement learning the system system
is allowed for example in this case we
are talking about Chess so we allow the
system to first of all watch playing a
game of chess so it could be with a
human being or it could be the system
itself there are computer games of chess
chess right so either this new learning
system has to watch that game or watch a
human being play the game because this
is reinforcement learning is pretty much
all visual so when you're teaching the
system to play a game the system will
not actually go behind the scenes to
understand the logic of your software of
this game or anything like that it is
just visually watching the screen and
then it learns okay so reinforcement
learning to a large extent it works on
that so you need to create a mechanism
whereby your model will be able to watch
somebody playing the game and then you
allow the system also to start playing
the game so it pretty much starts from
scratch okay and as it moves forward it
it's at right at the beginning the
system really knows nothing about the
game of chess okay so initially it is a
clean slate it just starts by observing
how of your plane so it will make some
random moves and keep losing badly but
then what happens is over a period of
time so you need to now allow the system
or you need to play with the system not
just one two three four or five times
but hundreds of times thousands of times
Maybe
hundreds of thousands of times and
that's exactly how alphago has done it
played millions of games between itself
and the system right so for the game of
chess also you need to do something like
that you need to allow the system to
play chess and learn on its own over a
period of repetition so I think you can
probably explain it to this much to this
extent and I
sufficient
now this is another question which is
again somewhat similar but here the size
is not coming into picture so the
question is how will you know which
machine learning algorithm to choose for
your classification problem now this is
not only classification problem it could
be a regression problem I would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm I am going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms but now within
the classification algorithms you have
decision trees you have SPM you have
logistic regression is it possible to
outright say yes so for this particular
problem since you have explained this
now this is the exact algorithm that you
can use that is
okay so we have to try out a bunch of
algorithms see which one gives us the
best performance and best accuracy and
then decide to go with that particular
algorithm so in machine learning a lot
of it happens through trial and error
there is no real possibility that
anybody can just by looking at the
problem or understanding the problem
tell you that okay in this particular
situation this is exactly the algorithm
that you should use then the questions
may be around application of machine
learning and this question is
specifically around how Amazon is able
to recommend other things to buy so this
is around recommendation engine how does
it work how does a recommendation engine
work this is basically the question is
all about so the recommendation engine
again Works based on various inputs that
are provided obviously something like uh
you know Amazon a website or e-commerce
site like Amazon collects a lot of data
around the customer Behavior who is
purchasing what and if somebody is
buying a particular thing they're also
buying something else so this kind of
Association right so this is the
unsupervised learning we talked about
they use this to associate and Link or
relate items and that is one part of it
so they kind of build association
between items saying that somebody
buying this is also buying this that is
one part of it then they also profile
the users right based on their age their
gender their geographic location they
will do some profiling and then when
somebody is logging in and when somebody
is shopping kind of a mapping of these
two things are done they try to identify
obviously if you have logged in then
they know who you are and your
information is available like for
example your age maybe your agenda and
where you're located what you purchased
earlier right so all this is taken and
the recommendation engine basically uses
all this information and comes up with
recommendations for a particular user
user so that is how the recommendation
engine work all right then the question
can be something very basic like when
will you go for classification versus
regression right when do you do
classification instead of regression or
when will you use classification instead
of regression now yes so so this is
basically going back to the
understanding of the basics of
classification and regression so
classification is used when you have to
identify or categorize things into
discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values another is the
continuous values so for regression if
we are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if you
are trying to find some discrete values
you use classification and then you need
to illustrate what are some of the
examples so classification is like let's
say there are images and you need to put
them into classes like cat dog elephant
tiger something like that so that is a
classification problem or it can be that
is a multi-class classification problem
it could be binary classification
problem like for example whether a
customer will buy or he will not buy
that is a classification binary
classification it can be in the weather
forecast area now weather forecast is
again combination of regression and
classification because on the one hand
you want to predict whether it's going
to rain or not it's a classification
problem that's a binary classification
right whether it's going to rain or not
rain however you also have to predict
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow right now temperature is a
continuous value you can't answer the
temperature in a yes or no kind of a
response right so what will be the
temperature tomorrow so you need to give
a number which can be like 20 degrees 30
degrees or whatever right so that is
where you use regression one more
example is stock price prediction so
that is where again you will use
regression so these are the various
examples so you need to illustrate with
examples and make sure you include those
keywords like discrete and continue so
the next question is more about a little
bit of a design related question to
understand your Concepts and things like
that so it is how will you design a spam
filter so how do you basically design or
developers back so I think the main
thing here is he's looking at probably
understanding your Concept in terms of
what is the algorithm you will use or
what is your understanding about
difference between classification and
regret
and things like that right and the
process of course the methodology and
the process so the best way to go about
responding to this is we say that okay
this is a classification problem
because we want to find out whether an
email is a spam or not spam so that we
can apply the filter accordingly so
first thing is to identify what type of
a problem it is so we have identified
that it is a classification then the
second step may be to find out what kind
of algorithm to use now since this is a
binary classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as I said
earlier also we can never say that okay
for this particular problem this is
exactly the algorithm that we can use so
we can also probably try decision trees
or even support Vector machines for
example svm so we will kind of list down
a few of these algorithms and we will
say okay we want to we would like to try
out these algorithms and then we go
about taking your historical data which
is the labeled data which are marked so
you will have a bunch of emails and then
you split that into training and test
data sets you use your training data set
to train your model that or your
algorithm that you have used or rather
the model actually so and you actually
will have three models let's say you are
trying to test out three algorithms so
you will obviously have three models so
you need to try all three models and
test them out as well see which one
gives the best accuracy and then you
decide that you will go with that model
okay so training and test will be done
and then you zero in on one particular
model and then you say okay this is the
model will you use we will use and then
go ahead and Implement that or put that
in production so that is the way you
design a spam the next question is about
random Forest what is random form so
this is a very straightforward question
however the response you need to be
again a little careful while we all know
what is random Forest explaining this
can sometimes be tricky so one thing is
random Forest is kind of in one way it
is an extension of decision trees
because it is basically nothing but you
have multiple decision trees and trees
will basically
for doing if it is classification mostly
it is classification you will use the
the trees for classification and then
you use voting for finding that the
final class so that is the underlyings
but how will you explain this how will
you respond to this so first thing
obviously we will say that random Forest
is one of the algorithms and the more
important thing that you need to
probably the interviewer is is waiting
to here is Ensemble learner right so
this is one type of Ensemble learner
what is Ensemble learner Ensemble
learner is like a combination of
algorithms so it is a learner which
consists of more than one algorithm or
more than one or maybe models okay so in
case of random Forest the algorithm is
the same but instead of using one
instance of it we use multiple instances
of it and we use so in a way that is a
random Forest is an ensemble there are
other types of Ensemble Learners where
we have like reuse different algorithms
itself so you have one maybe logistic
regression and
combined together and so on and so forth
or there are other ways like for example
splitting the data in a certain way and
so on so that's all about Ensemble we
will not go into that but random Forest
itself I think the interviewer will be
happy to hear this word Ensemble
Learners and so then you go and explain
how the random Forest works so if the
random Forest is used for classification
then we use what is known as a voting
mechanism so basically how does it work
let's say your random Forest consists of
100 trees okay and each observation you
pass through this forest and each
observation let's say it is a
classification problem binary
classification zero or one and you have
100 trees now if 90 trees say that it is
a zero and ten of the trees say it is a
one you take the majority you may take a
vote and since 90 of them are saying
zero you classify this as zero then you
take the next observation and so on so
that is the way a random Forest works
for classification if it is a regression
problem it's somewhat similar but only
thing is instead of what we will do is
sorry in regression remember what
happens you actually calculate a value
right so for example you're using
regression to predict the temperature
and you have 100 trees and each tree
obviously will probably predict a
different value of the temperature they
may be close to each other but they may
not be exactly the same value so these
hundred trees so how do you now find the
actual value the output for the entire
Forest right so you have outputs of
individual trees which are a part of
this Forest but then you need to find
the final output of the forest itself so
how do you do that so in case of
regression you take like an average or
the mean of all the 100 degrees right so
this is also a way of reducing the error
so maybe if you have only one tree and
that one tree makes a header it is
basically hundred percent wrong or 100
right right but if you have on the other
hand if you have a bunch of trees you
are basically mitigating that I already
so that is the way random Forest works
so the next question is considering the
long list of machine learning algorithms
how will you decide on which one
want to so once again here there is no
way to outright say that this is the
algorithm that we will use for a given
data set this is a very good question
but then the response has to be like
again there will not be a one-size-fits
all so we need to first of all you can
probably shorten the list in terms of by
saying okay whether it is a
classification problem or it is a
regression problem to that extent you
can probably shorten the list because
you don't have to use all of them if it
is a classification problem you only can
pick from the classification algorithm
right so for example if it's a
classification you cannot use linear
regression algorithm or if it is a
regression problem you cannot use svm or
maybe now you can use svm but maybe a
logistic regression right so to that
extent you can probably shorten the list
but still you will not be able to 100
decide on saying that this is the exact
algorithm that I am going to use so the
way to go about is you choose a few
algorithms based on what the problem is
you try out your data you train some
models of these algorithms check which
one gives you the lowest error or the
highest accuracy and based on that you
choose that particular algorithm
all right then they can be questions
around bias and variants so the question
can be what is bias and variance in
machine learning uh so you just need to
give out a definition for each of these
for example a bias in machine learning
it occurs when the predicted values are
far away from the actual value so that
is the bias okay and whereas they are
all all the values are probably they are
far off but they are very near to each
other though the predicted values are
close to each other right while they are
far off from the actual value but they
are close to each other you see the
difference so that is bias and then the
other part is your variance now variance
is when the predicted values are all
over the place right so the variance is
high that means it may be close to the
Target but it is kind of very scattered
so the points the predicted values are
not close to each other right in case of
bias the predicted values are close to
each other but they are not close to the
Target but here they may be close to the
Target but they may not be close to each
other so they are a little bit more
scattered so that is what in case of a
variance okay then the next question is
about again related to bias and variance
what is the trade-off between bias and
variance yes I think this is a
interesting question because these two
are heading in different directions so
for example if you try to minimize the
bias variance will keep going high and
if you try to minimize the variance bias
will keep going high and there is no way
you can minimize both of them so you
need to have a trade-off saying that
okay this is the level at which I I will
have my bias and this is the level at
which I will have variance so the
trade-off is that pretty much uh attack
you you decide what is the level you
will tolerate for your bias and what is
the level you will tolerate for variance
and a combination of these two in such a
way that your final results are not way
off and having a trade-off will ensure
that the results are consistent right so
that is basically the output is
consistent and which means that they are
close to each other and they are also
accurate which that means they are as
close to the Target as possible right so
if either of these is high then one of
them will go off the track define
precision and Recall now again here I
think it would be best to draw a diagram
and take up in the confusion Matrix and
it is very simple the definition is like
a formula your Precision is true
positive by true positive plus false
positive and your recall is true
positive by true positive plus false
negative okay so that's you can just
show it in a mathematical way that's
pretty much a
that's the easiest way to define so the
next question can be about decision tree
what is decision tree pruning and why is
it so basically decision trees are
really simple to implement and
understand but one of the drawbacks of
decision trees is that it can become
highly complicated as it grows right and
the rules and conditions can become
it and this can also lead to overfitting
which is basically that during training
you will get 100 accuracy but when
you're doing testing you'll get a lot of
Errors so that is the reason pruning
needs to be done so the purpose or the
reason for doing decision tree pruning
is to reduce overfitting or to cut down
on overfitting and what is decision tree
pruning it is basically that you reduce
the number of branches because as you
may be aware a tree consists of the root
node and then there are several internal
nodes and then you have the leaf nodes
now if there are too many of these
internal nodes that is when you face the
problem of overfitting and pruning is
the process of reducing those internal
nodes all right so the next question can
be what is logistic regression uh so
basically logistic regression is one of
the techniques used for a performing
class application specially binary
classification now there is something
special about logistic regression and
there are a couple of things you need to
be careful about first of all the name
is a little confusing it is called
logistic regression but it is used for
classification so this can be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if it's
really
quiet and they can also ask this like a
trick question right so that is one part
second thing is the term logistic has
nothing to do with the usual Logistics
that we talk about but it is derived
from the log so that the mathematical
derivation was log and therefore the
name logistic regression so what is
logistic regression and how is it used
so logistic regression is used for
binary classification and the output of
a logistic regression is either a zero
or a one and it varies so it's basically
it calculates a probability between 0
and 1 and we can set a threshold that
can vary typically it is 0.5 so any
value above 0.5 is considered as 1 and
if the probability is below 0.5 it is
considered as zero so that is the way we
calculate the probability of the system
calculates the probability and based on
the threshold it sets a value of 0 or 1
which is like a binary classification
zero or one okay then then we have a
question around K nearest neighbor
algorithm so explain K nearest neighbor
algorithm so first of all what is the K
nearest neighbor algorithm this is a
classification algorithm so that is the
first thing we need to mention and we
also need to mention that the K is a
number it is an integer and this is
variable and we can Define what the
value of K should be it can be 2 3 5 7
and usually it is an odd number so that
is something we too much technically it
can be even number also but then
typically it would be odd number and we
will see why that is okay so based on
that we need to classify objects okay we
need to classify objects so again it
will be very helpful to draw a diagram
you know if you're explaining I think
that will be the best way so draw some
diagram like this and let's say we have
three clusters or three classes existing
and now you want to find for a new item
that has come you want to find out which
class this belongs right so you go about
as the name suggests it you go about
finding the nearest neighbors right the
points which are closest to this and how
many of them you will find that is what
is defined by K now let's say our
initial value of K was Phi okay so you
will find the K the five nearest data
points so in this case as it is
Illustrated these are the five nearest
data points but then all five do not
belong to the same class or cluster so
there are one belonging to this cluster
one the second one belonging to this
cluster two three of them belonging to
this third cluster okay so how do you
decide that's exactly the reason we
should as much as possible try to assign
an odd number so that it becomes easier
to assign this so in this case you see
that the majority actually if there are
multiple classes then you go with the
majority so since three of these items
belong to this class we assign which is
basically the in in this case the green
or the tennis or the third cluster as I
was talking
right so we assign it to this third
class so in this case it is uh that's
how it is decided okay so K nearest
neighbor so first thing is to identify
the number of neighbors that are
mentioned as K so in this case it is K
is equal to 5 so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that and and then the new data
point is assigned to that class okay so
that's pretty much how K nearest
neighbors work all right so that brings
us to the end of this module I hope you
enjoyed this interview questions and I
hope you will be able to crack your next
interview if any of these questions come
up and in case you have other questions
that you would like to be answered
please feel free to put them down below
this video in the comment section and we
will try to maybe compile all of them
and create a new video out of that okay
with that I would like to sign off thank
you very much have a good day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here